FOR COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN RISKS THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC.
AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCES
THE PATIENT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA HE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE EMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
. WE ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE- STREET
BUILDING I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE PRESENT IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR CORPSMAN BEGINNER
HEARING. LESS YOU THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO FROM
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE ON
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID AND
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY IME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU WERE USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FUTURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON YOU BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
ME WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE. YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WAS TO TESTIFY
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. AGAIN
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE HEARD
AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED. BEFORE WE BEGIN
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. SENATORS COME LONGER YOU'RE A
MOTHER HERE NIELSEN. NIELSEN
PRESENT CABALLERO ROTH ROTH HERE
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM WITH
THREE MEMBERS PRESENT. AKORN HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED TODAY THE
COMMITTEE WILL HEAR AN OVERVIEW
OF THE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
ALL ITEMS ARE FOR DISCUSSION
ONLY WE WILL NOT BE TAKING ANY
VOTE TODAY DURING THE HEARING.
THE FIRST ISSUE FOR DISCUSSION
IS TAXES AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENTS. AND ADMINISTRATION
ARE YOU HERE TO PRESENT. A YES
MANAGER CALL THE WIFE WITH
FORMER FINANCE. OKAY HIT. THANK
YOU GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS ACKLEY WHY THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE I WILL BE
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW ON
SOME OF THE MAJOR PROPOSALS
WITHIN THE TAX. ARSES AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AREA ON THE
- MY CUTTING OUT YOU ARE CUTTING
IN AND OUT. REALLY WANT TO HEAR
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY SO KEEP
SAYING KEEP AN ISSUE NOW IF I
BUT IN ITS ONLY BECAUSE- YOU
PROBABLY SAID SOMETHING REALLY
IMPORTANT WE COULDN'T HEAR YOU
BUT RIGHT NOW WE CAN HEAR YOU.
OKAY GREAT. ON THE AGENDA TODAY
THERE ARE THREE COMPONENTS THAT
COMPRISE A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
OF THE MINISTRY. RATIONS BROAD
BASED RELIEF PACKAGE. FIRST WE
HAVE EARLY PROPOSAL MADE BY THE
MINISTRATION PROVIDE BROAD BASED
RELIEF TO NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS
FACING HIGH GAS PRICES. AND%
OTHER INFLATION INDUCED PRICE
INCREASES. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
PROVIDE A ONE TIME REFUND OF
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS TO EACH
ELIGIBLE OWNER OF A REGISTERED
VEHICLE. THE PROPOSAL CAPS THE
NUMBER REBATES TO A REGISTERED
VEHICLE OWNER FOR A TOTAL OF
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
INDIVIDUAL. IT EXCLUDES FLEET
AND CORPORATE. CORPORATE ON
VEHICLES AND EXCLUDES VEHICLES.
OVER CERTAIN VALUE- THIS BROAD
BASED REFINER RETURN ESTIMATE
ELEVEN POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS BACK TO TAXPAYERS. A
SECOND PREMIER VISION ALSO
INCLUDES SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION INSTEAD OF GRANTS TO
TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE FREE TRANSIT FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR THREE MONTHS.
AND LASTLY THERE'S A PROPOSED
TWELVE MONTH PAUSE ON THE
GENERAL FUND PORTION OF THE
SALES TAX ON DIESEL FUEL. TO
HELP BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS
MITIGATE THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS
RISING FUEL PRICES- MOVING ON TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC. MY
DEVELOPMENTS- WE HAVE MULTIPLE
ISSUES THERE AND I WILL
HIGHLIGHT SEVERAL OF THE LARGER
ISSUES ON THE AGENDA. FIRSTLY
REVISION PROPOSES TO EXTEND THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM AT ITS CURRENT FUNDING
LEVEL OF ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION PER YEAR. THREE TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT SENATE
TO BUSINESSES TO LOCATE OR STAY
IN CALIFORNIA. AND CREATE
QUALITY FULL TIME JOBS IN THE
STATE. THIS PROGRAM IS SET TO
SUNSET AT THE END OF FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE- FOR THE
MAY REVISION FOR. POSES A SECOND
YOUR FUNDING IT HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES GRANT PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDES GRANTS TO
BUSINESSES THAT MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO BENEFIT FROM A NON REFUNDABLE
TAX CREDIT. AND BUT STILL
PRESENT VITAL ECONOMIC ARE EVER
CONFRATERNITIES FOR THE STATE
THAT ARE AT RISK OF TAKING PLACE
OUTSIDE THE STATE. THE MAYOR
VISION ALSO INCLUDES FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS. HARD HIT INDUSTRIES
GRANT PROGRAM. ADMINISTERED BY
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE WITHIN
GO BIZ THIS GRANT PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE. FIVE RELIEF GRANTS OF
1-000-025-0000 SMALL BUSINESSES
CAN ATTEND INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE
BEEN MOST NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. OF THE ORIGINALS
INCLUDES SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL BUSINESS DROUGHT
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE. TO PROVIDE GRANTS OF
300-005-0000 SMALL AGRICULTURAL
BUSINESSES NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
BY THE DROUGHT. THESE BUSINESSES
INCLUDE FARMERS AS WELL AS MANY
TYPES OF SUPPORT OF AGRICULTURAL
BUSINESS. THIS PROGRAM FUNCTIONS
SIMILARLY TO EXISTING COMING
NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IN
CONSULTATION WITH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. AND THEN MOVING ON
TO THE ITEMS UNDER THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD- THE FIRST ISSUE IS
THE LATE PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM OR PPP CONFORMITY. A
PREVIOUS CONFORMITY ACTION BY
THE STATE DID NOT INCLUDE
CERTAIN LATE ISSUED FEDERAL PPP
GRANTS YOU TO A FEDERAL
EXTENSION. AND THIS CHANGE WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL PPP GRANTS TO
CAL. FORTY BUSINESSES ARE
TREATED EQUITABLY I WILL NOT BE
SUBJECT TO STICK TAXATION. THE
NARRATION INCLUDES TWO
EXPANSIONS TO THE STATE'S YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT BY INDEXING THE
ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR CREDIT TO
INFLATION. AND ALLOWING ZERO
INCOME RETURNS TO CLAIM THIS
CREDIT WHICH ALLOWS MORE
FAMILIES WITH YOUNG CHILDREN TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS MEAN FOR
CREDIT AND TO PREVENT INFLATION
FROM ERODING THE VALUE OF THE
CREDIT- A REVISION ALSO INCLUDES
A ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR. A NEW ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR REFUNDABLE
CREDIT FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WOULD OTHERWISE QUALIFY FOR THE
EARNED INCOME TAX. CREDIT AND
THERE IS INCLUDES A TAXPAYER
PAYMENT FLEXIBILITY PROGRAM
WHICH WILL ALLOW TAXPAYERS.
UNDER CERTAIN INCOME LIMITS TO
PAY THEIR TAXES FOR THE
201-920-1920 TWENTY OR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TAX YEARS. BY
SEPTEMBER THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WITHOUT INCURRING ANY
INTEREST OR PENALTIES. I'VE BEEN
A REVISION INCLUDES POSITIONS
AND FUNDING FOR THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD FOR THE EXPANSIONS THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT THE NEW
FOSTER YOU THE ITC AND THE
TAXPAYER PAYMENT. FLEXIBILITY
PROGRAM THAT I JUST NOTED. IN
ADDITION THERE'S FUNDING
INCLUDED FOR THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO EXPAND ITS VOLUNTARY
INCOME TAX ASSISTANCE SERVICES
TO REIMBURSE THE DEPARTMENT YOU
SERVICES DEVELOPMENT FOR
ADMINISTRATORS IN MINISTRY TO
CALORIFIC AND TAX CREDIT GRANTS.
AND TEN MILLION IN ONGOING GRANT
FUNDING IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
FOUR. TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
TO FUND EDUCATION OUTREACH FOR
THE CALLIE ITC PROGRAM AND FREE
TAX PREPARATION SERVICES.
FURTHER AS IT RELATES TO THE I.
T. SEEN THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES. A FUNDING FOR
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO DO TARGET
OUTREACH TO PROMOTE AWARENESS OF
THE ITC. AND INCREASE ITS UPTAKE
. LASTLY UNDER A FRANCHISE TAX
FOR THERE IS A FUNDING INCLUDED
FOR DATA UPGRADES AND INCREASED
LITIGATION COSTS. ALSO THAT
INCLUDES MY HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
OF THE PROPOSALS WITHIN- THE
TAXES AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AREA I AM JOINED BY MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE PHARMA FINANCE
AS WELL AS FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
GO BIZ AND CD TFA. TO HELP WITH
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
SO NEXT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE- L.
A. O. IF YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
COMMENT. THE MANAGER A GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BRIAN
WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH OUR-
HUH- COMMENTS ON THE ISSUES THAT
ON THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE JUST
DISCUSSED WE WANTED TO PROVIDE
SOME OVERALL TAKEAWAYS OF THE
MAY REVISION. OF FEE TO KEEP IN
MIND AS YOU CONSIDER THESE
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
THE ON THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS
WOMEN THE OVERALL STRUCTURE OF
THE BUDGET. SO THE MAY REVISION
ALLOCATED FIFTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN OVERALL GENERAL FUND
SURPLUS. AND IN ADDITION WE
ESTIMATE THE GOVERNOR HAD A
THIRTY THREE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS WITHIN THE SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUDGET.
ALLOCATED DISCRETIONARY PURPOSES
. AND THERE'S THIRTY NINE
BILLION DOLLARS OF PROPOSALS
THAT MEET THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT
REQUIREMENTS. AND THE TWO
LARGEST CATEGORIES OF PROPOSALS
ARE THE ELEVEN POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX REFUNDS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION JUST
PRESENTED ON. AS WELL AS A
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY. IN THIS WE'VE
SOME SO REQUIREMENTS AND
ADDRESSED ALTHOUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION MEETS THE CELL
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FISCAL YEARS THE GOVERNOR
LEAVES. THREE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDRESS ALL
REQUIREMENTS IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY THREE IN THIS
SENSE OF THE FISCAL CLIFF IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. SO WE
ESTIMATE THE STATE WOULD FACE AN
ADDITIONAL CELL REQUIREMENT OF
OVER TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS TO
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
THE REVISION DOES NOT INCLUDE A
PLAN TO ADDRESS THIS REQUIREMENT
AS A RESULT THE STATE WOULD VERY
LIKELY FACE A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
PROBLEM NEXT YEAR. AND
COMPOUNDING THIS CONCERNS
CERTAIN ECONOMIC INDICATORS
HISTORICALLY HAVE OFFERED WITH
WARNING SIGNS THAT A RECESSION
IS ON THE HORIZON. AND MANY OF
THESE INDICATORS CURRENTLY
INDICATE S. R. SUGGEST A
HEIGHTENED RISK OF RECESSION
WITHIN TWO YEARS SO WE RECOMMEND
INCREASING RESERVES RESERVES
WILL BE ESSENTIAL TO THE STATE
MAINTAINING ITS CURRENT PROGRAM.
IN LIGHT OF THE SIGNIFICANTLY
HEIGHTENED BUDGETARY RISKS THE
STATE NOW FACES AS A RESULT OF
EITHER THE REQUIREMENTS OF
SALARY POSSIBLE RECESSION SO.
TURNING NOW TO THE TAX REBATE
FOR. A PROPOSALS AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP
HAVE PROPOSED AN ALTERNATIVE
RELIEF PACKAGE OF EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. THIS BETTER FOR
FAMILIES TAX REBATE AS DESCRIBED
IN THE AGENDA HAS THREE
COMPONENTS. THE FIRST WOULD
PROVIDE AN INCOME TAX REBATE OF
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS PER TAXPAYER
PLUS TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
DEPENDENCE FOR SINGLE FILERS
EARNING OF TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND AND JOINT. FILERS
EARNING UP TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. THIS PACKAGE WOULD
ALSO PROVIDE A SUPPLEMENTAL ONE
TIME MONTHLY GRANT FOR CULVERTS
FAMILIES AND SS I. SS P.
RECEIVED. LASTLY THE LATEST TAX
PACK WOULD FINE. THE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR OTHER LIVING HEALTH
. WHO DO NOT FILE STATE INCOME
TAXES. AS YOU WE THESE
PROPOSALS- FOR- IN TAX RELIEF
ARE WE SUGGEST THAT YOU DESIGN A
PACKAGE. CONSIDERING THE
FOLLOWING FOUR ELEMENTS. FIRST
WE- WE SUGGEST LEGISLATURE
DESIGNED A PACKAGE THAT TARGETS
RELIEF TO THE GROUPS THAT IT
WANTS TO PRIORITIZE A FOR
EXAMPLE CATEGORIES OF FOCUS
COULD INCLUDE THOSE EXPERIENCING
HIGHER FUEL PRICES THOSE
EXPERIENCING THE GREATEST
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP OR RESIDENTS
WHO ARE BROADLY AFFECTED BY
HIGHER PRICED- WE SUGGEST YOU
DESIGN A PACKAGE THAT COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY. THE SPEED AT WHICH
EACH POLICY OPTION COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED WILL VARY BASED ON
FACTORS. SUCH AS WHETHER IT
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED FOR A NEW
PROGRAMMER THROUGH AN EXISTING
PROGRAM AND WE SUGGEST YOUR
PACKAGE ALIGNS WITH YOUR OTHER
POLICY AND BUDGET PRIORITIES NOW
LAST WEEK WE SUGGEST THE
LEGISLATURE DESIGNED A PACKAGE
THAT HELPS THE STATE NEEDED SELL
REQUIREMENTS SO. GIVEN THE
CONSTRAINTS IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THE LEGISLATURE WANT TO
DESIGN A RELIEF PACKAGE THAT
FOCUSES ON MEETING THE STATE'S
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE CELL.
SUCH AS SPENDING ON EXCLUDABLE
ACTIVITIES AND TAX REFUNDS. SO
TURNING TO THE- THE ITEMS UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT- I'M ON
THE CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
HARD HIT INDUSTRIES GRANT
PROGRAM. I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW IF
THE WILD RAPID ECONOMIC RELIEF
TO SMALL BUSINESSES WAS A
PRIORITY AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE ARE CONCERNED THESE
PROGRAMS HOW TO MAKE TRADE OFFS
IN TRANSPARENCY. AND OVERSIGHT
AND EFFECTIVE TARGETING THAT ARE
NO LONGER WARRANTED IN OUR
OPINION. NOW THE ECONOMY IS
LARGELY RECOVERED. AND WE
RECOMMEND- OF REJECTING THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
THE- THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
BUSINESS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
FOR THE PROPOSED HARD.
INDUSTRY'S GRANT AND REDIRECTING
THESE FUNDS FOR OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AND
SIMILARLY- WE ALSO- RECOMMEND
REJECTING SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A SIMILAR PROPOSAL.
THAT WOULD- CREATED IT WOULD
HAVE CREATED A NEW RAPID
DISPERSAL. GRANT PROGRAMMING GO
BIZ- OFFICES SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE TO MAKE GRANTS TO
SMALLER AGRICULTURAL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE AFFECTED BY DROUGHT. IN
ADDITION TO THE CONCERNS. RAISED
REGARDING OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
GRANT PROGRAMS WE NOTE. THAT
THIS PROGRAM WOULD NOT. ADDRESS
ANY OF THE UNDERLYING WATER
AVAILABILITY. ISSUES OR WATER
EFFICIENCY. AND THEN- THE- AND
CLEAN ENERGY FINANCING PROPOSAL
THIS PROPOSAL MIGHT HAVE MERIT.
ALTHOUGH WE DO HAVE SOME GENERAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
SUBSIDIZING PRIVATE ELECTRICITY
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS IS AN
APPROPRIATE ROLE FOR THE STATE
SO- THAT'S ON TOP IS TURNING TO
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. ON THE
PROPOSAL TO ADMINISTER A TAX
PAYMENT FLEXIBILITY PROGRAM
WHILE THE WELL THIS PROGRAM
COULD HAVE SOME MERIT THIS- TAX
SIMPLICITY PROGRAM WE DO NOT
FEEL THAT THE MODEST BENEFITS TO
TAXPAYERS JUSTIFY THE RELATIVELY
HIGH COSTS OF ADMINISTERING THIS
PROGRAM. IS ADMINISTERED. AS
ESTIMATED BY THE ADMINISTRATION-
AND THEN THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES A LOT OF FUNDING FOR A
REACH FOR THE CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT AND FOR TAX
PREPARATION ASSISTANCE FOR LOW
INCOME TAXPAYERS. AND THOSE
PROPOSALS HAVE MERIT IN OUR
ESTIMATION HOWEVER THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO IS PROPOSING
TO FUND A NEW PROGRAM THAT WOULD
PROACTIVELY CONTACT HOUSEHOLDS
THAT ARE IDENTIFIED AS BEING.
ELIGIBLE FOR STATE EITC BUT
CANNOT CLAIM ONE THIS IS THE
TARGETED EITC OUT REACH PROPOSAL
AND WHILE THIS. COULD SEEM LIKE
A REASONABLE PROPOSAL ON ITS
FACE BASED ON OUR PREVIOUS
ATTEMPTS BY OF THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD WE BELIEVE THIS PROGRAM
WOULD LIKELY BE HIGHLY
INEFFECTIVE. SO THAT CONCLUDES
OUR R. T. COMMENTS ON THEIR
TAXES AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PORTION OF THE AGENDA BUT- WE'RE
PREPARED TO DISCUSS RESPOND OR
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF THE OTHER
ME REVISION ITEMS THAT WE DIDN'T
SPECIFICALLY MENTION. I'LL GREAT
SO. I- BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE JUST YOU KNOW ON THE
FACE WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LIKE TO RESPOND AT LEAST TWO OF
THE OPENING SALVO I THINK MADE
BY L. A. L. AS IT RELATES TO- A
RECESSION. THAT WE SHOULD BE
EXPECTING IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS AND THE NEED TO ACTUALLY
SAVING BE MORE STRATEGIC. WELL
WE ARE WE ARE WE THIS CALL THE
WHITE PART OF THE FINANCE WE YOU
KNOW WE AGREED THAT STATES
SHOULD BE- STRATEGIC AND- AND WE
HAVE. A LOT OF OUR PROPOSED
SPENDING THAT IS IN THE BUDGET
IS ONE TIME AND- AND WE ALSO
HAVE. A LARGE AMOUNT OF RESERVES
IN THE CASE OF A YOU TO THE
RAINY DAY FUND- AS FAR AS
RECESSION SELF THAT'S- THAT'S-
A- OF SOMEONE IMPOSSIBLE TO
PREDICT WITH ANY ANY TYPE OF
PRECISION WEEK PREPARING
ECONOMIC FORECAST- THAT IS.
BASED ON. A GLOBAL- AN
INTERNATIONAL FORECASTING FIRM
AND THEN WE TRANSLATE THAT INTO
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC FIRM THAT
HAS A BROAD VARIETY OF
ASSUMPTIONS IT DOESN'T EXPECT
ESTIMATES COULD EXPLICITLY ARE
RECESSION BUT- BUT WE DO ASSUME.
FOR EXAMPLE IN OUR FORECAST WE
MAKE AN ASSUMPTION. WITH REGARD
TO- CAPITAL GAINS- DECLINE IN
TAX YOUR TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
THE CLIENTS THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
THE STOCK MARKET SO WE'VE TAKEN.
THE LATEST DATA THAT'S AVAILABLE
TO US AND MADE A FORECAST. THAT
WE FEEL IS- IS THE BEST
ESTIMATION OF A OF A FORECAST
INSTEAD YOU KNOW IT REASONABLY
CONSERVATIVE FORECAST FOR THE
STATE GOING FORWARD. OKAY THANK
YOU SAID I'M GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT THEY HAVE. ON
CALL AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL OR SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY SIX
PEOPLE. SO IF YOU HAVE ANY ISSUE
I'M HOPING TO GOODNESS THAT
SOMEONE IS ON THE LINE TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION. VICE CHAIR I'D
LIKE TO START WITH YOU DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR TO FINANCE.
PLEASE WHY IS THE- THROUGH ICE
TO TARGET. AS YOU'RE DOING I
NEED TO PROPERLY EXPLAINED SOME
OF IT. BUT MY CONCERN IS THE
STATE NEVER DOES SEEM TO GET
THINGS RIGHT EDT MOST RECENTLY
AND I'M EXPECTING A LOT OF CALLS
FROM CONSTITUENTS COMING FORWARD
THAT THEY DIDN'T GET THEIR CHECK
OR WHATEVER. BECAUSE THE FIASCOS
THAT ABSOLUTELY ALWAYS OCCUR.
WOULD IT NOT BE MORE SIMPLE JUST
TO MAKE A STANDARD ACROSS THE
BOARD REDUCTION IN THE GAS TAX
FOR A TIME CERTAIN. ANY ANY
REDUCTION TO THE TO THE GAS TAX
HAS AS A COUPLE- A COUPLE
PROBLEMS WITH IT- ONE IS THAT
YOU MAY NOT ACTUALLY SEE
POTENTIALLY ALL OF THE SAVINGS
FLOW FOR TO CONSUMERS BY. TWO AS
IT PERTAINS TO THE- THE GAS TAX
ON GASOLINE WHICH IS- PRIMARILY
AN EXCISE TAX THOSE THOSE FUNDS
ARE EARMARKED FOR A LOCAL AND
STATE TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES
AND WOULD REQUIRE MOST LIKELY
REQUIRE BACK FEELS IN ORDER TO-
IN ORDER TO MAKE THOSE FUNDS.
FUNDS HOLE SO IT'S NOT A NOT AS
- SIMPLE AS THAT AS IT SEEMS ON
ITS FACE. THANK YOU BUT I
REITERATE I'M EXPECTING A LOT OF
CALLS. IS THAT IT YES OKAY A
SENATOR ROTH. SURE I GUESS THIS
IS TO FINANCE TO ON THE SAME TAX
REBATE PROPOSAL WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE FOR- THE VEHICLE VALUE
LIMITATION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. SO FOR AT THAT
QUESTION I WILL. HELLO I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TERESA
KALBURGI. AN INCREASE TO COVER
WHAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THERE
ARE A COUPLE THINGS THAT IN THAT
BROAD BASED REALLY PROPOSAL IN
THIS REFUND- SPECIFICALLY WE
HAVE. A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT
ARE- LIMITATIONS OR PARAMETERS
THAT WOULD BE AROUND EVERY TIME
SO YOU MENTION ONE WHICH IS THAT
KIND OF A THRESHOLD VALUE- M. AS
DETERMINED BY DMV PURSUANT TO
EXISTING EVALUATION PROCESS SAYS
THERE'S ALSO- OF LIVING UP TO
PER REGISTERED VEHICLE OWNER AND
THEN THERE'S ALSO AN EXCLUSION
FOR FLEETS AND CORPORATE OWNED
VEHICLES. AND THIS IS AGAIN
TRYING TO TARGET TO THOSE- THAT-
THAT MOST NEED IT AND ALSO.
PROVIDE THAT YOU KNOW REASONABLE. PARAMETERS AND THIS IS PART OF
OUR- REMEMBER LANGUAGE THAT WE
HAVE OUT THERE AS WELL THAT
COULD OF DESCRIBE. THE
PARAMETERS FOR A PROPOSED SO
WHAT IS THE VALUE LIMITATION.
RIGHT NOW THE TRAILER BILL
DOESN'T HAVE IT LISTED- AS A
PLACE HOLDER AND WE EXPECT THAT
THAT WOULD BE PART OF THE
DISCUSSIONS AND- AND
NEGOTIATIONS ON THIS AND- THE
LEGISLATUE PROPOSAL FOR HER
REFUND AND RELIEF WELL I HOPE WE
SPENT A LITTLE TIME ON IT
BECAUSE I THINK PEOPLE ARE.
THINKING ABOUT MILLIONAIRES WHO
DRIVE TESLAS BUT YOU KNOW. OF
LOWER MIDDLE INCOME INDIVIDUALS
SO AND ALSO HAVE VERY EXPENSIVE
OF TRUCKS FOR EXAMPLE THAT THEY
USE OR ISSUE VIS THAT THEY NEED
TO HAVE IN ORDER TO MOVE. THE
FAMILY MEMBERS AROUND IN A
VARIETY OF OTHER REASONS WHY
SOMEONE MIGHT HAVE A VEHICLE
THAT SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE
PRICEY. AND MAY IN FACT
REPRESENT A FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE- NET INCOME OF
THE FAMILY INVOLVED BUT- JUST
SETTING A VALUE OF COULD HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SO I
WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE THAT WE-
SPEND A LITTLE TIME ON THAT ITEM
. WITH REGARD TO THE ONE YOUR
PAWS ON AN INCREASE IN STATE
DIESEL TAXES AYE. I'M NOT ABLE
TO TELL FROM THE ANALYSIS
EXACTLY WHAT THAT ENTAILS. OTHER
THAN THE PLAIN LANGUAGE- IN THE
ANALYSIS IS NOT EXPECTED TO
REDUCE. THE PRICE OF DIESEL AT
THE PUMP. SO THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION IT IS EXPECTED TO
REDUCE THE PRICE OF DIESEL UPON
SO THE EXAM. THE EXEMPTION IS A
GENERAL FUND EXEMPTION SALES TAX
EXEMPTION ON THE PRICE OF DIESEL
FUEL. WHICH IS EQUIVALENT TO
APPROXIMATELY 4% OF THE OF THE
PRICE OF A WITH A- 4% RATE
THAT'S APPLIED TO THE- TO THE-
TAXES TAXABLE DIESEL FUEL SALES
SO. IT SHOULD LOWER THE PRICE OF
DIESEL OUT OF FIVE BY IN THE
FULL AMOUNT. SO WHY NOT MAYBE
THIS QUESTION WAS YES. IN A
SENSE BY MY COLLEAGUE THE VICE
CHAIR BUT WHY NOT SUSPEND THE
TAX ALTOGETHER FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME SINCE THE- BOTH THE PAUSE
ON THE INCREASE AND A SUSPENSION
WOULD BOTH SEEM TO ME HAVE A- AN
IMPACT ON THE DIRECTED
TRANSPORTATION FUND ACCOUNT.
WELL THAT THE DIESEL- THE
GENERAL FUND SALES TAX ON THE
DIESEL FUEL IS- IS A DIFFERENT A
DIFFERENT ANIMAL SO TO SPEAK
AND- EXCISE TAXES ON THE- ON THE
GAS SIDE SO ARE THEY ARE THEY
ARE IS- THERE ARE EARMARKS
RELATED TO- RELATED TO THAT. THE
SALES TAX ON DIESEL FUEL THAT GO
TO THE PUBLIC RITESH ACCOUNTS
HOWEVER. IT IS SAD THE TRAILER
BILL INCLUDES A AYE BACKFILL
PROVISION THAT ENSURES THAT THE
SAME THE SAME AMOUNT WILL GO
WILL GO TO THE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNT. UNDER
CURRENT LAW OR UNDER THE
PROPOSED A UNDER THE PROPOSED A
- PAUSE FOR THE GENERAL FUND
SALES TAX FOR THIS WAS THIS WAS
SIMPLY A CHOICE THAT WAS MADE BY
THE- ADMINISTRATION TO DO IT FOR
DIESEL BUT NOT FOR GASOLINE.
WELL I'M NOT A AND BY THAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE GENERAL FUND
BACK FILL. IT WAS A CHOICE SIDE
ON THE DIESEL SIDE WE HAVE- WE
HAVE DIESEL PRICES THAT ARE THAT
ARE HIGHER THAN GASOLINE SIDE IN
AND FOR THE GAS WE MADE A
DECISION TO- TO- DO THE DO THE
REBATE PROPOSAL WHICH IS
INTENDED TO. ALLEVIATE THE- THE
PAIN AT THE PUMP FOR GAS PRICES
FOR CONSUMERS WHERE AS DIESEL
WILL BENEFIT- WILL BENEFIT TO A
LARGE EXTENT- IT WILL BENEFIT-
SMALL BUSINESSES AND BUSINESS IN
GENERAL AND THEN IT WILL BE
INDIRECTLY THAT. OKAY THANK
THANK YOU FOR THE CONSUMERS
THANK YOU FOR THE SPOTS BUT WITH
THE PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR LET
ME JUST JUMP AHEAD WITH ONE.
YOUNG OTHER THERE IS A COMMENTS
IN A QUESTION HAVING TO DO WITH
CAL COMPETES THE TAX CREDIT
EXPANSION AND GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH I SUPPORT A THOUSAND
PERCENT- HOWEVER I HAVE SAID
THIS BEFORE AND I THINK I WANT
TO SAY IT AGAIN. FIRST A COUPLE
COMMENTS YOU KNOW WE HAVE THIS
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT PROGRAM RINA- AND THE
HOUSING ALLOCATION PROCESS WHICH
REGIONS
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A PLANNING
PROCESS AND NOT A BUILDING
PROCESS IT HAS. SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT PARTICULARLY IN THE
INLAND REGIONS OF THE STATE. AND
WE HAVE THIS SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES- PROCESS AND SERIES
OF PROGRAMS THE PERIMETER AT
LEAST RESTRICT. CURRENTLY OR AND
PROPOSED TRANSPORTATION CAPACITY
PROJECTS THAT ADD VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED OR VMT. AND WE HAVE GO
BILLS WITH THE CAL COMPETES TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM AND SOME OF THE
GO BIZ. STATE MONEY HAS BEEN
DIRECTED CERTAINLY IN THE PAST
AND CONTINUES TO BE ON SOME
LEVEL. TO THE URBAN COASTAL
AREAS WHERE WHEN YOU HAVE
EXPANDED BUSINESSES OR NEW
BUSINESSES THAT ARE RECRUITED.
THE NEW WORKERS IN THOSE
BUSINESSES ARE UNABLE TO FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND THEN ARE FORCED
TO MOVE INLAND. WHETHER IT'S
INLAND CENTRAL VALLEY AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. OR OTHER
SIMILARLY SITUATED PARTS ARE
FORCED TO MOVE INLAND AND THEN
COMMUTE TO THEIR JOBS IN ORDER
TO SECURE. THE FORTY WILL
HOUSING AND SO IN THOSE INLAND
AREAS WHEN WE HAVE THOSE
WORKERS. AND BILL THAT HOUSING
THAT RINNA REQUIRES. UNDER THE
PROPOSED RULES WE ARE UNABLE TO
A HAD TRANSPORTATION CAPACITY
PROJECTS TO MOVE WORKERS FROM
THEIR HOMES TO THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE IT INCREASES. VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. SO THOSE OF THE
COMMENTS THE QUESTION IS. HAVE
WE THOUGHT ABOUT LINKING THE CAL
COMPETES AWARD PROGRAM AND THE
AWARDS THAT ARE GENERATED. THE
CERTIFICATIONS BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT THE
JURISDICTION HAS. OR WILL ENSURE
THAT IT HAS SUFFICIENT. WORKER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THESE NEW
WORKERS THAT WERE PAYING. TO
RELOCATE OR COME TO CALIFORNIA
FOR THESE JOBS I GUESS IT GOES
TO FINANCE. YES THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION I WILL I WILL DEFER
TO MY COLLEAGUES AT A CO PAYS
FOR THAT. THAT QUESTION. CENTER
THINGS THE QUESTION- IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE CURRENTLY DISCUSS I
THINK WE'D BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU OR YOUR OFFICE ON THE
PROPOSAL. WELL THANK YOU BECAUSE
IT'S A REAL PROBLEM AND I'VE FOR
IT TO BE QUITE HONEST I HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO GET ANY TRACTION.
RECENTLY THAT THE SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION OR TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY SAID THERE WILL BE NO.
NEW CAPACITY PROGRAMS. AND THAT
THAT IS A PROBLEM. BECAUSE THE
HOUSING PEOPLE ARE SAYING THERE
WILL BE MORE HOUSING. GO
BUSINESS SAYING WE'RE
ENCOURAGING MORE JOBS SO WE NEED
TO SOMEHOW COORDINATE AND THAT'S
NOT THIS IS NOT THE FORUM FOR
THIS BUT I JUST WANT TO THROW IT
OUT. WE NEED TO SOMEHOW
COORDINATOR STATE POLICIES SO
FRANKLY THAT MAKES SENSE AND
RIGHT NOW TO ME. THESE DON'T
MAKE SENSE SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SPONSORED FORWARD TO. HE WAS
SPEAKING AND WORKING WITH YOU ON
IT THANK YOU MA'AM SURE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU. SENATOR
KABIRU. I THINK- CENTER YOU JUST
OPENED UP THAT CAN OF WORMS ON
THAT ONE AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
IT- IT MAY EVEN MAKE MORE SENSE-
TO- EXAMINE WHETHER THAT
JURISDICTION IS BUILDING THE
READING NUMBERS BEFORE THEY CAN
CAN THEY CAN GET A COW COMPETES
GRANT BECAUSE- HI IT JUST SEEMS
TO ME THAT. THE SITUATION IS
EVEN WORSE THAN YOU DESCRIBED IT
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION WANTS TO
MAKE SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
ROADWAYS- THERE ARE PROHIBITED
FROM USING STATE FUNDS TO DO
THAT- BECAUSE THEY CAN'T. YOU
CAN'T USE IT TO IMPROVE-
COMMUTER TRAFFIC SO TO SPEAK AND
I AND I THINK THAT INCLUDES A
HIGHWAYS AS WELL SO EVEN EVEN
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS THAT'LL
PROTECT THE PUBLIC CANNOT BE
IMPROVED- SO- BUT I'M- MOVING ON
TO RENT ANOTHER ISSUE- I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION I WAS LOOKING
THROUGH THE DIFFERENT. THE
DIFFERENT FUNDS AND I'M NOT
SURE. I THINK I KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWER TO THIS ONE IS BUT- WHEN
WE WERE DOING THEY DIFFERENT
GRANT PROGRAMS DURING THAT- THE
WORST PART OF AT LAST YEAR
DURING THAT CORONA VIRUS
OUTBREAK- WE WERE APPROACHED BY
SMALL INDEPENDENT THEATERS TO
EAT BEING INCLUDED IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT VENUE CATEGORY
UNDER THE BUDGET. AND WE DIDN'T
WE DID NOT END UP DOING THAT WE
DID NOT CAPTURE THE REQUEST AND
I'M WONDERING AS I LOOK THROUGH
THE DIFFERENT FIND HERE- UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
HARD HIT INDUSTRY GRANT PROGRAM
THERE THERE ARE- ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT AND RECREATION BUT
IT'S NOT SPECIFIC IT DOESN'T
SPECIFICALLY CALL OUT OR EXCLUDE
SMALL INDEPENDENT THEATERS AND I
WAS WONDERING IF YOU HAD
CONSIDERED THAT. HAD MADE A
DECISION TO EITHER INCLUDE OR
NOT INCLUDE THOSE SMALL
INDEPENDENT THEATERS. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND
I'LL TURN IT BACK OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE. AT THIS CENTER THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION AGAIN- THE
UNDER SPECIFICALLY UNDER THAT
CALIFORNIA RELIEF GRANTS
PROGRAMS THE SMALL BUSINESSES-
THERE ARE ENTERTAINMENT SECTOR
BUSINESSES INCLUDED IN THAT-
HOWEVER- THE INDEPENDENT
THEATERS WOULD WOULD NOT BE I
BELIEVE THEY'RE NOT BE ELIGIBLE
ON THIS ONE- AS WELL AS THE-
LINED IN USE ONE SO I THINK
THAT- WE- WE DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER FOR YOU ON OUR- OKAY WELL
I'M GONNA ASSUME THAT. THAT-
THAT THEY'RE NOT INCLUDED IN
THAT THEY WERE EXCLUDED AS ONE
OF THE RECIPIENTS IF YOU IF YOU-
BELIEVE OTHERWISE IF YOU COULD
GET IN TOUCH AND LET US KNOW I
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF SMALL
INDEPENDENT THEATERS IN- IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA THEY COULD
THERE WERE REALLY ON THE VERGE
OF BANKRUPTCY AND SO ANYTHING WE
CAN DO I THINK TO HELP THE
MACHINE WOULD BE ADVANTAGEOUS
AND THEN- JUST- MADAM CHAIR ON
IBM. YOU KNOW IT'S ALWAYS HARD
TO LOOK IN IN THE CRYSTAL BALL
BUT- BUT I REALLY DO THINK THAT
I APPRECIATE THE L. A. O.'S
CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF THESE
FUNDS- WE INSTITUTED A NUMBER.
OF GRANT PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE
WANTED TO GET. MONEY OUT THE
DOOR AND WE THOUGHT IT WAS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT GIVEN
OUR ECONOMY- AND- I'M WONDERING
IF SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS- ARE
REALLY APPROPRIATE GIVEN THAT.
THE CHANGIN ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES IF YOU WILL AND I
THINK THE CAUTION ABOUT THE
HEIGHTENED RISK RISK OF
RECESSION WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE
COUPLE YEARS IS SOMETHING AND
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT- YOU
KNOW PEOPLE ARE REALLY FEELING
THE STRAIN OF THE HIGHER GAS
PRICES THE HIGHER THE RISK THAT
THE- INFLATION- THE UNCERTAINTY
CREATED BY- THE STOCK MARKET
IT'S I'M ASSUMING IS REACTING
TO- TO. THE WAR AND- PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED AND I THINK-
RIGHTFULLY- SCARED ABOUT THAT.
WHERE WHERE EXACTLY ARE KANEMI
IS GOING AND- THE GOOD THING IS
THAT EMPLOYMENT IS UP WAGES ARE
UP THERE SAID JUST SOME REALLY
GOOD POSITIVE STUFF BUT THE
EMPLOYMENT BEING UP AND WAGES
BEING IS NOT WHAT FILLS OUR
COFFERS. SO I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT HER A RECESSION I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT SPENDING MONEY
THAT WE IN THE LONG TERM CAN'T
SUPPORT IN SO- HOPE HOPEFULLY WE
TAKE A- TAKE THAT TO HEART. AND-
THAT THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT THIS PORTION OF THE BUDGET
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR NIELSEN. A VERY QUICK
FOLLOW UP COMMENT TO FINANCE.
THE RURAL AREAS OF CALIFORNIA DO
NOT HAVE THE ARRAY OF
ENTERTAINMENT WE HAVE OTHER
ATTRACTIONS AND LYFT SUSTAINING
AND JOYFUL THANKS. BUT THE SMALL
INDEPENDENT THEATERS I THINK
IT'S REPREHENSIBLE THAT THE
GOVERNOR OF THE FINANCE WOODFILL
PURPOSEFULLY IGNORE THEIR NEEDS
THEY ARE NOT HUGE BUT THEY'RE
SIGNIFICANT IN THESE COMMUNITIES
I WOULD PLEASE THE YOU TO TAKE
THAT BACK TO THE GOVERNOR AND TO
YOUR DIRECTORS IN FINANCE AND
LET IT KNOW THOUGH THAT THAT'S
KIND OF IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA AND
IT CAN'T BE JUST SUMMARILY
DISMISSED BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
MANY UP. OKAY THAT'S IT YES YOUR
DROP IN MIKE'S OVER THERE VICE
CHAIR. ARM SO I TO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS- FOR FINANCE THE FIRST
IS AROUND- THE TAX REBATE
PROPOSAL- AT THE VEHICLE- THREE
GREAT. SO YOU CAN YOU EXPLAIN
THIS A LITTLE MORE BECAUSE AS
I'M LISTENING TO YOU AS SENATOR
ROTH WAS ASKING QUESTIONS I WAS
THINKING- OF SO MANY DIFFERENT
KINDS OF SCENARIOS YOU HAVE
SCENARIOS WHERE FOLKS OWN CARS
THAT MAYBE THEY CAN OR CAN'T
AFFORD AND IT'S NOT OUR PLACE TO
JUDGE SOMEBODY FOR THE KIND OF
CAR THAT THEY PURCHASE BUT- IT
WAS MENTIONED THAT IT IT SOME
VEHICLES OVER A CERTAIN VALUE
WOULD BE EXCLUDED AS WELL AS-
CERTAIN AS WELL AS COMMERCIAL
CARS. SO THERE ARE FOLKS THAT DO
THAT THERE ARE FOLKS- YOU KNOW
IS IT PER FAMILY IS IT PER
HOUSEHOLD YOU KNOW SOMETHING
THAT HAVE A NUMBER OF KIDS AND
MANY OF THE KIDS HAVE CARS YOU
HAVE SOME INSTANCES WHERE YOU
KNOW FOLKS WERE DIVORCED IN MAY
BE A PARENT WHO NO LONGER LIVE
STATE PURCHASED A CAR OUT OF
STATE FOR ONE OF THE CHILDREN
THAT LIVES HERE IS THAT A
SCENARIO WHERE THAT CAR WOULD BE
EXEMPT- IS TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A
NIGHT OFF I MEAN WHERE I LIVE
GAS THE SIX DOLLARS AND FIFTY
SEVEN CENTS- YOU KNOW PER
GALLON. AND SO HOW ARE YOU CREE
HOW WOULD YOU CREATE A PROGRAM A
REBATE PROGRAM THAT IS FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH. TO TARGET. ALL OF THE
KINDS OF FOLKS THAT YOU ARE
WANTING TO RECEIVE THIS MONEY.
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS OF FOLKS
THAT HAVE CARS. NOTE THAT IN AN
ENTIRELY REGISTRY TO COLOR WITH
APARTMENT F. AND ANSWERED A LOT
OF DIFFERENT SCENARIOS AND SO
THAT THE FOUR HUNDRED DOLLAR.
RIGHT REGISTER VEHICLE WOULD BE
LINKED TO THAT REGISTERED
VEHICLE OWNER SO THEY'D B THE
LIMIT UP TO HER- REGISTERED
OWNERS OWNERS OF REGISTERED
VEHICLES- AGAIN ARE YOU KNOW WE
TRIED. BE CLEAR AND KIND OF
ENVISION THE PARAMETERS THAT
WOULD BE BUILT AROUND THIS TO BE
ABLE TO KIND OF. SHOW WHERE-
THAT CHECKS MIGHT BE EXPECTED
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE ALSO
HAVE IT AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION AS WE HAVE- SOME
SUPPORT DOLLARS A CONTRACT ALL.
THE MOTOR VEHICLE BECAUSE WE
ANTICIPATE. FOLKS WILL BE
CALLING AND ASKING ABOUT- THESE
CHECKS SO AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO KIND OF LAY OUT THE
FRAMEWORK IN THAT LANGUAGE BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT THERE ARE DIFFERENT
PARAMETERS AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT SCENARIOS
THAT COULD BE- CONTEMPLATED
HERE. YOU ALSO HAVE SCENARIOS
WHERE SOMEONE MAY HAVE A CAR AND
MAYBE THE PERSON THAT THE CAR IS
REGISTERED TO. YOU KNOW MAYBE
THEY'RE INVOLVED IN A CUSTODY
BATTLE MAYBE THERE YOU KNOW- YOU
KNOW SORT OF. A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVOR ALL CAPS IN
THE AREA SO I JUST I THINK
REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THE REALITIES
OF VEHICLE OWNERS AND HOW THEY
HAVE CARS. IN IN IN WHAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
WITH THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
AND THEN IT SAYS SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THREE
MONTHS OF FREE TRANSIT SERVICE
SO IS THAT EVERY SINGLE PERSON
IS GETTING ACCESS TO THREE
MONTHS OF FREE TRANSIT SERVICES
IT IN CERTAIN REGIONS IS IT UP
TO A CERTAIN DOLLAR AMOUNT. IS
IT. DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH MONEY
I MEAN WHAT IS THAT. YEAH AND
THAT'S BEING THEM AND THE
TRANSPORTATION AREA AS OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEES BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
THROUGH THE LOCAL TRANSIT
AGENCIES SO THEY WOULD HAVE TO
OPT INTO THIS PROGRAM WE WOULD
HAVE A GRANT THAT'S BASED ON THE
NUMBER TO TWENTY NINETEEN AFTER
BOX REVENUES AND IN EXCHANGE FOR
THE GRANT THEY WOULD PROVIDE
THAT THREE MONTHS OF FREE
TRANSIT TO THEIR TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS SO IT'S NOT TO A
PERSON IT'S THROUGH THAT TRANSIT
AGENCIES. I SEE AND SO THEN BACK
TO THE CARS WHO WOULD ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAM WHO ACTUALLY WOULD
BE SENDING OUT THE CHECKS. DO
RIGHT NOW AS PART OF A REVISION
PROPOSAL WE HAVE IT BUDGETED AS
PART OF WITH A CONTRACT AND THEN
ALSO- ENVISIONING THAT M. DMB
WOULD HAVE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
RELATED TO I GET CALLS INQUIRIES
RELATED TO THOSE SO RIGHT NOW
THAT IS BUDGETED AND PROPOSED AS
PART OF THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES BUT AGAIN A THIRD A
THIRD PARTY CONTRACTOR IS
ENVISIONED. TO HELP WITH THAT.
IN YOUR CALCULATING THE FEES
THAT THEY WOULD CHARGE TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM. YEAH THE
MADE IT BASED ON OTHER
DEPARTMENTS- EXPERIENCES AND
THEN FOR THE PORT SIDE FOR YOU
CAN BE USED- SUPPORT AND ALLEN
DOLLARS WERE LOOKING AND THEY
HAVE LOOKED AT ME LIKE THE
EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS KIND OF A-
A MODEL IN THE FRAMEWORK SO
THESE ARE OUR- BEST ESTIMATES OF
WORK WITHIN CONTRACT
EXPENDITURES AT THIS TIME. OKAY
I'M MOVING ON TO THE HARDEST HIT
INDUSTRIES GRANTS I IT IN HERE
IT DOES MENTION- WHO THE
ELIGIBLE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS COULD BE A THE
CRITERIA BUT IT'S BASED ON
FEDERAL CODES AND SO I THINK THE
ASSUMPTION IS THAT HARDEST HIT
INDUSTRIES NATIONALLY MAY MAKE
THE HARDEST HIT INDUSTRIES IN
CALIFORNIA. IS. THAT A FAIR
ASSESSMENT THAT WE SHOULD BE
MAKING. I TAKE THAT IN AT BRIAN
RUTLEDGE BUDGET OFFICE.
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I JUST TO
CLARIFY THAT WERE USING THE
FEDERAL CODES. BECAUSE THEY'RE-
THEY'RE USED- WOULD YOU APPLY
FOR YOUR TAXES BURKE FOR MOST
BUSINESSES JUST SORT OF A I
CONVENIENCE THING. WHAT DID THE
DATA THAT WE'RE USING TO
IDENTIFY THE INDUSTRY'S THAT'S
BASED ON IN CALIFORNIA. SO THESE
WERE THE TEN HARDEST HIT
INDUSTRIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- FROM FROM THE COBIT.
IMPACTS WELL I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT THE TIME THAT I HAVE SERVED
ON THIS COMMITTEE WHEN WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT- PARALLELS BETWEEN
FEDERAL AND STATE AND COMPLIANCE
ISSUES. CONVENIENCE IS NOT
ALWAYS THE BEST BAROMETER FOR
WHAT MAKES SENSE FOR CALIFORNIA-
SO I JUST WANT TO SORT OF. LAY
THAT OUT THERE BUT THEN ALSO YOU
KNOW OUT REACH AND HOW THESE
ENTITIES WOULD APPLY TO GET THIS
MONEY. IS DO YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ON THAT OUR THOUGHTS
. YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- WELL WE'LL KNOW THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS FOCUSED ON
ON EQUITY INCLUSION HERE. CALLOW
IS VA IN PARTICULAR NOT JUST
WITH THIS PROPOSED PROGRAM BUT
WITH OUR EXISTING PROGRAMS. SO
THE WAY THAT THE HARD HIT
INDUSTRIES WOULD WORK IN TERMS
OF MAXIMIZING AWARENESS
MAXIMIZING- INCLUSIVITY OF YOU
KNOW A SMALL BUSINESS THAT MIGHT
NOT HAVE. THE RESOURCES I IN MY
NEEDS SOME HELP IDENTIFYING THIS
AND APPLYING THE WAY WE'RE
WORKING TO ADDRESS THAT IS.
THROUGH THE CODE RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM THAT CURRENTLY IS EXIST
WE BUILT OUT A NETWORK OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
NONPROFITS AND IT'S BASICALLY A
STATEWIDE NETWORK THAT HAS
GOTTEN BETTER OVER THE TWO YEARS
THAT WE'VE NOW DONE DISCOVERED
RELIEF GRANTS. SO WE WOULD
LEVERAGE THAT EXISTING NETWORK
TO- TO GET THE WORD OUT. THAT
THAT INCLUDES WE'D ALSO DO
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES FOR THE MEDIA
CAMPAIGNS- SO WE SO WE DO HAVE A
PLAN FOR MAXIMIZING. AWARENESS
AND GETTING EVERYONE- APPLYING
THAT THAT. COULD POTENTIALLY
APPLY HERE. I'M JUST HOPING AS
YOU ALL ARE DUSTING OFF THESE
PLANS THAT YOU'RE ALSO TWEAKING
THEM BECAUSE WE'VE ALSO HEARD
DURING COVE IT THAT THERE ARE SO
MANY COMMUNITIES AND BUSINESSES
THAT WERE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
RESOURCES THAT WERE BEING
PROVIDED BY THE STATE- AND WE
DON'T WANT TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THAT. REPEATED I MEAN WE HAVE
THIS HUGE SURPLUS AND FOLKS ARE
GOING TO BE LIKE WHERE'S THE
MONEY AND HOW DO I GET IT INTO
FOR STILL USING THE SAME OLD
PLAYBOOKS. WE'RE GONNA BE IN FOR
A LOT OF DISGRUNTLED FOLKS
LEGITIMATELY SO. DOES THAT MAKE
SENSE. YEAH WELL WILL KNOWLEDGE
THE POINT AND SAY THAT. IT HAS
BEEN A LEARNING A LEARNING CURVE
FOR- CAL OCA AND OUR PARTNERS AS
WE SORT OF. HAD THAT
UNPRECEDENTED PROGRAM AT AN
UNPRECEDENTED SCALE- WE WOULD
SAY THOUGH THAT. WE'VE WE'VE
GOTTEN BETTER- AND WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THAT NETWORK WE'VE NOW
BUILT OUT- THE PRACTICE- YOU
KNOW STANDARDIZING READING-
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES AND MEDIA
CAMPAIGNS. THAT SORT OF THING IS
GOING TO BE HELPFUL. FOR THIS
PURPOSE PROGRAM SO- THE
KNOWLEDGE IT- THE POINT. THANK
YOU SO THE L. A. O. SAID WE
SHOULD FLAT OUT REJECT THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL AGRICULTURAL
BUSINESS DROUGHT RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM. MY QUESTION IS HM HOW
WAS THIS FUNDING AMOUNTS SIZED
N. B. HOW IS THIRTY THOUSAND TO
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS GOING TO
HELP. A FARM DEALING WITH.
SEVERE DROUGHT ISSUES I DON'T
KNOW MUCH ABOUT FARMING BUT FROM
THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD WITH
FOLKS WHO REPRESENT FARMERS THAT
WOULDN'T GO VERY FAR. THANK YOU
FOR BOTH THOSE QUESTIONS WE AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE QUESTIONS THAT
WE GRAPPLED WITH. DESIGN THE
PROGRAM. FIRST ONE IN TERMS OF
SIZE THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
REPRESENTS WHAT WE THINK. IT'S
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO STRIKE A
REASONABLE BALANCE BETWEEN
AVAILABLE RESOURCES WHICH- THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS FOCUSED ON
FISCAL RESILIENCY. NOT JUST IN
THE IMMEDIATE BUDGET YEAR BUT IN
THE OUT YEARS. AND SO SEVENTY
FIVE WAS A WHITE COULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE HERE BUT ALSO MAKE AN
ACTUAL IMPACT SO SEVENTY FIVE.
WERE PRIORITIZING FOR THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO FOCUS
ON THE SACRAMENTO AND SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. I AS A PRIORITY
IN TERMS OF APPLICANTS SO WE
THINK IF. A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF THE SEVENTY FIVE WHEN OUT
SPECIFICALLY IN THAT REGION THAT
WOULD MAKE A DRAMATIC IMPACT AND
WHAT- WITH OUR CONVERSATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS- HAS BEEN CLEARLY
ONE OF THE HARDEST HIT PLACES.
SO THAT THAT HELPS GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF THE SIZE. IN TERMS OF
THE ACTUAL GRANTS AMOUNTS AND
HOW WE THINK THIS MIGHT MAKE AN
IMPACT. WE WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THIRTY THE GRANT SIZES ARE
THIRTY FORTY AND FIFTY THOUSAND.
WE THINK THAT'S GOING HAVE. AN
ACTUAL INJECTION THAT HELPS.
FINANCIAL OPERATIONS FOR THE
STRUGGLING BUSINESSES WE'RE NOT
SAYING WE DON'T HAVE THE
IMPRESSION THAT IT'S GOING TO
COMPLETELY ERASE- WHATEVER
REVENUE YOU MIGHT HAVE LOST
THAT'S- THAT'S CERTAINLY NOT THE
GOAL OR- WE DON'T HAVE THAT
ILLUSION- WE WILL KNOW THOUGH
THAT THE SIZES OF GRANTS ARE
LARGER THAN WITH THE COVERT
RELEASED GRANT PROGRAM. THE
SPECIFIC REASON FOR THE LARGER
GRANT AMOUNTS IS WE DESIGNED
THEM SO THAT GIVEN THE SCALE OF
AGRICULTURE. I EVEN IF YOU ONLY
HAVE TWENTY THIRTY FORTY FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES YOUR CASH FLOW
YEAH IT IS POTENTIALLY GOING TO
BE LARGER THAN A SMALL RETAILER
OR SOMETHING IN A DOWNTOWN.
ENVIRONMENT SO THE SCALE OF THE
BUSINESSES IS REQUIRES A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF A CASH INJECTION TO
MAKE AN IMPACT. THAT'S WHY WE
WORK WITH THESE AMOUNTS- BUT OF
COURSE WE NEED A BALANCED
AGAINST THE FACT THAT THE STATE
CAN'T- FULLY FIND ALL ALL
POSSIBLE LOSSES. WELL YOU'RE IN
LUCK BECAUSE THAT QUESTION
TRIGGERED A QUESTION FROM VICE
CHAIR NIELSEN. SURE YOU ARE
TALKING TO A FORMER. AND THIS IS
ALMOST INSULTING WHY BOTHER. THE
DISPLACED AGRICULTURAL LANDS AND
CROPS ARE GOING TO BE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF TWENTY AT THE
MINIMUM THE 80% OF CROPS NOT
PLANTED BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
WATER BECAUSE OF THE DROUGHT.
HELLO INTERJECTED MOTHER
THOUGHT. TO THAT EFFECT. THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE ALMOST
NOTHING TO EXPEDITE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF SITES RESERVOIR
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE WATER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AGRICULTURAL AND
DOMESTIC USE- TYPICALLY
ENVIRONMENTAL AND AGRICULTURE SO
YOU'RE IGNORING SUPPLY. BUT NOW
IN THIS DROUGHT WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER ONE SOON I
DON'T SEE THIS ADMINISTRATION
LOOKING FORWARD ANYWAY. AND
THESE SMALL FARMS. CUTTING OFF
THAT MUCH REVENUE DOESN'T JUST
CUT OFF THAT REVENUE TO THE
FARMER IT CUT OUT JOBS TO FORMER
EMPLOYEES. IT CUTS OUT INCOME
THAT WILL SUSTAIN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES I WOULD SUBMIT TAKE
THAT BACK TO YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
SUGGEST THAT WE NEED TO REVISIT
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU. I AND I
JUST ONE OH SORRY YES PLEASE.
BUDGET JUST GONNA KNOW THAT YES
I CAN TAKE THOSE FROM INSPECTOR
PROJECT THAT. THANK YOU AND I
JUST WANNA ADD THAT I THINK THAT
THERE ARE FARMS THAT ARE DEALING
WITH ISSUES. INCLUDING THE
DROUGHT BUT ALSO WITH ADDITIONAL
ISSUES TO AND SO I MEAN I WOULD
THINK THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME
SMALL FARMS THAT AID MAKE NOT BE
IN SACRAMENTO OR IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY THAT ARE DEALING
WITH OTHER ISSUES. THAT WOULD
ALSO BE REALLY DESIROUS OF
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY
FOR GRANTS SO. ON THE SECOND
THING IS. THE- MOVING INTO I
HAVE SO MANY QUESTIONS BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME- I'M
GONNA JUMP TO THIS- TAXPAYER
FLEXIBILITY PAYMENT PROGRAM-
THIS THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADMINISTER- AND I'VE IF I RECALL
WE ACTUALLY HAD A HEARING ON
THIS AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THIS- BEFORE AND WE HAD HEARD
THAT WHAT WE WERE DOING IN THE
PAST WAS NOT WORKING. AND SO
VERY CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT IS SO
DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS. THANK YOU
ALL DEFERRED TO MY COLLEAGUE-
JEANNIE HERMAN IN FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD AFTER. GET AFTERNOON
CHENEY HERMAN- FRANCHISE TOP FOR
COULD YOU CLARIFY- FOR ME SO I
CAN ANSWER YOUR QUESTION WHAT
WAS NOT WORKING. AND THEN I'LL
JUMP INTO THE YES YES- OUTREACH
CONNECTING TO LOWER INCOME
FILERS AND NON FILERS MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE GIVING THEM THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
APPLY THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO GET
WHAT IS DUE TO THEM I'D RECALL
WE HAD A LARGE DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THIS WAS HIGHLY
INEFFECTIVE. AND SO NOW THIS
PROPOSAL IS ASKING FOR THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS
TO DO SOMETHING THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY NOT BE THAT. LIKE A
LITTLE CLARITY. BUT IT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT CLARITY VERY
HELPFUL SO THAT PAYMENT BUT TO
PROGRAM IT IS IT IS COSTED OUT
THIRTY MILLION AS YOU CAN SEE
WITH THE PROPOSAL THAT'S
PRESENTED. SO THIS IS- A PROGRAM
THAT'S REACHING OUT AND OR
IMPACTING ABOUT AN ESTIMATED
THREE MILLION TAXPAYERS. SO AND
NOT AS WINDY INTO THE INCREASED
COSTS THAT YOU'RE SEEN SO NOT
TOO MANY OF THOSE TAXPAYERS-
HAVE PAID THEIR DEBTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE- PENALTIES. FEES AND
INTEREST THAT WILL BE SUBJECT TO
WAIVER AND FTP. WILL BE ISSUING
REFUNDS AUTOMATICALLY THIS
TAXPAYERS SO THAT REALLY WON'T
BE ANY OUT REACH OTHER THAN THAT
THEY'RE GETTING- SOME FORM OF
NOTIFICATION AND A DEBIT CARD OR
A CHECK. OR A DIRECT DEPOSIT
INTO THEIR- BANK ACCOUNTS WITH
THIS. SOME OF THOSE FOLKS ARE
GOING TO CALL AND THEY'RE GOING
TO SAY WHAT HAPPENED HOW TO
CALCULATE THE SIX OTHER. AND
SUCH WITH THE STOCK BECAUSE FOR.
AND THEN THE OTHER NO INTO. ARE
TYPICALLY GOING TO BE THOSE THAT
ARE CURRENTLY. INSTALLMENT
AGREEMENT FOR SOME SORT OF A
COLLECTION ACTIVITY BUT
OTHERWISE HAVE A DEBT IN
EXISTENCE WITH THE FRANCHISE
TALKSPORT. DOT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED ENGAGE A TO ENGAGE IN ONE
ON ONE WITH THEM ONCE THEY
CONTACT US TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO FULLY PAY-
POLICE SAY THAT TAX DEBT OVER
THE YEAR PERIOD WHICH IS THE-
THE REASON THIS PROGRAM IS IN
EXISTENCE AND ALLOWING FOR THE
BASEMENT OF THOSE OTHER COST. SO
YOU'RE ALSO REFERRING TO ANOTHER
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE BEFORE YOU
WHICH IS THE OUT REACH FULL TO
THE KELLY AGENCY GRANTS I'M
SORRY TAXPAYERS AND IT IS
ASSUMING THAT OF SHOULD BE WILL
REACH OUT TO YOU I GET ABOUT TWO
MILLION TAXPAYERS. SOME THAT ARE
FILED WITH US BUT NOT CLAIM THE
EITC CREDIT AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
NOT FILED WITH US BUT
pINFORMATION WE HAVE AVAILABLE
SUGGESTS THEY MAY ACTUALLY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE CREDIT- YOU ARE
CORRECT WE NEED TO SHOW THAT
CONCERN WHEN YOU LOOK ACROSS THE
NATION NOT JUST WHAT THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD OUT REACH.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK ACROSS THE
NATION- IT MANY ENTITIES THE
IRS- OTHER STATE ENTITIES OTHER
SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAMS THAT
REACH OUT TO THESE FOLKS TO TRY
TO GET THEM ADDITIONAL BENEFITS
THAT THEY MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR.
THE RESPONSE RATE IS FAIRLY LOW
SO WE'VE ESTIMATED ABOUT A 5%
RESPONSE RATE- FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS OF THE TEN MILLION
WE WOULD EXPECT MAYBE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO ACTUALLY COME IN.
AND TAKE US UP ON- AN OFFER TO
WORK TOGETHER TO EITHER GET IT
RETURNED FALL FOR THE FIRST TIME
OR TO RESPOND WITH AN AMENDED
RETURN SO THAT YET- AND MADE A
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS BACK INTO
THE- THEIR HANDS SO THAT THEY
CAN- COVER SOME EXPENSES. THEY
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE. SO
WHAT HAPPENS TO AN IN. WHO IS
CURRENT ON A PAYMENT PROGRAM.
SECOND QUESTION THANKS FOR THAT
SO- IF THEY ARE CURRENTLY ON AN
INSTALLMENT AGREEMENT WITH
FRENCH OR SOMETHING FOR THEM TO
AND THEY ARE ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE AND THE PAYMENT
FLEXIBILITY PLAN. THEN IF THEY
ARE ON A PAYMENT PLAN THAT- IS
LESS THAN OR EQUAL TO A YEAR
OKAY JUST KEEP ON CARRYING ON
ALL THINGS ARE GOING TO BE GOOD
ENOUGH TO BE IT'S GOING TO
UPDATE. THE RELEVANT INTEREST
PENALTIES AND FEES AND THEN THEY
WILL SUCCESSFULLY PAY OFF THEIR
DEBT ASSUMING THEY CONTINUE ON
AS THEIR AGREEMENT INDICATES
THEY WELL- IF THIRD INSTALLMENT
AGREEMENT WITH A SIXTY THREE
YEAR PERIOD- FOR EXAMPLE FOR TWO
MONTHS EIGHTEEN MONTHS- TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS. THOSE FOLKS ARE
GOING TO NEED TO REACH OUT TO
US- AT THEIR DISCRETION. IN
ORDER TO RENEGOTIATE THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO ACTUALLY AFFORD-
THAT ACCELERATION OF THE
PAYMENTS. SO THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE. OF THE PROGRAM WHICH IS
ABOUT A YEAR. TO BE ABLE BE
SENDING ABOUT THREE NOTE TO THE
CENTRE. TELLING THEM ABOUT THE
PROGRAM TELLING THE PARAMETERS
OF THE PROGRAM WHAT THEY CAN DO
TO HELP- THEMSELVES HOW THEY CAN
REACH OUT TO US SO THAT WE CAN
GET GOING ON- EITHER A
MODIFICATION TO THEIR
INSTALLMENT ARRANGEMENT OR EVEN
BETTER YET PERHAPS AND
ESTABLISHMENT OF A FIRST TIME
AND SMALLER RANGE RIGHT. AS WELL
. OKAY AND SO THE ADMINISTRATION
COSTS FOR THIS PROGRAM WOULD BE
ROUGHLY THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARS- EVEN THOUGH
THE PROGRAM RESULTS IN ABOUT
ONLY A HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
AND FIND FEE FORGIVENESS. SO YES
SO THE COSTS OVER THREE YEARS
ONE BECAUSE OF COURSE THE
PROGRAM AT THIS POINT OVERLAPS
TWO FISCAL YEARS- AND THERE'S
GOING TO BE- RAMPING UP AND THEN
THERE'S GOING TO BE RAMPING DOWN
AND SOME. REMAIN TO WORK
ASSOCIATED WITH DOCTORS REGIONAL
PLUS PROGRAM SAYING HEY I MISS
IT OR WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO NOW
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO NEED TO
ADDRESS SO. THERE IS A THREE
YEAR PERIOD- THAT WE'RE LOOKING
TO COVER TO MAKE SURE THAT
RESOURCES BUT YOU CAN SEE BASED
ON THE PROPOSAL THAT COSTS ARE
SEVERELY- OR SIGNIFICANTLY SKEWS
ME LASSEN NOT THIRD YEAR. THEN
THEY ARE IN ON THE FIRST YEAR
FOR SURE IN THE SECOND
ADDITIONALLY ENOUGH THIRD HERE
THERE IS SOME WORK LEFT TO BE
HOT SINCE THE LATE IN ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE THIS PROGRAM. IN THE
FIRST AND SECOND YEAR SO SOME OF
THOSE COSTS PARTICULARLY FOR
TECHNOLOGY STOCKS IN YEAR THREE
ARE DOING NOT WORK THAT WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO DO BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO PUT IT ON HOLD BUT IT IS WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. SO THE
ADDITIONAL STUFF FOR THOUGHT AND
THAT DOES SUPPORT THE FULL
PROGRAM OVER THE LIFE WHICH IS
ESTIMATED TO BE ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MILLION- ELIMINATION
OF FEES. PENALTIES AND INTEREST
. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. I AM
TEMPORARY TAPPED OUT OF THIS SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ISSUE WHICH IS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS. SO
WOULD THE ADMINISTRATION LIKE TO
PRESENT. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE AND
YOUR MARCH OUT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I'LL BE
WRITING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE-
THE MAY REVISION- HOUSING
HOMELESS THE PROPOSAL. SO
OVERALL THE MAYORS AND
REPRESENTS A ONE POINT ONE FIVE
BILLION GENERAL FUND INCREASE
FROM THE GOVERNOR PROJECT
PROBABLY AN HOMELESSNESS OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD- SPECIFICALLY
FOR HOUSING. AND THEIR VISION
INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND OVER TWO
YEARS FOR ADAPTIVE REUSE TO
CONVERT EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
UNDER UTILIZE RETAIL. AND
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS INTO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. FOR HOW MUCH
THAT THE MAYOR HAS BEEN INCLUDED
UNDER FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. FOR ADDITIONAL HOME KEY
GRANTS BRINGING THE TOTAL HUNKY
FUNDING TO THREE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION SINCE THE. BEGAN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
ADDITIONAL VERIFY HUNDRED NINE
ONE TIME. FUND OVER TO YEARS TO
HOUSE UNTIL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY IN CAMP ON STATE
OWNED LAND. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR INTER OUSING
AND BANCORPORATION ON STATE
LOCAL OR PRIVATE LAND. LEAVING
FROM HOUSING PLACEMENTS WILL
PROVIDE BRIDGE HOUSING FOR
UNSHELTERED INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN
BE TRANSITIONED INTO LONG TERM
HOUSING PLACE. ADDITIONALLY THE
MAYOR VERSION INCLUDES TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR. FOR THE ESTIMATED
COST TO REPAIR THE GENERAL FUND
COSTS ALONE WHICH IS AUTHORIZED
IN SB ONE FIFTEEN AFTER ELIGIBLE
STATE AND LOCAL EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM APPLICATION.
THAT WERE RECEIVED BY MARCH
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
WELL ACTUALLY AFTER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING. THE MAYOR IS AN
INCLUDES SEVERAL- AYE. THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE DEPARTMENT
INCLUDING LIMITED TERM RESOURCES
TO CREATE A COMMUNITY CONFLICT
RESOLUTION AND CONCILIATION
TEAM. IDENTIFY AND PROVIDE
CONCILIATION SERVICES TO
COMMUNITIES AFFECTED BY HATE
INCIDENTS OR OTHER
DISCRIMINATION. ADMINISTRATIVE
RESOURCES FOR THAT COMMISSION ON
THE STATE OF HATE AS IF THAT WAS
BY AB ONE ONE ONE TWO SIX IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
ADDITIONALLY AND LASTLY- THE
MAYOR WAS IN PROPOSES STATUTORY
CHANGES TO RENAME THE AT THE AGE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS
APARTMENT TO BETTER REFLECT THE
DEPARTMENT EXISTING ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. I'M ALSO
JOINED BY MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
ETT HI FI H. AND IF YOU. TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU MR MARC NOW
WE HERE FROM L. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON SANDERS I'M NEW TO THIS
ONE ON THIS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THE NEW
REMISSION PROPOSAL IS THE NUMBER
OF NEW HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
INITIATIVES WELL CONTINUED STATE
FUNDING TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING AFFORDABILITY IS A
REASONABLE GIVEN THE SCALE OF
THESE CHALLENGES IN THE STATE.
THERE MAY BE OPPORTUNITIES TO
LEVERAGE EXISTING PROGRAMS TO
KEEP PROGRAM EFFICIENCIES
IMPROVE PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION
IN PARTICULAR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED TO
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND ITS JANUARY
PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH A DOCTOR
MAY USE PROGRAM WITH AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR A TOTAL
OF SIX HUNDRED MILLION. OVER
THREE YEARS. FURTHERMORE THE MAY
REVISION WAS A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS FOR THE
INCOME HOUSING ON STATE OWNED
LAND THIS IN ADDITION TO THE
STATE ACCESS I PROPOSAL FROM
JANUARY WHICH OPPOSES ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO
YEARS FOR PERMANENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON STATE LAND. IN BOTH
CASES MAKING EXISTING PROGRAMS
SUCH AS HOME HE IN THE STATE
LANDS PROGRAMS MORE FLEXIBLE
COULD ACHIEVE THE PURPOSE IS
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL REDUCING THE NEED TO CREATE
NEW PROGRAMS. ADDITIONALLY THE
MEROVINGIAN PROPOSES FUNDING FOR
STATE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS UNDER. THE
FILE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
INSTEAD APPROPRIATE ALL OF THE
FUNDS THIS YEAR YOU WILL FIND
FOR X. COLLUDED. HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS PURPOSES. ARE YOU
THIS WAY TO LET- THE STATE CUT
TO LABOR ITS DESIRE TO OF FUN
TOWARDS. WHILE ALLOW. THE STATE
TO SORT OF READ BENEFITS
OVERRULED YEARS. I'M MORE OVER-
MOREOVER SHOULD HAVE GIVEN TO
THE MOUNTING SIGNS THAT THE
ECONOMY IS APPROACHING THE PEAK
OF ITS CURRENT EXPANSION
EXPANSIONARY CYCLE. ELAINE
INFUSION OF THESE FISCAL
RESOURCES TO WIN CONDITIONS
MAYBE HAVE SOFTENED COULD
ENHANCE THE BENEFITS OF THESE ON
IF YOU'RE NOT FUNDS OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS. FINALLY DEUTSCHE
FOR ANY AUTHORIZED HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING SECOND THE
LEGISLATURE SPEC CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS AND ESTABLISH
METRICS TO ASSESS PERFORMANCE
THIS WOULD HELP FACILITY
OVERSIGHT OF THE STATE'S
PROGRESS TOWARD ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. AND DEVELOPING
HOUSING THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
ITEM. LIKE TO BRING IT TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE VICE
CHAIR NIELSEN DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. HERE YET AGAIN. IS
A- MISSION AGREED JUST SO
MISSION OF THE NEEDS OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION. ALL THE
DESCRIPTION OVER THE DECADES HAS
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING SHELTER.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. BUT
ALMOST NEVER DO I HEAR ANY
DISCUSSION OF HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THE PROBLEMS THAT INDUCE AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS HOMELESS
POPULATION. THEY HAVE NEEDS AND
WHEN YOU ARE ASKING FOR MORE
MONEY FOR SHELTER. I'M ASKING
YOU THE ADMINISTRATION WHAT ARE
YOU DOING TO THE COURT NEEDS OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS SOME NEED
TREATMENT OF MANY SORTS ARE WE
ADDRESSING THAT. SOME HAVE THE
HEALTH NEEDS ARE WE ADDRESSING
THAT. ALL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
PROVIDING SHELTER AND DIFFERENT
MEANS TO DO THAT I COMPLIMENT
YOU ON THAT BUT I REALLY THINK
IT'S AN EGREGIOUS LEFT OUT NOW
MAYBE YOU CAN SAY ALL THE OTHER%
AGENCY OTHER AGENCIES ARE TAKING
CARE OF THAT FIND THAT CONNECT
THEM FOR US SO WE KNOW THAT
SOMETHING'S HAPPENING THERE THAT
INDIVIDUALS IN THESE HOMELESS
ENCLAVES. THAT ARE BEING
ASSESSED IN SOME MANNER I'M
TALKING ABOUT I E. PIECE
INDIVIDUAL LED THE EDUCATION
PLANS IN EDUCATION YOU CALL IT
WHATEVER YOU WANT HERE BUT THE
INDIVIDUAL HOMELESS PEOPLE
INDIVIDUALS BE SURVEYED AND
THEIR NEEDS ASSESSED AND THEY BE
DIRECTED TO AS YOU PROVIDE
HOUSING BE DIRECTED TO SOME
KINDS OF FACILITIES OR
ASSISTANCE FOR THOSE OTHER MORE
IMPORTANT NEEDS THAN JUST
SHELTER. CAN SOMEONE TALK TO ME
ABOUT THAT JUST A BIT. I'M CHRIS
HILL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD
BE HAPPY TO FEEL THAT QUESTION-
THE YOUNG. THE PROPOSAL'S
MINISTRATION WORKING OVER THE
PAST COUPLE YEARS TO HELP
TREATMENT COMPONENTS AND BALL
AROUND APERAM FOR EXAMPLE GIVES
MONEY TO LOCALS FOR WRITING
EVERY PURPOSES AND THAT CAN
INCLUDE A COMPONENT TO ACTUALLY
GET PEOPLE LOOK. SERVICES IN THE
CARE THEY NEED ON ONGOING BASIS
NOT JUST HOUSING ON THE ACCOUNTS
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE ON BOTH ON
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED BUDGET YEAR IN THE
COMPONENT WE HAVE A CAREER.
THAT'S ALSO COMPREHENSIVE
PROPOSAL THAT FINDS PEOPLE IN
NEED AND PROVIDE SOME SHELTER IN
AN ONGOING SERVICES AS WELL IN
THE MINISTRATIONS ALSO
SPONSORING YOUNG THE CHARACTER
OR PROPOSAL WHICH IS GOING TO
ALSO WORK WITH PEOPLE WHO
PARTICULARLY HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ACCOUNT TO PROVIDE NON.
TARGETED ASSISTANCE UNDER OF. HI
PLAN. AND ALSO TO- CANCEL FIND
SHELTER FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS AS
WELL SO WE ARE HARD TO THE NEED
FOR BOTH CARE AND SHELTER AND
I'M MORE PROPOSED OUR ONGOING
PROPOSALS AND OUR PROPOSED
PROPOSALS ONGOING PROGRAMS OR
PROPOSALS ALL SEEKS TO. ACHIEVE
THOSE GOALS WELL MOST OF THESE
NEEDS WILL BE PROVIDED FOR BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT NOT STATE
GOVERNMENT SO WILL MONIES BE
DIRECTED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR
THESE PURPOSES IN THESE PROGRAMS
YOU KNOW SIR. YES THESE PROGRAMS
ARE ALL GRANT FROM THE STATE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE OF
COURSE AS YOU KNOW THE LOCALS
ARE BOOTS ON THE GROUND WERE
WRITING CARE OKAY- IF YOU'D BE
SO KIND THE TO GET A RECITATION
OF THE THOSE THE ASSERTION TO
JUST GIVEN ME SO WE CAN LOOK
INTO A LITTLE MORE IN DEPTH
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE LOST IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE BUDGET AND IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL. TO FOCUS ON A LITTLE
BIT THANK YOU. THANK YOU S. ROTH
. THANK YOU THANK YOU MEDICARE'S
BEAT MY HAND UP BUT I DO HAVE A-
I JUST WANT TO GET SOME CLARITY
AND READING THE ANALYSIS THAT
INDICATES THE- INSPIRATIONS
COMMITTEE DO X. EXTENDING
HAPPENED CURRENT LEVELS FOR
ADDITIONAL YEARS BEYOND
202-320-2020 TWO TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE. I MEAN DO I READ
THAT TO SUGGESTED OF COURSE
GIVEN. AN APPROPRIATE CONDITION
OF THE GENERAL FUND BUDGET THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS IN YEARS BEYOND TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. YES WE ARE
COMMITTED TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO- LOOK INTO THE
POSSIBILITY OF FUNDING- HELP ON
ON GOING BASIS AND THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT IS- SUBJECT TO
NEGOTIATION OF COURSE BUT NOW
I'M- LOOKING AT THE POSSIBILITY
PROVIDING. RESOURCES BEYOND THE-
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THE PARTICULAR EMPHASIS ON
TRYING TO PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR
PROGRAMS SUCH AS HOME HEATING
WHICH JOHN HAS A- OKAY GOOGLE
THE SHELTERS AND THEN THERE'S AN
ONGOING NEED TO FOR A LAUGH BUT
HERE. IN SERVICES FOR THE PEOPLE
AND DOES. NOT HOUSING SO LOOKING
AT WAYS TO LEVERAGE ANY
POTENTIAL FUTURE HOW FUNDING TO
MEET ONGOING NEEDS. SO WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION LEGISLATURE.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE COURT
PROPOSAL- IS FAIRLY RECENT AND
THESE OTHER PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN.
ONGOING ALTHOUGH THERE'S SOME
FUNDING AUGMENTATION MAYBE I'VE
MISSED IT IS THERE ADDITIONAL
SPECIFIC CARE COURT FUNDING
PROPOSED TO DEAL WITH HOUSING
ISSUES AND REQUIREMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT PROGRAM-
ASSUMING THE PROBABILITY THAT
THE OTHER HOUSING MONEY TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT HAS ROLLED OUT.
HAS SORT OF BEEN COMMITTED.
ENCUMBERED WHATEVER BY OTHER
HOUSING NEEDS IN THESE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IF THAT QUESTION
MAKES SENSE. THE ON- THERE ARE
NO FUNDS PROPOSED IN THE
REVISION CARE CORK AIRPORT IS-
OF PUZZLES THE LEGISLATION IS
GOING TO BE A POLICY THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW. AND I THINK THAT-
ONCE I CAN. I DIDN'T SPEAK THERE
ARE THERE ARE SOME FUNDING TO
POST IN OUR- HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AREA- I DON'T HAVE A
DOLLAR COUNTY FRONT OF ME- BUT-
THERE'S ALSO SOMEBODY PROPOSING
JUDICIARY BUDGET ON BOTH OF THE
COR CAR. THE ON FOUR SO. STAR UP
COSTS FOR THE PROGRAM CREDIT
DON'T HAVE THOSE NUMBERS BECAUSE
US OUTSIDE OF MY UNITS POLICY
AREA BUT- SO THIS IS THE SENATE
FRAMEWORK YOUR COURT AND ON THE
ONGOING COSTS. THE TERM AND- YOU
KNOW ONCE THE FRIEND OF THE
PROGRAM'S LEGISLATION SPOUSES.
PROGRAMS PUT INTO PLACE RIGHT
AND I LISTEN I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE OTHER COMPONENTS OF THIS
AND- AND AS I RECALL AND I DON'T
RECALL THE SPECIFICS EITHER
THERE WAS A THIRTY SOMETHING
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE- REVISION
FOR THE COURT SYSTEM FOR CARE
COURT AS I RECALL IF I'M
CORRECT. AND THEY'RE PROBABLY
SOME WERE SOME OTHER COMPONENTS
THAT WERE DEALT WITH IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE BUDGET BUDGET THE
ONLY REASON I MENTION IT. IS
CARE CORD IS REFERENCED IN OUR
ANALYSIS UNDER. THE UNDER THE
HELP PROGRAM. IF MY POINT IS
THIS. THERE'S SOME HOUSING
COMPONENTS OF THE CARE COURT
PROGRAM AS I UNDERSTAND IT. AND
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO ADDRESS
THOSE HOUSING COMPONENTS
SEPARATELY FROM THESE OTHER.
THESE OTHER HOUSING- ELEMENTS.
THEY WERE DEALING WITH TODAY
UNDER THIS ITEM ZERO FIVE ONE
FIVE. AND IT'S PROBABLY GOING TO
HAVE TO GO BEYOND THE EXISTING
FUNDING LEVELS IN THESE OTHER
PROGRAMS JUST BECAUSE THE NEED
IS GREAT AND WE'RE ADDING.
ADDITIONAL NEED WITH THE CARE
COURT PROGRAM. SO I. THINK
THAT'S ALL I NEED TO SAY MANAGER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR HELP IN
YOUR RESPONSE OR- THANK YOU
SENATOR OUT OF EUROPE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR- SO LET ME
LET ME JUST- START- YOU KNOW WHO
. HOUSING HAS BEEN IF YOU ASK
THE PUBLIC WHAT THE ISSUE IS
THAT THEY'RE MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT IT IT'S BEEN HOUSING FOR
MANY YEARS- AND- MMHM. IT'S
ALMOST UNIVERSAL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
AND THE LACK OF HOUSING IS A
CRITICAL ISSUE I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS THAT WE'VE
HAD ON HOUSING BUT BUT I ALSO
ANA I'M I'M I'VE BEEN CONCERNED
. ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ABOUT- BEST PRACTICES I THINK IS
THE BEST WAY TO PUT IT- AND PART
OF THE CHALLENGE ABOUT UNIT
REPRESENTING SIX COUNTIES I GOT
A CALL SIX COUNTIES AND FIND OUT
WHAT WHAT THEY DID WITH THEIR
HAPPEN THERE HE FINDS AND- AND
IT IT'S DIFFERENT AND I WONDER
IF WE HAVE SOME MODELS OUT THERE
THAT THAT ARE ARE MORE EFFICIENT
MORE EFFECTIVE IN REALLY
ACTUALLY GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREET SO I'M WONDERING IF WE
HAVE- WE STARTED TO ASK FOR SOME
SOME DATA BUT- BUT I'M WONDERING
IF WE HAVE ANYTHING THAT
EVALUATES THE SUCCESS OF THE
PROGRAM'S AND MIGHT CONCERN IS
THAT- WE HEARD A BILL RECENTLY
ABOUT THE HOUSING FIRST PROGRAM.
TO MAKE SOME MODIFICATIONS TO
THAT AND I THINK THERE'S SOME
THERE MAY BE SOME INTEREST LONG
TERM TO LOOKING AT OTHER
STRATEGIES AND OTHER MODELS
THAT- THAT THAT CAN WORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE HOUSING
FIRST BUT I'M WONDERING FIRST OF
ALL DO WE HAVE ANYTHING THAT AND
I'M LOOKING AT THE HOMELESS
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM WHICH IS A
HALF BROTHER TO CONTINUE FINDING
IT WHICH I THINK I THINK WE HAVE
TO DO- DO WE HAVE IS AB AB
SYSTEM TO EVALUATE THE SUCCESS
OF THE PROGRAM. AND- AND IS
THERE. YES THE OTHER PART OF IT
IS THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT EVERY THAT THERE IS IT'S
CLEAR THAT THIS THESE ARE STATE
FUNDS THAT ARE BEING USED THIS
QUITE FRANKLY WHEN I HEAR ABOUT
A ROLL OUT OF THE PROGRAM THE
CITIES IN THE COUNTY SAID SAY
HEY WE DID A GREAT JOB PUTTING
THIS PROGRAM TOGETHER AND THEN
THEY FORGET THAT WERE PARTNERS
IN IT SO I'M WONDERING IF
THERE'S A WAY I MEAN THAT'S
IT'S- IT'S SELF SERVING IN MANY
WAYS BUT IT REALLY IS IMPORTANT
THAT. THAT THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'VE GOT TO GIVE US DATA AND
INFORMATION SO THAT WE CAN
EVALUATE WHETHER FUNDS ARE BEING
UTILIZED IN THE MOST APPROPRIATE
WHERE WHERE THEY MEET WE NEED TO
MAKE CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM. YES
THERE ARE THERE ARE DATA
REPORTING ELEMENTS REQUIRED FOR
ACCOUNTS- LOCALS- CITIES AND
COUNTIES YOU CAN USE. CONTINUES
OF CARE THEY UPLOAD DATA
REGULARLY TO THE- CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE- BUT BUT HOW
THE PROGRAMS ARE SO NEW THAT-
THERE ARE NOT ANY. REPORTS YET
OUT THERE- THAT HAVE OUTCOMES-
WERE. NASCENT STAGES OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND SAME WITH ON CAMPUS
SO- WE'RE WE'RE DEVELOPING A
DOUBT EVER GETTING DOWN ON DOWN
WE WILL HAVE INFORMATION ON ON-
OUTCOMES KELLY C. H. WE'D ALL BE
NOW BUT WE DON'T THIS EARLY
STAGE HAPPENING YEAH. WELL I
HAVE PROGRAM IT'S TRUE THAT IT'S
FAIRLY NEW BECAUSE WE I KEEP
FIRST RIGHT AND THEN HE PROGRAM-
WAS AROUND FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND SO I GUESS THAT'S WHY I KIND
OF FEEL LIKE HAPPY AS THE
OUTGROWTH OF HEAPING MAYBE MAYBE
THAT. THE DETAILS WERE DIFFERENT
SO MAYBE I'M NOT BEING FAIR
ABOUT THAT BUT IT JUST SEEMS TO
ME THAT SINCE I RETURNED TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE MADE HOUSING
A PRIORITY WHEN THESE THREE OR
FOUR YEARS NOW- I HAVEN'T SEEN
THE DATA WHEN I ASK FOR IT
LOCALLY IT'S VERY. VERY HARD TO
GET AND I'M I WORRY THAT WE'RE
RECYCLING PEOPLE THROUGH THE
PROGRAM AND THAT WE'RE NOT
GETTING THEM PERMANENTLY OFF THE
STREETS BECAUSE THE PROBLEM
ISN'T SEEM TO GET. TO GET BETTER
IN SO I'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THE
DATA OR A LOOK AT THE DASHBOARD
AND- TRY TO GET A SENSE OF THAT
BUT I REALLY DO THINK THAT- AS
MUCH MONEY AS WE'RE SPENDING ON
THIS ISSUE- AP. I HATE TO RELY
ON VIGNETTE STORIES BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T TELL US WHETHER WE'RE
DOING WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO DO
TO. MAKE A DENT IN THE PROBLEM
AND I UNDERSTAND IT'S- IT'S SOME
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. DISTINCT
ISSUES IN THE HOMELESS
POPULATION THAT ARE REALLY
DIFFERENT FROM EACH OTHER BUT I
DO THINK THAT. THAT- THERE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE IF IT IF
FOR PURCHASING PROPERTIES TO BE
ABLE TO HOME HOUSE THE HOMELESS
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PROPERTIES CAN BE MAINTAINED AND
THAT THEY CAN BE- THAT THEIR
SECURED IN A WAY THAT THAT. IT
STAYS. BUT PROPERTY AND IT
DOESN'T GO INTO THE HANDS OF
PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS THAT USE
STATE FUNDS IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO. TO BUILD SOMETHING AND THEN
NOT REALLY KEEP IT. IN THE
PUBLIC. DOMAIN AND THAT. AS WE
GET MORE SOPHISTICATED ABOUT HOW
WE- HELP PEOPLE TO LEAVE THE
STREETS THAT THERE'S A WAY FOR
THEM TO STAY. OFF THE STREETS SO
THAT WITH WITH ENDED DON'T TURN
AROUND AND DO IT SACRAMENTO DID
RECENTLY WHICH IS THEY SAID HEY
WE'RE CLOSING THIS UP WE CAN NO
LONGER MAINTAIN IT AND- PEOPLE
WERE BACK ON THE STREET AGAIN SO
THAT I GUESS THAT'S MY BIGGEST
CONCERN ABOUT THE EVALUATION AND
MAKING SURE WE'VE GOT THAT.
CONDITIONS IN PLACE TO MAIN TO
ENSURE THAT THE MONEY THEN THAT
IS BEING SPENT ON THESE.
CONVERSIONS OF MOTELS. RESULT IN
THEM BEING PART OF UP A PUBLIC.
ASSET IF YOU WILL THAT THE
COMMUNITIES HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
HOUSE PEOPLE. BECAUSE THEY DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE TO BE HOMELESS THEY
CAN BE OTHER INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND THOSE YOU KNOW
SENIORS AND- I AM CONCERNED THAT
WE MAINTAIN ALL OF THAT- SO
THAT. MISPRISION CONCERNS AND
THAT'S GREAT THAT'S WHY WE'RE
COMMITTED TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT LEVERAGING
POSSIBLE ONGOING POSSIBLE LONGER
TERM FUNDING SOURCES LIKE MAYBE
HE CAN NOW HERE'S TO HELP THOSE
UPPERS. EXTRACTS USING. THANK
YOU FOR THAT I I'M I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THE MINISTRATION IS
CONCERNED ABOUT IS WHAT CAUSED
THAT I THINK WE CAN WE CAN TAG
THAT FOR SOMETHING TO. MAYBE DO
A HEARING ON SO WERE WERE WE ALL
ARE. ON THE SAME PAGE WITH THAT
ALSO- I REALLY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- THE RESOURCES IN
THE- ADAPTIVE REUSE REUSE
CATEGORY- COULD YOU TELL ME IF
THERE'S A REQUIREMENT- PRIORITY-
FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP- OPPORTUNITIES
IN IN IN THIS PARTICULAR FIND-
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT- I'M IT'S
MY BELIEF THAT. THAT RE USING
INFILL PROPERTY. IN IN AND IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
HOUSING PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY
LOOK AT CONDO- TYPE OF-
STRUCTURES AND- IT'S- AT LEAST
NOT IN MY MIND MORE PROBABLE
THAT THOSE. PROPERTIES WOULD BE
. FOUR DOUBLE TWO PEOPLE OF
MEDIAN IT MEDIUM AND BELOW
INCOME- IT'S A WAY FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO BUILD EQUITY AND
ASSETS AND START TO DEAL WITH
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A REAL
LACK OF. HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES IN MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I'M WONDERING IF
YOU IF YOU IF THAT PARTICULAR
FUND WHICH IS A NEW FIND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT- WOULD ENVISIONED.
FOR SALE UNITS. I'LL TURN OVER
MY HOUSING COLLEAGUES FOR A DOT
. MARKS. HEY AND YOUR MARCH- I
BELIEVE THAT THE INTENT IS
GENERALLY TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT I HAVE COLLEAGUES ON
THE LINE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE- COLOR
YOUR QUESTION. SENATOR UNCLES
DID SHE GET THE CD. THERE'S NO-
EXPLICIT- DIRECTION AROUND. FOR
UP FOR SALE OR OWNERSHIP HOUSING
. W. GENERALLY THERE'S NO
EXCLUSION FOR THAT RIGHT SO
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU IN THE
RIGHT OR WITH THE JURISDICTIONS
YOU MAY ACCESS THIS FUNDING TO
THE RIGHT TYPE OF INTERVENTION.
THE ABOUT MAKING SURE WE CAN GET
SOME BENEFIT. WILSON HOUSING IN
THE PLACE USUAL IN FIRST. THAT
IS GOING ON USED OR
UNDERUTILIZED- AND REALLY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF WHAT LIKE A
DISTRESSED ASSETS AUTHOR
COMMUNITY SO CERTAINLY IF WE HAD
PROPOSALS THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE
AND FOR SALE. OPTION THAT WE
FIND IN OUR REGION- IT'S
RESIDENTIAL USES THAT WERE
LOOKING TO COME UP. VERY GOOD
WELL I WOULD I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT- THAT TO THAT. SOME
CONSIDERATION BE GIVEN TO FOR A
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN THIS CATEGORY BECAUSE
IT'S ONE OF THOSE- UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES- WHERE YOU'RE
YOU'RE TAKING PROP PROPERTY
EXACTLY AS YOU SAID THAT IS
UNDER UTILIZED AND CONVERTING IT
INTO A POTENTIALLY MIXED USER OR
CONDO KINDS OF. OF OF
DEVELOPMENT AND PROVIDING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO PURCHASE
THEIR FIRST UNIT WOULD BE-
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT THAT THE
SENATE HAS HAS REALLY FOCUSED ON
HOME OWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES-
THROUGH A FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS
PROGRAM TYPE OF DISCUSSION AND-
LIKE TO THINK THAT MAYBE WE
COULD. WE COULD ADD- ONE OF THE
CAT SUBCATEGORIES IN THIS AREA
FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
AS WELL AND MAYBE ENCOURAGE JUST
LIKE WE'VE DONE THE EIGHTY IS
ENCOURAGE- THAT THE PROGRAM TO
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE MORE
SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT SO. THAT
THAT THAT. THAT MIGHT BE A AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE JUST
COULDN'T AVOID- WE COULDN'T TURN
DOWN- AND THEN IN REGARDS TO
THIS ALSO IS FOR EACH CD. IN
REGARDS TO THE- BOTH OF THE-
WELL THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE
LISTED IN THE BUDGET ARE THESE.
THESE GRANTS THE HOMELESS
HOUSING ON STATE OWNED. LAND AND
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES INTO
THE HOME KEY FUNDING PROGRAM ARE
THOSE FIRST COME FIRST SERVE- A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM AND
THE REASON THAT I'M ASKING IS
THAT- IS IT MANY TIMES SOME OF
THE SMALLER COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE A ROBUST STAFF TO DO
GRANT WRITING HAVE A HARD TIME
ACCESSING. HOUSING FUNDS AND SO
THEY HAVE TO WAIT FOR A
DEVELOPER TO COME FORWARD IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO- CRAFT AT-
THE PROJECT AND I'M WONDERING IF
YOU IF YOU- ONE HAVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IT'S AVAILABLE OR TWO
IF THERE'S A WAY FOR- FOR
EIGHTEEN. PORTION OF THE GRANT
TO GO DUE TO. COMMUNITIES THAT
GENERALLY DON'T HAVE A HEART ARE
GENERALLY HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
ACCESSING FUNDS FOR HOUSING.
SHURIKEN GET TO THAT YOUR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE GRANT PROGRAM
HE PROPOSED PRINTER HOUSING IT
IS DESIRED TO BE INCREASED TOUCH
LOW- LOW REQUIREMENT IN TERMS OF
STAFF WORK AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND GETTING MONEY DOWN TO LOCAL
TO HELP CREATE A MORE INNER OF
HOUSING OPTIONS- AS THAT REACHED
ALL THE PERMIT HOUSING GOT
COMING ONLINE FEEL PREVIOUS
YEARS INVESTMENTS. I WILL KNOW
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
YOUR MATES OF THE PREVIOUS
QUESTIONS YES FROM THE PREVIOUS
HOUSING INVESTMENTS FROM THE
PAST- HOUSING GOING TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND OTHER SUCH WITH
LEGISLATIVE LESLIE INVESTMENTS
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN FIVE THOUSAND
UNITS CONSTRUCTED WITH THIRTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED CURRENTLY
IN CONSTRUCTION. NO TWENTY K.
PLUS A PENDING A CONSTRUCTION SO
WE ARE TRYING TO CREATE THAT
KIND OF CONTINUE ON WHILE WE
WAIT FOR ALL THAT HOUSING TO BE
BUILT IN THE STATE IS EXPECTED
FROM EACH CITY FUNDED PROGRAM.
THE NEW COUNT OTHER THINGS
HAPPENING IN THE PRIVATE MARKET.
IN THE TACKLES COURSE ALWAYS
STRIVE DO THAT FOR A LITTLE
GOVERNMENTS I KNOW THIS IS A NEW
PROPOSALS HOW TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT IT'S-
WORKS IS BEST I CAN FOR THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I KNOW THAT YOU
CAN. MAKE IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE
TO GET QUICKLY TO CREATE INNER
OF HOPPING. HE'S.
I THINK WE HAVE NOT MADE A FIRST
COME FIRST SERVE WE COULD GET
RESERVE FUNDS. FOR VARIOUS PARTS
OF THE STATE AND THEN OF COURSE
OPENED UP FUNDS AND WE'VE BEEN
PRETTY PRETTY ENCOURAGED BY. OF
COURSE THE OVER SUBSCRIPTION
WITH THIS YEAR'S FUNDING ROUNDS
SO- HOPE THAT IT'S YOUR QUESTION
- THAT IS THE INTO. OF AND YOU
PRO ON THE- SIDE PROGRAMS THE
INTERIM. I'M HAPPY THAT WORK
LIST. TO ENSURE THAT IT'S- FULL
TO SPEAK THE THREE. AND LOOKING
AT RESOURCES TO COMMUNITY. BUT
ALSO MAKING SURE WE CAN. SUPPORT
HOURS AND FORTY. THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND THAT THAT- I GUESS THAT
. THE QUESTION I WOULD- THE
ACTOR WAS FROM IS THE
SUBSCRIPTION OF GRANT GRANT. DO
YOU REOPEN THE APPLICATION
PROCESS ALL OVER AGAIN TO GET
NEW FUNDS OR DO YOU UTILIZE THE
NEW FINES FOR THOSE THAT WERE
NOT FUNDED DURING THE FIRST
GRANT CYCLE BECAUSE THEY JUST
WEREN'T READY AND I THAT'S THE
REASON FOR THAT AGAIN GETS BACK
TO THIS MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE PASSED OVER.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND IF YOU
KNOW THAT NEW FUNDS MAY HELP YOU
FINALLY GET THERE- THAT THAT'S-
WOULD GOOD NEWS TO BE ABLE TO GO
OUT TO SOME OF MY COMMUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO TELL THEM. EMBOLDENS
COROLLA YOU SEE YOUR PRODUCTIVE
USE AND FOR THOSE GRANTS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR HOUSING OR
NEW PROGRAMS SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY SORT OF- RESEARCHERS AND
THEY'RE- YOUR SUBSCRIPTION- WAS
SPEAKING TO WHAT'S ON HOKEY.
SAID SO WHAT WE WHAT WE ARE
DOING IT IS- KNOWING THAT. THIS
YEAR'S CURRENT BUDGET AND- THAT
WAS PASSED. YEAR HAVE TO. OF
FUNDING SO WE WOULD BE ABLE
HOUSING FUNDING AVAILABLE IN
JULY WHEN WE ARE NOT FORCING
FOLKS TO REAPPLY. WE AS LONG AS
I. CURRENT APPLICATION IT. NEEDS
THE PROGRAMMATIC RITUALS THEY
WILL GET FUNDED MUTUAL. FUND
UNTIL. THE NEXT BUDGET YEAR. AND
THAT THEY WILL NOT HAVE TO
REAPPLY SO NOW WE- WILL. BE ABLE
TO DEPLOY THE- AWESOME. WHAT'S
THE- PASTORS. THAT LAST YEAR- IN
ADDITIONAL AND BELIEVE- ACTUALLY
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE MORE IN
THIRTY SO WOULD WILL BUILD UPON
THE CURRENT AND THEN WILL OUT
THE NOTICE OF THE FIELD FOR
THEIR FUNDS. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SO. APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU SO
I HAVE SENATOR. AND THEN.
NIELSEN THANK CHURCH ONE OF FOR
BEHIND MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
CENTER VALLEY WHEN WAS ASKING
SOME ABOUT METRICS AND YOU KNOW
IN THINKING ABOUT THAT I'M I'M
JUST THIS I'M JUST CURIOUS- DO
DO COMMUNITIES. AND THE GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES THAT THEY SET OUT
. ON THE VARIOUS ISSUES FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE IN THAT ARE
ENCOMPASSED BY HAPPEN CAN'T
WOULD RESOLUTION HOME KEY
OPERATING SUSTAINABILITY COURT
CARE COURT HOUSING SUPPORTS AND
PROBABLY MANY OTHERS. ARE THESE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES ARE THEY
STANDARDIZED ACROSS THE BOARD
AMONG COMMUNITIES OR- DO
COMMUNITIES GENERALLY HAVE. A
DIFFERENT ISSUES AND DIFFERENT
HIGHEST PRIORITIES. AND IF THE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES ARE NOT
STANDARDIZED ACROSS COMMUNITIES
WITH RESPECT FOR EXAMPLE HAP HOW
DO WE DESIGN OF SYSTEM OF
METRICS THAT MAKE SENSE. I MEAN
I KNOW USED INDICATED YOU'RE
COLLECTING DATA BUT HOW HOW DO
YOU DESIGN A SYSTEM OF METRICS.
A GOALS AND OBJECTIVES WINS
LOSSES THAT MAKES SENSE. IF EACH
COMMUNITY GETS TO SAID IT'S HIS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE OF CALLIE
C. H. WORKS WITH THE VISION. I
UNDERSTAND A KELLY C. H. WORKING
EACH INDIVIDUAL HELP APPLICANTS
TO STRUCTURE. RAMPS FUNDING- IN
A WAY THAT BEST MEETS THEIR
NEEDS AND- IF THEY ARE- YOU'RE
NOT AVAILABLE FOR COMMENT I
WOULD DEFER TO THEM ON THAT
PARTICULAR STYLE- I SEE SO. EACH
INDIVIDUAL APPLICATION IF
AWARDED HAS A SET OF GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND THEN THE
INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES GRATED
AGAINST THE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
THAT ARE SET AT THE BEGINNING.
HELLO THIS IS JULIE LOW KELLY C.
H. I'M GONNA TRY MAN- THANKS FOR
THE QUESTION- IT'LL- LIKE THAT
ON IT THIRD ROUND OF HALF THREE
WHICH IS IN. PROCESS IN
IMPLEMENTATION CURRENTLY THERE
ARE COMMON COMPONENTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED OF THE APPLICATIONS
THAT. ARE COMPRISED OF SOME SORT
OF ASSESSMENT OF THE NEED WITHIN
THAT PARTICULAR COMMUNITY- SOME
EVIDENCE AND DATA AND NARRATIVE
AROUND HOW THOSE NEEDS WILL BE
ADDRESSED AND ALT ALL HAVE
GRANTEES. ARE REQUIRED TO SET
GOALS AROUND SIX COMMON MEASURES
THAT WE'RE REFERRING TO IS THE
SYSTEM PERFORMANCE MEASURES THE
SYSTEM PERFORMANCE MEASURES ARE-
INDICATORS OF THE TYPE OF- TIONS
. THAT RAIN FROM INTAKE OF EXTRA
HOME. THE TIMES FOR PEOPLE TO
EXIT HOMELESSNESS INTO POSITIVE
HOUSING SETTINGS AND AS WELL AS
A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT SORT OF
USUALLY TELL US. AROUND ON THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE FULL SYSTEM
SO EVERY JURISDICTION WILL HAVE
SET GOALS THAT ARE TAILORED TO
THEIR OWN. I'M RESOURCES AND
NEED- BUT THERE ARE COMMON
METRICS AS WELL AS COMMON
COMPONENTS REQUIRED WHAT IS
SPECIFIC TO EACH INDIVIDUAL
JURISDICTION. IS A WILL VERY AND
THE HAPPY IN THE CALAIS CH TEAM
IS WORKING WITH EVERY GRANTEE TO
DEVELOP THOSE APPLICATIONS AND
THOSE GOALS. FOR THE RED. RIGHT
THE REASON I ASK MICHAEL IS I'M
LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS AND
GOING BACK TO THE QUESTION I ASK
ABOUT ONGOING FUNDING- AND A
COMMITMENT TO EXTENDING THAT
WHICH I UNDERSTAND THERE IS. THE
ANALYSIS IS PENDING FURTHER
DISCUSSION WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO MEANINGFUL INCREASE OUTCOMES
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ON LOCAL HAP
SPENDING AND I'M JUST TRYING TO
GET AN IDEA WHAT SORT OF
DISCUSSION WE NEED TO BE HAVING. SO WE ARE CURRENTLY IN IN
RELATION TO THE SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE MEASURE SENTIMENT
IMPLEMENTED AROUND HALF THREE
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION PHASE. WE ARE
EAGER TO- BE ABLE TO GET THROUGH
A PERIOD SO THAT WE CAN REPORT
ON A QUARTERLY BASIS. OKAY WELL
I GUESS THAT ANSWERS MY QUESTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
RESPONSE. SENATOR NIELSEN. THANK
YOU MANAGER YOU KNOW OUR
COMMITTEES ASKING A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THE AGENCIES
DO BUSINESS AND THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT SENATE HAS
ACCEPTED. OF A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS HERE IN H. TWO D. THE
MAY REVISE INCLUDES A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE POSITIONS.
PERMANENT POSITIONS THEY WERE
ADMINISTRATIVELY CREATED. UNDER
pWHAT ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY TO
CREATE THAT MANY POSITIONS AND
THAT'S A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN P. WEISS AND TO OUR
OVERALL STATE BUDGET. THE
QUESTION IS WHY IS THIS BIG OF A
REQUEST COMING INTO THE MAY
REVISED IT WOULD SEEM THAT THE
AGENCY WOULD BEEN WELL AWARE OF
THIS AS THEY PROMULGATED THE
BUDGET THROUGH THE LATTER PART
OF LAST YEAR. IS THERE SOME
REASON THAT THIS JUST POPPED IN
RIGHT NOW. I'M JUST CURIOUS THIS
IS MORE OF PROCEDURAL QUESTION
WITHIN THE AGENCY ABOUT HOW YOU
DO YOUR BUSINESS. AND IT SEEMS
INTERESTING WHY THIS BIG REQUEST
COMES IN AT THE MAY REVISION.
SENATOR AND YOU'RE RIGHT TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGAIN-
THIRTY HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
POSITIONS WERE ADMINISTRATIVELY
ESTABLISHED- IN THE CURRENT YEAR
ON TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. TO
IMPLEMENT FUNNY NOT WITH
PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT IF YOUR CALL
THERE'S AN IMMENSE INVESTMENT IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. AND TO THE PHYSICIANS WERE
PROVIDED WERE ADMINISTRATIVELY
ESTABLISHED- USING THAT THAT
ADMINISTRATORS SATISFIED EASILY
THERE'S A 5% MINISTER. I AND
WITHOUT FUNDING. AND- THESE
PROGRAMS LAST FOR YEARS-
TYPICALLY AND- THERE'S- A LONG
TERM- AT THE MANAGEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THESE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS- SO. INTENSELY THE
PHYSICIAN ARE SOMETHING THAT
BECAUSE OF THE- THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE BUDGET LATE LAST YEAR-
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO BE
INCLUDED- WHEN THE FUNDING WAS
PASSED- SO THEY WERE
ADMINISTRATOR LAY FABLESS AND IT
WAS AN OVERSIGHT NOT TO INCLUDE
THEM IN GOVERNOR BUDGET AND THEY
WERE COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE
NOW- TO. TO HAVE THE SUGGESTED
VERSION TO BE PERMANENTLY.
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU- GREAT QUESTIONS AT I HAVE A
COUPLE SO WITH REGARDS TO THE
HOMELESSNESS HOUSING ON STATE
OWNED LAND THAT PROPOSAL.
CURIOUS IF THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS IDENTIFIED THE STATE OWNED
LAND IN QUESTION IF YOU HAVE AN
IDEA OF THE NUMBER OF FOLKS THAT
ARE HOMELESS THAT ARE. ON THE
STATE LANDS- AND IF YOU CAN GIVE
US A LITTLE CLARITY ON HOW YOU
CAME UP WITH THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT.
THERE IS A NO WIN THE DEPARTMENT
HANDLE THAT QUESTION I'D BE
HAPPY TO TAKE A SHOT AT MYSELF-
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY CURRENTLY TWO
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS- WINNING ON
STATE OWNED PROPERTIES STATE ON
LANDS. YEAH ON THE- FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR FIGURE WAS JUST
SOME OF SOME OF THOSE ARRIVED
OUT BASED ON AVAILABLE FUNDS AND
THEN- AND- THEN THE BUDGET
PRIORITY. YES YEAH AND- NO
MATHEMATICIAN TO PROVIDE A MORE
SET OF SERVICES FOR PEOPLE THREE
YEARS FOR INDIVIDUAL. UHHUH AND
SO I MEAN LIKE WHAT WOULD THIS
LOOK LIKE WOULD YOU WHAT WOULD
THIS LOOK LIKE I MEAN I THIS IS
THE SIMPLEST WAY TO ASK THE
QUESTION BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY PROGRAMS THAT WE- EITHER
HAVE SUPPORTED THAT WE HAVE
FUNDED THAT HAVE BEEN DESIGNED.
TO FOCUS ON HOW WE MOVE FOLKS
FROM BEING ON HOUSE TO HOUSE AND
THEN THEIR ADS SO. WHAT IS IT
CHRIS WOULD LIKE ME TO ADDRESS
THOSE. I THINK YEAH SO. MANY
DEPARTMENT. BILL AS I MENTIONED
RIGHT BUSINESS SUPPORTS THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- I BELIEVE YOU
KNOW I WILL WORK FOR YOU ALL BUT
I THINK THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF
DEMANDING NEED A LOOKER REPORT
IN TERMS OF IN RING HOUSING
NEEDS OFTEN FOLKS AREN'T
ENCAMPMENTS OR OR OR ON HOUSING
WORKING AND SO KNOWING THAT
WE'VE INVESTED QUITE A BIT INTO
PRODUCTION OF NEW HOUSING WE'RE
DOING. A LOT OF A HOME HERE WELL
THAT'S COMING UP VERY VERY FAST
THERE ARE STILL INTERNAL IN THE
DARK GRANTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
ORDER TO- FOLKS TO OTHER PARTS
THEIR COMMUNITY NOT HAVE TO BE A
STATE OWNED LAND FOLKS WHO ARE
ON THE HOOK ON LAND WHO MEDIA
PRIORITY BUT- TO MOVE IN WITH
THEIR COMMUNITY AB RIGHT HERE OF
HOUSING. TO ASSIST ME WHERE
NECESSARY GOVERNMENTS AND
HELPING. WITH AND SO THE COULD
TAKE THE FORM- WHATEVER MAKES
SENSE FOR THAT WILL COMMUNITY.
BUT THIS IS THE GRANT STOP KIND
OF COME IN FOR THAT INTERIMS.
THAN LOOK AT REDUCING. WELL IT
WOULD SEEM TO ME I KNOW KNOW
THAT MY ABOUT. ALL OF THE BUT IT
SEEM TO ME THAT IT MIGHT MAKE
MORE SENSE TO. CALL THIS DOLLAR
AMOUNT INTO SOME OTHER EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WORKING. AND
ALLOW. THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THE CITIES AND THE COUNTIES THAT
ARE DOING THIS WORK. TODAY IN.
THE FEED INTO THAT RATHER THAN
SORT OF. COMPARTMENTALIZE IN ALL
OF THESE CHUNKS THESE BUCKETS OF
DOLLARS. AND THEN HAVE FOLKS.
HAVE TO CHASE BUCKET AFTER
BUCKET AFTER BUCKET. BECAUSE
WHAT WE'VE ALSO TO LEARN IS
THAT. THERE'S SO MUCH BRAIDING
THAT HAPPENS. THAT I MEAN WE
WANT AND YOU KNOW THAT IT JUST
WE END UP NOT BEING ABLE TO BE
AS EFFICIENT WITH THE DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE. FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT ARE
DOING THIS WORK BECAUSE WE'VE
CREATED ALL OF THESE SEPARATE
BUCKETS. WHEN AT THE END OF THE
DAY THEY HAVE IDEAS ABOUT WHERE
FOLKS ARE WHO ARE AND HOUSE IN
THE BEST WAYS TO GET THEM HOUSE.
I MEAN YOU KNOW THEY'RE ALL
KINDS OF SOLUTIONS. THAT
DIFFERENT- JURISDICTIONS ARE-
COMING UP WITH SO. I'M THE
ADAPTIVE RE USE IS REALLY
EXCITING- NEW PROGRAM- KIND OF
QUESTIONING HOW MANY UNITS COULD
THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING CREATED
ME WHAT ARE YOU ANTICIPATING TO
HAPPEN WITH THIS. YEAH OTHERS
SAY THEY SHOULD BE I THINK IT'S
DIFFICULT TO SAY HOW MANY UNITS
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT YOUR INVESTMENT SOMETIMES
INFRASTRUCTURE SO- VERY SIMILAR
TO PROBABLY FIFTY ARE REALLY.
INTELLIGENT RESEARCHER GRANT
PROGRAMS WE OFFER ASSISTANCE
FOR- INFRASTRUCTURE PERMISSIBLE
DETAILS. SO I THINK WE'RE HERE
IS I TO- NOT READ ANYTHING
CERTAINLY LET'S TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF DISTRESS- DISTRUST ARE UNDER
LESS PROPERTIES- IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT YOU KNOW ME NOT.
WE CAN IN TERMS OF HOW MANY
UNITS IT WOULD CREATE I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY TO REALLY HELLO-
BECAUSE THESE WOULD BE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WOULD BE TO HOUSING.
TRANSFORMATIVE TYPE CATALYTIC
THINGS WITHIN. OUR COMMUNITY
BUT- WE CAN CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THIS WE WILL CERTAINLY TRY TO
MAKE. OKAY GREAT AND THE FINAL
COMMENT. AS IT RELATES TO THE
ADDITIONAL ADAPTIVE REUSE
FUNDING YOU KNOW I ACTUALLY
THINK THAT THIS IS- VERY
EXCITING- AND I WAS THINKING
ABOUT A NUMBER OF CORRIDORS
THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT- WHERE I
HAVE ALWAYS THOUGHT THERE WAS
OPPORTUNITY FOR MIXED USE TO
TURN LIGHT INDUSTRIAL OR
COMMERCIAL. INTO USE- AND ALSO
REALLY HOPING THAT THERE THAT.
THIS IS- REALLY THOUGHTFUL- AND
TARGETED BECAUSE THERE'S ALSO A
LOT OF SCURRILOUS DEVELOPERS OUT
THERE WHO WOULD SEE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU KNOW LARGE
MONEY GRABS TO DO I AM. THIS
KIND OF DEVELOPMENT I MEAN THERE
WAS AN ARTICLE JUST IN THE PAPER
I THINK LAST WEEK ABOUT A
DEVELOPER IN MY DISTRICT THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY CHANGING THE ENTIRE
LANDSCAPE. OF A OF A
NEIGHBORHOOD- AND THEY HAVE THE
COULD THESE KINDS OF DEVELOPERS
ACTUALLY HAVE THE- CAPACITY AND
THE CAPITAL TO DO THIS BUT
THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS THE ONES WITH
THE BEST INTENTIONS AT HEART
ABOUT HOW TO CREATE A REDESIGN
OR BOLSTER OR INFUSE INTO
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
THAT KIND OF DEVELOPMENT THAT
MAKES SENSE THAT. DOUBLE IT
SEEMS LIKE A REALLY GREAT IDEA
AND I KNOW MANY OF US HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ADAPTIVE RE USE-
FOR A LONG TIME AND I WOULD HOPE
THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME
ADDITIONAL THOUGHT GIVEN TO THIS
AND GUARDRAILS ABOUT LIKE WHAT
YOU ARE TRYING TO TARGET AND
WHILE YOU'RE OUT OUTCOMES WHAT
YOU WANT THE OUTCOMES TO LOOK
LIKE. BECAUSE THIS COULD HAVE
SERIOUS UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. I DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE
RUSHING TO THE MICROPHONE SO I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
GENERAL GOVERNMENT AND STATE
ADMINISTRATION. WOOD THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LIKE TO
PRESENT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BY
ONE POINT IN THE FINANCE. A
VISION INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSALS RELATED TO
GENERAL COVER. UNDER THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY THE
MAIN VISION INCLUDES FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION ON GO GENERAL FUND
AND TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE FOR THE DIGITAL
INNOVATION SERVICES REVOLVING
FUND IS FOR THE REORGANIZATION
OF THE OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION THE CALL DATA CLEAN.
IN THE OFFICE OF THE CENTER FOR
GOVERNMENT EXCELLENCE AND
TRANSFORMATION INCLUDING
RESOURCES WERE CLOSED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET APPROVED BY
THIS COMMITTEE LAST WEDNESDAY I
DO IT NEATLY TELL WHICH OFFICER
DATA IN THE NATION. THE OFFICE
OF DATA INNOVATION WILL EXIST IN
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
FOR BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TO THREE WILL BE ESTABLISHED
VEHICLE VIA TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AS A STANDALONE STATE
DEPARTMENT BEGINNING IN. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. WITH
THE OFFICE PLANNING AND RESEARCH
THE MALE VISION A- SEVENTY THREE
ONE. DOLLAR YOU FIND ON GOING
BEGINNING TWENTY TWO FOUR TWENTY
FIVE DIVIDE CLINIC FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE. SCHOOL
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM WILL WHAT
OVER THREE THOUSAND FIVE HELLO
ANNUALLY AS THEY TACKLE
STATEWIDE SHALL. RANGING CLIMATE
CHANGE THE FOOD IS READY. FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF AFFAIRS THE
MALE VISION TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND OVER THREE
YEARS THE SUPPORT THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
WHILE IMPROVED LICENSING FEE
MODEL IS DEVELOPED FOR USE BY
LICENSEES. IN PLEDGING THE NAME
OF ASIAN INCLUDES SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
BUDGET TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. IN AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE TO
SUPPORT THE COMPLETION OF THE
BROADBAND MIDDLE MILE
INITIATIVE. THE REFERENCE THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDES TWEETS IN A QUARTER
BILLION TO TWO POINT STATE TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
STATEWIDE MIDDLE MILE NETWORK.
TO CONNECT ON CHILDREN I.
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THE POPULATIONS MADE
EIGHTY HAS SINCE IDENTIFIED NEW
MARKET HENSCHEL RESTS IN
ANTICIPATED COSTS THOUGH OVERALL
INCREASE THE COST OF THE
PROJECT. THE AUDIT PASSED ME
DOING WHAT I DO THANK. IN
ADDITION THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES FIFTH FIVE NO ONE
GENTLE FUND TWENTY TWENTY TO
THREE. IN SIX HUNDRED SEVEN. AND
FORTY ON GOING SUPPORT SHORT
TERM IT PROJECTS APPROVED
THROUGH THE TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION FUNDING PROCESS
HELLO COMMENDED BY CITY
DESTABILIZATION SERVICES
ASSESSMENT TEAM. FINALLY
UNDEFEATED CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS THE MALE
VERSION INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA VETERAN HEALTH
INITIATIVE. THE COMMISSION FOR
FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING VETERAN
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION EFFORTS INCLUDING AN
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION CAMPAIGN.
GRANTS TO VETERANS SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN FUNDING FOR A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM RESEARCH
VETERAN MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
BACK INCLUDES FINANCES
PRESENTATION ON THE SIGNIFICANT
ENVISIONED PROPOSALS BUT I OF
FINANCE COLLEAGUES INCLUDING
STAFF JOINING US ON THE LINE TO
ASSIST IN ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THE
WAY WITH THE SHIP. GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
FROM THE L. A. O. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRIAN METZGER WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. I
WILL PRESENT OUR COMMENTS ON
FOUR PROPOSALS IN THE ORDER THEY
ARE PRESENTED IN THE AGENDA. ON%
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATION
AGENCIES OFFICE OF DATA AND
INNOVATION PROPOSAL. I IN
GENERAL THE REORGANIZATION OF
THE NEW ODI AS A STANDALONE
ENTITY APPEARS READY TO CALL
YOU. I'M GONNA GET OFF THIS AND
CALL YOU- GIVEN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE. GIVEN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND PROGRAMMATIC
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THESE
ENTITIES HOWEVER WHETHER TO
PROVIDE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE FOR DATA
AND INNOVATION SERVICES SHOULD
BE WEIGHED AGAINST OTHER
PRIORITIES OF THE LEGISLATURE
ALSO PROPOSED ODI ACTIVITIES
WILL REQUIRE COORDINATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
INCLUDING HELP PROJECTS BOTH IT
AND NON IT YOU'RE HANDED OFF AND
ARE SHARED BETWEEN THE TWO
ENTITIES. SO HOW FUNDS FOR DATA
AND INNOVATION SERVICES IN THIS
PROPOSAL AND FUNDS FOR SYSTEM
STABLE GEN AND TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION IN CITY TEAMS
PROPOSALS WORK TOGETHER COULD
WARRANT SOME CLARIFICATION AND
IN SOME CASES PRESCRIPTION AND
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO FOR
EXAMPLE PLAN DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT MORE PROJECTS THAT
QUALIFY AND SALAS. WHEN THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH IS
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE COR PROGRAM
PROPOSAL THE FIRST COHORT OF
THIS PROGRAM WILL NOT BEGIN
UNTIL FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
AND SO WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU
REJECT THIS PROPOSAL AND THAT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS TO DEVELOP
A LONG RANGE. STRATEGIC PLAN.
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS BUREAU OF PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION FUND BACK SO
PROPOSAL WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE ONE YEAR OF
FUNDING IN REQUIRE THE BUREAU TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON ITS
PROGRESS. IN DEVELOPING A NEW
FEE STRUCTURE IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE BUREAU REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL TIME BEYOND ONE YEAR
TO DEVELOP THE FEE STRUCTURE YOU
COULD SEE FUTURE FUNDING BACK
BILLS THAT THAT'S FINE. WHAT IS
REASONABLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP A NEW
FEE STRUCTURE IT IS UNCLEAR WHY
THAT PROCESS WOULD TAKE THREE
YEARS. THIS APPROACH WOULD ALSO
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO RIP.
REGULAR UPDATES ON THE PROGRESS
OF DEVELOPING A NEW THREE D.
STRUCTURE. AND FINALLY ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL THE PROPOSED
ALLOCATIONS IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE ARE INTENDED TO
ACCOUNT FOR INCREASED LABOR AND
MATERIALS COSTS AS WELL AS
POTENTIALLY ADDITIONAL MILES FOR
THE STATE'S BROADBAND MIDDLE
MILE INITIATIVE. HOWEVER THERE
IS NO BUDGET YEAR APPROPRIATION
THAT WOULD FUND OR PROPOSED
BUDGET BILL LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD CODIFY THESE ALLOCATIONS.
FURTHERMORE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING FROM THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOBS ACT FOR
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. WILL
BE AVAILABLE IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THE
ADMINISTRATION ACKNOWLEDGES THE
FUTURE AVAILABILITY OF THIS
FUNDING IN ITS PROPOSED
REVISIONS TO A CONTROL SECTION
TO ALLOW FOR THE APPROPRIATION
OF FEDERAL FUNDING ONCE IT'S
RECEIVED. AND OFFSET STATE BOND
SUCH AS THOSE FOR. SORRY SUCH AS
THOSE PURPLE HERE HIT NEEDED.
THEREFORE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
WAIT TO MAKE THIS DECISION NEXT
YEAR WHEN MORE INFORMATION CAN
BE PROVIDED ABOUT ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING IN BROADBAND
MIDDLE MILE INITIATIVE CHANGES
AND COSTS. MY COLLEAGUES AND I
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO BEFORE WE GO
TO THAT ARE MY COLLEAGUES- WOULD
AS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND- I WITH-
ANYONE ON THE LINE FROM THE
COSMETOLOGY WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND TO. THE EARLIEST
COMMENTS ON THE MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND INITIATIVE PROJECT
PLEASE DO SO. ABSOLUTELY MARTIN
ROE- CALIFORNIA BERMAN
TECHNOLOGY THE END OF THE THINK
AS- DELEO IT IS LAID OUT IDEA
ACTUALLY DESCRIBED. THE PROPOSAL
OF WHAT I WOULD SAY THOUGH IS
THIS WE- YOU KNOW IT I WANT TO
REMIND EVERYBODY THROUGH TWENTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS PROVIDED IN
THE CURRENT BUDGET IS IT'S ALL
OPPORTUNITY THAT ALL NEEDS TO BE
UNDER CONTRACT BY DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SO WE HAVE A
VERY TIGHT TIME FRAME WATCH. TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS. OUR
CURRENT PROCESS AND KNOW THAT
THE PLAN IS TO HAVE KILLED BILL
AS MUCH OF THIS IS. AND SO WE
ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH HAVING
CALTRANS DESIGN- AND- AND- DO
THE PRE CONSTRUCTION WORK ON
THIS PROJECT. AND THE CONCERNED
WITH DELAY IN THIS FUNDING IS
THAT. OF WHEN A CITY WORKS WITH
CALTRANS AND GOLDEN STATE NATTEN
OF UTILITIES COMMISSION AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS PROJECT.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE CALTRANS
DESIGN. AND DEVELOP A PROJECT
THAT IS SIZED TO THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE. SO IF THE FUNDING
ISN'T PROVIDED THIS YEAR THEN WE
WOULD SIDES THE PROJECT- TO THE
THREE POINT TWO FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE. IF MONEY WERE
PROVIDED IN THE FUTURE HERE-
CALTRANS PRE CONSTRUCTION WORK
IS ESTIMATED TO COST TO TAKE
ABOUT TWO YEARS. AND SO- WITH
ALL OF THE CONTRACT FUNDING
NEEDING TO BE- SIGNED ALL THE
CONTRACTS TO BE SIGNED BY
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY FOUR-
HUESO SUBSEQUENT YEAR TO GET
FUNDING. I WOULDN'T. C. TIER
CALTRAIN I'M TAX- DEVELOP A
BROAD PROJECT SO THAT'S WHY REST
FOR. THE FUNDING THIS YEAR. OKAY
THANK YOU ARRIVE TO DO ONE SINCE
YOU QUEUING AT THE- LA- HAD A
CUP OF- RESPOND. TO OUR COMMENTS
TO THE PROPOSAL SO BEFORE I HAVE
MY MEMBERS ASK QUESTIONS I'D
LIKE TO AT LEAST GIVE YOUR FOLKS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND.
BELIEVE WE HAVE SOMEONE ON THE
LINE FOR THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH REGARDING THE COLLEGE
SERVICE QUICKLY GRAHAM THAT'S
RIGHT AND YOU'RE GOING TO KILL
SOMEBODY OF ABOUT COUNT YET BUT
COLLEGE. THAT'S RIGHT. COACH
CORPORAL. GREAT DAY THANK YOU
RYAN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS
IS JOSH FRIDAY WITH CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS. APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY COME BEFORE YOU AND
TALK ABOUT THIS PROGRAM- AND
ALSO A CHANCE ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. SO WE KNOW THAT THE
COLLEGE COURSE IS A MODEL THAT
WORKS THIS PROGRAM IS BASED ON A
PILOT THAT WE'VE RUN. OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS WITH EIGHT
UNIVERSITIES AND SEVERAL HUNDRED
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
STUDENTS ARE ARE FACING
UNPRECEDENTED DEBT WE'RE IN A
DEBT CRISIS WE KNOW THAT
STUDENTS MANY TO MANY STUDENTS
ARE HAVING DIFFICULTY GRADUATING
ON TIME. THAT UNIVERSITIES ARE
FACING A CHALLENGE WITH
ENROLLMENT- IN BOTH RECRUITING
STUDENTS AND ALSO KEEPING THEM
AND ROLLED. AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY OFTEN CAN'T AFFORD
CAREER REACHING OPPORTUNITIES
LIKE THE COLLEGE COURT PROVIDES
WHICH GIVES THEM THE ABILITY TO
BUILD NETWORKS SOCIAL NETWORKS
AND SOCIAL CAPITAL ALSO TO BUILD
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS. AND I AND
ACCOMPLISHED WHAT UNIVERSITY
LEADERS ACROSS THE STATE CALL
HIGH IMPACT PRACTICES WHICH IS
WHAT THE COLLEGE CORPORAL GRAHAM
IS. WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
COLLEGE COURT ADDRESSES ALL
THESE ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING
WHILE CREATING. A NEW GENERATION
OF YOUNG LEADERS WHO ARE CIVIC
MINDED- FOR CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE
AND THEY'RE DOING IMPORTANT WORK
THE SUPPORTING THE COMMUNITY-
RIGHT NOW AND WILL CONTINUE-
DEBT THAT TO HELP VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. WITH ISSUES LIKE
CLIMATE ACTION SUPPORTING OUR
FOOD BANKS TUTORING AND
MENTORING OUR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY AS WE COME
OUT OF COVERAGE. AND SO THIS
PROGRAM IS IN SO MANY WAYS OF A
WIN ACROSS THE BOARD. IT WOULD.
HE'S IN HIGH DEMAND NOT JUST
ROOMS. TO WANT APPLY BE PART OF
IT BUT ALL FROM UNIVERSITY YOU
WANT PURCHASE A- AND SO FUNDING
PERMANENT FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM. IS NECESSARY TO ONE
ENSURE THAT UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY PLAN AHEAD TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS SO
CRITICAL TO SUPPORT STUDENTS TO
SUPPORT. ANY AND I'M SURE
ACCOUNTABILITY- WE KNOW FROM
PROGRAMS LIKE THE PEACE CORPS MY
EXPERIENCE IN THE MILITARY OUR
EXPERIENCE RUNNING AMERICORPS
PROGRAMS AT THE STATE THAT WE
CAN'T JUST SEND YOUNG PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY.
TO DO WORK THAT RELLY EFFECTIVE
IN TO MAKE IT A TRANSFORMATIVE
PROGRAM FOR THEM. AND THE
SERVICE AND THE COMMUNITY THAT
IT TAKES TIME TO BUILD AND
MAINTAIN PROPERLY. BENEFITS NO
THAT NEED TO GIVE STUDENTS A
VAN. THE ABILITY TO PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE TO BUILD IN OPPORTUNITIES
LIKE THIS INTO THEIR DECISION
ABOUT WHETHER TO EVEN GO TO CALL
IN THE FIRST PLACE WHETHER THEY
CAN AFFORD IT- AND HOW THEY CAN
MAKE THIS PART OF THEIR PLAN. TO
ACTUALLY PAY FOR COLLEGE WE ALSO
KNOW THAT IT IS IMPORTANT IN A
FOR ACTUALLY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO. PROVIDE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DREAMERS WHICH WE
ARE DOING FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT
AMERICORPS. PROGRAMS EXCLUDE
DREAMERS BECAUSE IT'S FEDERALLY
FUNDED SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO AND- AND
INTEGRATE DREAMER GIVE THAT.
LADY PARTICIPATE THIS FOR THE
FIRST TIME- THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED ONGOING SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE AND THAT FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM DEMONSTRATES. IN THE N.
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO BOTH
DEBT FREE PATHWAYS AS RUDE AS
WELL AS THE IMPORTANT CREE
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
SO MANY OF OUR LOW. YOU NEED
WHAT ARE TOO OFTEN EXCLUDED FROM
SO. HAPPY DANCE OR LOOK FOR TO
ANSWERING ANY AND ALL QUESTIONS
AND HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH
YOU ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK-YOU I'M AT. TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES BUT I DO WANT TO SAY
I DON'T. DE LA I WAS SUGGESTING
THAT WE SHOULDN'T HELP OUR
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO ARE
INTERESTED. THEY JUST WOULD. IT
DOESN'T OR ALTERNATE. I'M JUST
BEFORE I HAVE MA'AM RISK I DO TO
HAVE A GIVEN OPPORTUNITY FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ESSENTIALLY DEFENDER PROPOSALS
BECAUSE WE'RE HEARING FROM LA-
THAT SAYING YOU KNOW THERE'S
ANOTHER WAY TO DO SOMETHING MORE
EFFICIENTLY- SO THAT'S JUST A
YOU KNOW A PREP FOR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT COME UP BUT
SENATOR NIELSEN DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS. WELL YES-
CONFESSING THAT I KNOW A LOT OF
HISTORY HERE AND I'M GETTING A
LITTLE BIT CONFUSED. AND I'M
GLAD THERE'S A GENTLEMAN HERE
REPRESENTING THE OFFICE OF
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY. OVER THE
DECADES SINCE THAT AGENCY HAS
BEEN CREATED ITS GREATEST
SUCCESS HAS BEEN CHANGED ITS
NAME SEVERAL TIMES AND I'M NOT
SURE WHAT IT'S CALLED NOW I
GUESS IT'S OFFICE OPERATION THE
OFFICE OF INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
. WHAT I'M CURIOUS ABOUT AS TO
THIS PARTICULAR. PROPOSAL IT
IT'S SETTING UP A- DADDO AN
INFORMATION STAND ALONE
DEPARTMENT WHY CAN THIS NOT BE.
JUST A PART OF THE OFFICE OF
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY NOW THE
GO AHEAD TO THROW OME WORDS IN
HERE IMPROVING USER EXPERIENCE
THROUGH DIGITAL INNOVATION
SERVICE OF ALL BEING FUNDED
CENTER. I JUST DON'T SEE WHY
THAT CAN'T BE HANDLED IN THE
OFFICE OF INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
WHAT WE HAVE TO CREATE A NEW.
DEPARTMENT WITH ALL THE OVERHEAD
OF MANAGEMENT THAT IS ENTAILED.
OPERATION AND- BE WISE FOR THAT
LET'S GET TO THAT PARTICULAR
QUESTION WHY CAN'T THIS ALL BE
HANDLED WITHIN THE EXISTING
AGENCY. THANK YOU SENATOR
NIELSEN WE HAVE COLLEAGUES ON
THE LINE FROM THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION WHO WILL
RESPOND TO YOUR QUESTION. HELLO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION MY
NAME IS DR ON A CRIME THE US
TEAM WHITE SHIFTED OFFICER AND-
REPRESENTING CAL DATA THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY BE MERGING. WITH
OFFICE- THEY TO BE. ON THE
PROPOSAL TO RENAME IT THE OFFICE
OF DATA AND INNOVATION. AND
THERE'S A SHORTEN A LONGER
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION- AND
IT'S A- IT'S A IT'S A IT COMES
FROM A POSITION OF- THE CHANGE
THAT'S HAPPENING IN TECHNOLOGY
SO ESSENTIALLY- WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING FROM THE OFFICE OF
DATA AND INNOVATION A LOT OF THE
WORK WILL BE DOING WILL NOT HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH TECHNOLOGY
OR TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS AND IT'S A
DIFFERENT SKILL SET AND A
DIFFERENT SET OF BOOKS. SO
EARLIER TODAY YOU ALL WERE
TALKING ABOUT HOW LEAD MEASURING
THE EFFECTIVENESS AND THE AND
THE OF THE GRANTS PROGRAM AROUND
SOME OF THE ON THE HOUSING
HOMELESS WORK GREAT SO THE
OFFICE OF DATA AND INFORMATION
CAN BE A PARTNER AROUND SETTING
STANDARDS ABOUT HOW DO WE
MEASURE EFFECTIVENESS OF
PROGRAMS THAT'S NOT SOMETHING WE
DELEGATE HER I. T. TEAMS ARE
EIGHTY TEAMS MIGHT. HELP US
COLLECT THE DATA AND SECURE
STORAGE WE REALLY DOES. RELY ON
THE BUSINESS SIDE. OF IN THE
PROGRAM SO I TO REALLY TRULY USE
THAT DATA TO OPERATE THOSE
PROGRAMS EFFECTIVELY- IT'S KIND
OF ANALOGOUS TO. WELL WE ALL USE
SOFTWARE RIGHT- OF WRITER USES
SOFTWARE ON TO WRITE A NOVEL-
BUT THAT DOES NOT MEAN HE'S A
TECHNOLOGIST RATES OF THE SAME
THING WHEN WE USE DATA AND WE DO
SERVICE DESIGN AND DELIVERY
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A DIGITAL
COMPONENT. IT'S A DIFFERENT SET
OF SKILLS IT'S A DIFFERENT KIND
OF ENGAGEMENT AND- AND WE
ACTUALLY PULL AND DIFFERENT
PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT SECTORS TO
WORK ON THOSE PROBLEMS. LET ME
THEN FOLLOW UP AND I CONSIDER
THAT AN ADEQUATE ANSWER AND I
THANK YOU. MAYBE THE GENTLEMAN
FROM OR I. T. MAYBE CAN BETTER
ADDRESS THIS ONE. THIS IS A FAR
BROADER QUESTION AND KIND OF AN
IMPATIENT CONCERN AREA OF MINE.
IT'S JUST BEEN DISAPPOINTING
OVER THE DECADES THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THIS STATE HAS EXPANDED.
TO EMPLOY NEW TECHNOLOGY. AND
ALMOST NONE OF THEM OF WORKED.
THEY'VE ALL BEEN NOT ON TIME
NEVER ON BUDGET. ALWAYS SICK
CREDIBLY MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
INTENDED. FISCALE IS ONLY BUT
THE MOST RECENT DISASTER. COULD
SOMEONE TELL ME WHY THAT IS SO
IN THIS STATE. SUPPOSEDLY THE I.
T. CAPITAL OF THE WORLD. AND WE
CAN'T GET ANYTHING RIGHT IN OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS. I
WOULD FOR MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY ON THAT
QUESTION PLEASE THANK YOU.
I'LL GIVE IT A SHOT. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M CAROLYN NORDSTROM
AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROJECT MANAGEMENT
OFFICE AND SO. IN THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE PROJECT DELIVERY WE DO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OVER THE I. T.
PORTFOLIOS AT. THE PORTFOLIO OF
IT PROJECTS- WHILE IT IS TRUE
THAT WE HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF.
NOTABLE PROJECTS THAT HAVE.
EXCEEDED THEIR BUDGETS OR NOT
BEEN DELIVERED AS EXPECTED- IT
IS AN ACCURATE TO SAY THAT ALL
OF THEM. ARE ALWAYS LATE AND
ALWAYS OVER BUDGET THERE ARE
ACTUALLY MANY MANY PROJECTS THAT
GET DELIVERED EVERY YEAR THAT DO
MEET EXPECTATIONS- OF DELIVERING
THE BUSINESS VALUE THAT. IS
INTENDED FOR THAT SEVERAL NOT
SOMETHING THAT THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE PROJECT DELIVERY- IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING
PROVIDING THAT INDEPENDENT
PROJECT OVERSIGHT AND HELPING TO
. TRY TO CORRECT THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE THE PROJECTS DO
NOT MEET THEIR EXPECTATIONS AND
DO EXCEED THEIR BUDGETS SO THOSE
INSTANCES ARE UNFORTUNATE AND
GENERALLY THEY CAN BE HIGH
PROFILE BECAUSE THEY CAN BE VERY
EXPENSIVE BUT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
THE EXCEPTION RATHER THAN THE
RULE. IS FISCALE. WORKING NOW.
FISCALE. I AM NOT THE EXPERT IN
IT FOR SCALE I KNOW THAT THERE
IS STILL WORK THAT IS BEING DONE
AND THAT PROJECT HAS NOT BEEN
FULLY COMPLETED AT THIS TIME. I
DON'T HAVE FURTHER SPECIFICS-
THAT'S THAT'S NOT WHAT I WAS
HERE TO TESTIFY ABOUT SO I
WOULD. DEFER TO YOU KNOW ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS- LATER IF WE CAN
COME BACK TO YOU ON THAT STATUS
I WOULD APPRECIATE VERY MUCH I'M
NOT BEING OPTIONED AND I'M BEING
VERY AGGRESSIVE THOUGH BECAUSE
THIS IS A SITUATION THAT- THIS
IS NOT SATISFACTORY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I'M GLAD THAT
THERE ARE SOME AND I'M- PROBABLY
A LITTLE HARSH AND SAYING ALL.
BUT THAT SOME MAJOR ONES
INCLUDING THIS ONE- HELP. ME
AND- YEAH IT'S BEEN I'VE BEEN A
PART OF IT WHEN I WAS HEAD OF
THE BOARD OF PRISON TERMS WE HAD
THE- CORRECTIONAL INFORMATION
SERVICES WHATEVER IT WAS CALLED.
SHEAMUS I GUESS IN THE WHO SPENT
YEARS AND. DOZENS OF STAFF
DEPLOYED. CRASHED AND BURNED
NEVER DELIVERED TELL THANK YOU
FOR THE ATTEMPTING TO GET BACK.
UNDERSTOOD WE WILL DO THAT THANK
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON SENATOR ROTH THE MANAGER
FIRST- JUST TO FOLLOW ON MY
QUESTIONS AND MY COLLEAGUE- HAS
BEEN WITH ME IN. THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE IN DIFFERENT YEARS
AND I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
TERRORISTS DURING THE SUB
COMMITTEE FOR SIX YEARS OF.
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
AND SO. I HAVE SEEN SEVERAL OF
THE VERY LARGE PROJECTS THAT-
STARTED FRANKLY PRIOR TO MY TIME
HERE AND I THINK UNFORTUNATELY.
ONE OR TWO OF THOSE LARGE
PROJECTS OF. CONTINUE THE
ARTICLE TO APPEAR IN THE
NEWSPAPER AND THEY'VE NOT QUITE
AT LEAST THE ONE NOT QUITE COME
TO A TO CLOSURE ALTHOUGH IN THE
CASE OF FISCAL THEY'RE GETTING
THEIR THE TEAM THAT'S WORKING
IT'S GETTING THERE AND I'VE I
THINK YOU GIVEN THE SIZE THE
SCOPE THE COMPLEXITY AND THE
NUMBER OF BOARDS BUREAUS- IN THE
LAKE THAT- THAT FALL UNDER D. C.
A. N. AND I MEAN THAT B. C. A.
BUT- THE CONTROLLER AND- THE
PROPONENTS ABILITIES OF THE
CONTROLLER I THINK IT'S- IT'S
QUITE AN ACCOMPLISHMENT TO.
BRING THAT- BRING THAT PROGRAM
TO WHERE IT IS THEY'VE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN THE WAY
PROGRAMS OR SCOPE INCISED. OTHER
BEEN SIGNIFICANT CHANGES SINCE
MY INITIAL TIME IN THE SUB
COMMITTEE IN THE WAY THE PROJECT
APPROVALS ARE HANDLED AND I
THINK IT IS PROBABLY TRUE. THAT
THERE ARE MANY PROJECTS THAT
THAT THAT- ARE COMPLETED YEAR
OVER YEAR THE DO NOT MAKE THE
NEWSPAPER- BECAUSE OF THE HARD
WORK OF THE PERSONNEL OF THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY IN THE
HARD WORK OF THE PERSONAL
PERSONNEL IN THE AGENCIES IN THE
DEPARTMENTS- WHO DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO. IN ORDER TO ON BOARD
NEW SYSTEMS AND I THINK WE NEED
WE ARE TO GIVE THE FOLKS CREDIT
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY- THEY ARE
DOING AND CONTINUE TO DO IN THAT
IN THAT AREA. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
STEPPING UP WITH RESPECT TO THE
BUREAU OF PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. THIS IS AN AREA THAT
I WORK IN A DIFFERENT CAPACITY
HERE IN THE SENATE IT'S A
COMPLICATED ISSUE RATHER
COMPLICATED ISSUE THE CHANGES IN
THE- PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
ARENA- FRANKLY CALL FOR REVIEW
OF THE- BUREAU'S OPERATIONS IN
ITS REQUIRED FUNCTIONS TO
DETERMINE THE OPERATIONS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE REQUIRED ON A GO
FORWARD BASIS. I AM THE BEST
METHOD FOR FUNDING. OF THOSE
OPERATIONS THIS IS GONNA TAKE
SOME TIME- AND I DO APPRECIATE
THE ADMINISTRATORS BENEFICIAL
SUPPORT AND PATIENCE. AS WE WALK
THROUGH THIS PROCESS TO
DETERMINE. BUREAU OF PRIVATE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION FOR THE
FUTURE SO JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT KUDOS TO THE ADMINISTRATION
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU
SENATOR RON I AM. JUST A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS. OUT ONE WAS ABOUT
THE M. FOR IT REGARDING THE-
PROPOSAL. FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY THIS BROADBAND MIDDLE
MILE INITIATIVE AND THE QUESTION
JUST HAD TO DO WITH THE AMOUNT-
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S- A
30% PLUS COST. INCREASE AND JUST
WANTED TO KNOW IF THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION OR
DETAILS ON WHY THE COSTS HAVE
INCREASED SO SIGNIFICANTLY. SURE
SO THE UNIT IN TERMS OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS PROPOSAL
REALLY WE'RE LOOKING AT- IT KIND
OF WHAT WE'VE LEARNED ABOUT THIS
PROJECT OVER THE LAST YEAR-
SINCE- SB ONE FIFTY SIX WAS
PASSED AND SO SOME OF THE THINGS
WE HAVE SEEN- OR YOU KNOW IS-
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
HAS DONE ITS ITS JOB IN TERMS
OF- DEVELOPING MAPPING REALLY
IDENTIFYING WHERE THAT. IN THE
UNDERSERVED LOCATIONS WERE I'M
AND THEN AS WE'VE GONE AHEAD AND
WORK WITH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION BUILDING STATING THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED THE RISK IF
THERE MIGHT BE A NEED FOR A
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER- NETWORK
AND STEPS THAT THAT WAS ONE OF
THE DRIVERS YOU KIND OF LOOK AT
THE DRIVERS THAT WERE- AND
IDENTIFIED BY THE ONLY. THING
WITH THAT THE INFLATION- YOU
KNOW SO I JUST EXPECTED OVER THE
NEXT FOUR ONE HALF YEARS FROM
THE TIME FROM NOW UNTIL WE FOR
PROJECT- WITH THE PROJECT- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT COULD EASILY BE
IN THAT THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
RANGE- JUST JUST IN TERMS OF
INFLATION AND THEN IF YOU TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE- THAT THE
DEMAND ON- FOR RESOURCES IN FOR
LABOR WHEN YOU LOOK AT- YOU KNOW
HOW THAT IS GOING TO AFFECT
COSTS RIGHT SO- THE COSTS THAT
WERE ESTIMATED WORLD YOU KNOW
FOR THE PRELIMINARY YOU'RE GOING
TO PUT THIS TOGETHER- AND AS WE-
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP THE PROJECT
WE'VE UNDERSTOOD THAT THERE
THESE ADDITIONAL RISKS AND SO.
WE LOOKED AT KIND OF THAT THAT
THE SCALE OF THOSE RESTS IN THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE AND THEN
DEVELOPED THIS THIS REQUEST FOR
THE ONE POINT ONE BILLION SO
THAT THAT'S REALLY- IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY AN ITEMIZED LIST
IT'S REALLY AND I AM TRYING TO
IDENTIFY A NUMBER OF SIGNIFICANT
RISKS THAT ARE IN THE YOU KNOW
HUNDRED MILLION RANGE EVER MORE
THAN A HUNDRED MILLION AND A LOT
OF CASES- AND TRYING TO- TO
MITIGATE SOME. COMBINATION OF
THOSE WITH THE ONE POINT. Q. I.
AND THEN. OTHER QUESTION JUST TO
DO THE ARE. OF DATA DIGITAL. AS
A STATE. DEPARTMENT I WANT THANK
YOU FOR- PROVIDING THE-
CLARIFYING RESPONSE THAT YOU DID
TO SENATOR NIELSEN THE IBM. BUT
WAS JUST SORT OF CURIOUS ABOUT
IS THIS LIKE- WOULD THIS BE A
DATA SILO I MEAN DOES IT DOES IT
WHY DOES IT MAKE SENSE FOR TO BE
A STANDALONE DEPARTMENT RATHER
THAN TO. ALLOW THESE KINDS OF
SUPPORTS OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- TO BE INTEGRATED
INTO DEPARTMENTS ADD IS IT LIKE
YOU- IF YOU'RE ONE DEPARTMENT DO
YOU GO TO THIS DEPARTMENT WITH A
TICKET TO SAY HEY I'M GETTING
READY TO DO THIS PROJECT. CAN
YOU HELP ME OR GIVE ME GUIDANCE
ON HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE IS BETTER OR
IS THIS DEPARTMENT SORT OF DOING
AN ASSESSMENT OF HOW. DIFFERENT
PROJECTS ARE BEING MANAGED-
IMPLEMENTED WITHIN DIFFERENT
AGENCIES TO OFFER THEM FEEDBACK.
A. M. I DON'T KNOW. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE THAT- THAT'S A WONDERFUL
QUESTION AND IT'S EXACTLY- AT
THE HEART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THIS WHICH IS- A
PHRASE THAT WE'RE WE'RE SAYING
WE WANT TO BUILD CAPACITY NOT BE
THE CAPACITY IN ORDER TO BUILD
CAPACITY THAT WE NEED TO SET
STANDARDS OF WHAT GOOD LOOKS
LIKE AND ALL THESE THINGS
WHETHER IT'S DATA SCIENCE DATA
ANALYTICS. EVALUATION AND NOT-
METRICS CREATIONS BUT ON SERVICE
pADDITIONALLY- CONTENTS RIGHT ARE
HOW ARE WE WRITING- CONTENT THAT
IS READABLE FOR PEOPLE WHO YOU
KNOW OF MANY DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND I LOVE IT YOU
KNOW OF YOUR FIFTH GRADE GRAMMAR
LEVEL RIGHT WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE GOVERNMENT HE'S RIGHT AND
THEY'LL BE MORE LESS A CENTER OF
EXCELLENCE FOR THESE KINDS OF
CONCEPTS BY DEFINING.STANDARDS
OF WHAT GOOD LOOKS LIKE. FOR
CONSULT AND COACHING TO
DEPARTMENTS AND HELPING BUILD
THEIR- CAPACITY TO DO THIS
THEMSELVES THROUGH THE CALIPARI
WHICH WILL OPERATE THE STANDARDS
AND TRAINING. AND THEN BE READY
FOR THE DAY FUNDS- TO HELP
CATALYZE PLANT PROJECTS AND
SUPPLEMENT THEIR CAPACITY SO
THEY CAN ACCELERATE THE ADOPTION
OF THESE MODERN METHODS AND
APPROACHES. FROM THE SOUNDS OF
THAT THIS GROUP WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY BUSY BECAUSE THEY
WOULD HAVE TO GO TO EVERY SINGLE
DEPARTMENT AND HELP THEM FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE HAVING A
BETTER. CHANCE THAT WAS
FACETIOUS. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SO WE'RE GONNA- MOVE ON TO THE
LAST ITEM WHICH IS CANNABIS I A.
K. A. COOL NOT TO MOVEMENT OVER
HERE I DO WANT TO SAY- THAT IFORGOT TO ASK A QUESTION EARLY
ON ABOUT THE TAX REBATE WITH THE
CARS AND SO I'M JUST SAYING IT
NOW SO IF ANYONE IS IN THE LIKE
THE ZOOM Q. AND THEY DECIDED TO
LEAVE. THEY SHOULD COME BACK AND
I WILL TELEGRAPH THE QUESTION
WHICH IS WHAT ABOUT FOLKS WHO
DON'T HAVE CARS THAT FAMILIES
THAT HAVE INVESTED IN MAKING
SURE THAT THEY'RE PART OF THE
CLIMATE SOLUTION- AND SO THEY
DON'T HAVE A CAR AND WHERE DO
THEY FIT IN IN THIS REBATE
DISCUSSION SO I'M JUST SAYING
THAT NOW SO THAT THE RIGHT
PERSON CAN FIND THEIR WAY BACK
TO THE ZOOM AT THE APPROPRIATE
POINT TO GIVE US AN ANSWER. SO
WITH THAT CANNABIS CONTROL
CANNABIS TAX REFORM WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LIKE TO GO
. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING MEMBERS
CHARLIE MANNING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES TWO PROPOSALS
RELATED TO CANNABIS. THE FIRST
INCLUDE STATUTORY CHANGES. TO
RESTRUCTURE THE CANNABIS TAX
FRAMEWORK TO HELP STABILIZE THE
CANNABIS RETAIL MARKET. MAJOR
CHANGES INCLUDE SETTING THE
CULTIVATION TAX RATE AT ZERO
BEGINNING JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SHIFTING THE POINT
OF COLLECTION AND REMITTANCE FOR
EXCISE TAX FROM DISTRIBUTION TO
RETAIL ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. MAINTAINING A
FIFTEEN PERCENT EXCISE TAX.
SETTING THE FUNDING FOR YOUTH
EDUCATION INTERVENTION TREATMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION AND
STATE AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAMS AT A BASELINE OF SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION
ANNUALLY FOR THREE YEARS. WITH
UP TO A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND AVAILABLE
AS NEEDED TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX TO BACKFILL
ALLOCATION THREE FUNDING ALONG
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO INCREASE
THE EXCISE TAX RATE TO TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. IF TAX
REVENUES FALL BELOW THE BASELINE
FOR ALLOCATION THREE.
ADDITIONALLY STRENGTHENING TAX
ENFORCEMENT POLICIES TO INCREASE
TAX COMPLIANCE COLLECTION AND
REDUCE UNFAIR COMPETITION. THESE
PROPOSED CHANGES ARE INTENDED TO
SIMPLIFY THE TAX STRUCTURE AND
HELP REDUCE BURDENS FOR LEGAL
OPERATORS. THE MAY REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES TWENTY POINT FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR THE CANNABIS LOCAL
JURISDICTION RETAIL ACCESS GRANT
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM WAS THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA THAT DO NOT CURRENTLY
LICENSED STOREFRONT OR DELIVERY
ONLY ONLY CANNABIS RETAILERS IN
THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF A LOCAL RETAIL
LICENSING PROGRAM AND HELP MORE
OF CALIFORNIANS EXISTING
CONSUMERS GAIN ACCESS TO
REGULATED AND TESTED PRODUCTS
THE LICENSE LEGAL REASON.
THERE'S COLLEAGUES AND I ARE
FROM FINANCE AND THE DEPARTMENTS
ARE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU NOW WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR FROM THE L. A. R. THANK
YOU. SIR FOR CHRISTINE WITH THE
L. A. ONLY AT THE PROPOSALS TO
MOVE THE RETAIL EXCISE TAX POINT
OF COLLECTION AND TO ELIMINATE
THE CULTIVATION TAX- THESE TWO
PROPOSALS MATCH RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE IN OUR TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORT AND NOW WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS ON THOSE HE PROPOSED
RATE CHANGES FOR THE RETAIL
EXCISE TAX OR COMPLEX WHICH IS
AN IDEAL BUT THE PROPOSAL
CLEARLY IS TRYING TO STRIKE A
CERTAIN BALANCE BETWEEN
SUPPORTING THE PROGRAM IS FUNDED
BY CANNABIS REVENUES ON ONE HAND
AND HELP LICENSE CANNABIS MARKET
COMPETE WITH THE ILLICIT MARKET
ON THE OTHER. THE LOCAL RETAIL
GRANT- I LACKS DETAILS AN
INTERVIEW APPEARS UNLIKELY TO BE
EFFECTIVE AS STRUCTURED SO WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING IT. THE
PROPOSAL APPEARS TO ASSUME THAT
A LACK OF FUNDING TO DEVELOP A
LICENSING PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE
KEY REASONS WHY JURISDICTIONS DO
NOT ALLOW RETAIL CANNABIS. I
INTERVIEWED LIKELY THAT MANY
JURISDICTIONS DO NOT ALLOW
RETAIL CANNABIS PRIMARILY FOR
OTHER REASONS AND SO THESE
GRANTS AS STRUCTURED. WOULD NOT
ADDRESS THOSE- THAT CONCLUDES MY
PREPARED COMMENTS AND MY
COLLEAGUE JESSICA PETERS AND I
ARE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. OKAY
GREAT SO ONCE AGAIN BEFORE I
TURN IT OVER TO THE COLLEAGUES
ON THIS COMMITTEE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND TO- THE L. A. O. HE SAID
REJECT. SURE OF FOR THE TAX
REFORM THE INTENTION OF THIS
PROPOSALS TO PROVIDE A SUBSET OF
BALANCE BETWEEN SUPPORTING THE
PROGRAMS FUNDED BY CANNABIS TAX
REVENUES AND HELPING TO REDUCE
BURDENS ON LEGAL OPERATORS
THROUGH ELIMINATING THE
CULTIVATION TAX AND SHIFTING THE
POINT OF COLLECTION FOR EXCISE
TAX FROM DISTRIBUTION TO RETAIL.
THE MECHANISMS TO CHANGE THE
EXCISE TAX RATE IN THE EVENT
THAT ALLOCATION THREE REVENUES
DO NOT MEET THE BASELINE FUNDING
ARE INTENDED TO BE SIMPLE FOR
LICENSEES AS THEY WILL BE
NOTIFIED OF ANY NECESSARY
CHANGES IN THE ACCESS EXCISE TAX
RATE MY NUMBER NUMBER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE FOR CHANGES
IN THE RATE EFFECTIVE JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND BY
NOVEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR FOR CHANGES IN THE RATE
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. FOR THE GRANT
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM IS
INTENDED TO HELP THESE THOSE
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO DEVELOP A LOCAL
RETAIL LICENSING PROGRAM. THESE
ENTITIES HAVE COST BURDENS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT AND MINISTRATION.
THEY ALSO COST TO ESTABLISH AN
ORDINANCE AND CONDUCTING SECRET. MY COLLEAGUES ON. THE LINE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL- IF THEY WANT TO ADD ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. OKAY GREAT
I'M GONNA GO TO THE- TO SENATOR
NIELSEN- FOR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. TO ME THIS
DEBATERS GOT AN ELEMENT OF
ABSURDITY. NOW ADMITTEDLY I DID
NOT SUPPORT LEGALIZATION. IT'S
HERE. BUT NOW WE HAVE A HUGE
MESS. THE ILLICIT MARKET IS
DOMINATED. THE LEGAL MARKET IS
SUFFERING. WAS THAT NOT TO BE
EXPECTED OF COURSE IT WILL. OR
SHOULD HAVE BEEN. AND I DON'T
FAULT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHO DO
NOT WANT. CANNABIS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES I SUPPORT THAT. BUT
THIS IS NOT THE ENTIRE ANSWER.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK TO ME AND
CONVINCE ME THAT LET'S DO A FEW
THINGS ABOUT CRACKING DOWN ON
THE ILLICIT MARKET. IT'S RAMPANT
COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. IN THIS DESPOILING A
LOT OF OUR WATERSHEDS. POISONING
OUR GROUNDWATER. PREVENTING
THREATS DIRECT READING PUBLIC.
ALL KINDS OF PROBLEMS. AND IF
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT THIS THEN
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT SIDE OF
THE EQUATION. NOT FOCUSING ON
HELPING OUT THE LEGAL MARKET.
LET'S DO WHAT WE CAN THERE BUT
LET'S DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE
ILLICIT MARKET TO. IT'S A PLAGUE
ON CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON SENATOR ROTH VENTURE. YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE I THOUGHT ONE OF
THE COMPLAINTS WE HEARD SOMETIME
BACK FROM FOLKS IN THE RETAIL
BUSINESS ABOUT THE CANNABIS
STRUCTURE THAT WE SET IN PLACE
WAS THAT THE- THAT THE BURDEN
THE LOAD THAT WE PLACE ON THEM.
BOTH LOCALLY AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL WAS CAUSING THE PRICE OF
THEIR PRODUCT TO BE SUCH THAT-
THEY WERE PRICED OUT OF THE
MARKET. VIS A VIS THE- ILLEGAL
MARKET. AND I'M JUST TRYING TO
GET A HANDLE ON THE IMPACT OF
THIS CANNABIS TAX REFORM
PROPOSAL SO IF WE SET THE
CULTIVATION TAX RATED ZERO BUT
WE INCREASE THE EXCISE TAX TO
NINETEEN PERCENT. WHAT WHAT IS
THAT DO AT THE RETAIL LEVEL. IS
THAT A FAIR QUESTION YEAH.
SENATOR NICOLE ELLIOTT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT CANNABIS CONTROL
THANK YOU ALL FOR TAKING UP THIS
ISSUE TODAY- AND REGARDING YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT THE NINETEEN
PERCENT- WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
PARTNERS ON THE TAX REFORM
PROPOSAL ENGAGED AND IN THIS
HEARING AS WELL INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE 90% IS
AN ISSUE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CAN ALSO SPEAK TO ONE
THING I WILL NOTE THAT WITHIN US
ALL IS THAT IT DOES SPEAK TO ME
G. R. EXCISE TAX AT 15% FOR NO
LESS THAN A YEAR AND A HALF. IN
UP TO THREE YEARS I WITH THAT HE
DID OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO TALK MORE A LITTLE
ABOUT THE 90% FRESH YOU JUST
POST. GOOD AFTERNOON KIMBERLY
HARBISON FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS DIRECTOR ELLIOT
MENTIONED. OF THE 19% IS-
DESIGNED TO DO. TWO THINGS
REALLY WERE TRYING TO STRIKE A
BALANCE AS- THE ELLIE OKAY THE
FAMILY NOTED. BETWEEN THE
FUNDING FOR THE ALLOCATING THREE
PROGRAMS THAT'S THE YOUTH
EDUCATION TREATMENT PREVENTION
AND- NATURAL RESOURCES
PROTECTION AND THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMPONENTS SO. WE'RE TRYING TO
ASSESS OUR LEGAL PARTICIPANTS
AND ENCOURAGE THEM TO CONTINUE
THEIR BUSINESS TO BRING MORE
PEOPLE INTO THE MARKET. THAT'S
ONE WAY WE CAN COMBAT THE
ILLICIT ACTIVITY. AND WE ALSO
ARE TRYING TO BE MINDFUL OF.
FUNDING FOR THOSE ALLOCATION
THREE PROGRAM SO THAT THE
CURRENT TAX RIGHT NOW.
MOTIVATION IS ABOUT 4% AND
EXCISES 15% SO TOGETHER THAT'S
NINETEEN PERCENT. WERE ZEROING
OUT THE CULTIVATION SO THAT
LEAVES US AT 15% TO START THIS
PROJECT. WELL THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND
BACK CELLS SO THE IDEA IS. IF
THE TAX RATE IS LOWER PERHAPS
PEOPLE WHO BUY MORE CANNABIS
OVER ALSO THE REVENUE WON'T
DEBT. BECAUSE THE TAX RATE
LOWERED IT WILL JUST SAY ABOUT
THE SAME BECAUSE MORE CANNABIS
WILL BE PURCHASED MORE TAX
REVENUE WILL COME IN. IF THAT
DOESN'T TURN OUT TO BE THE CASE
WE CAN SUPPORT THEM THE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OF ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND. IF THAT STILL
DOESN'T GET THEM TO THE BASELINE
THAT'S WHEN WE WOULD. MAKE AN
ADJUSTMENT IN THE EXCISE TAX
RATES. AND THIS IS NICK WITH
ARSENAL PRODUCT. ATTACKS IN TWO
MINISTRATION I MAKE. I JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT IT'S NOT-NECESSARILY ABOUT. SELLING MORE
CANNABIS IT IS ABOUT. DRIVING
ACTIVITY. INTO THE LEGAL MARKET.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT BOTH THE TAX
REFORM PROVISIONS HERE. WELL AS
THE ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS WITH
SHRINK WHICH INCLUDED IN THIS
PROPOSAL. WILL ALLOW US TO MUCH
MORE EFFECTIVELY- GRAPPLE WITH-
THE ILLICIT MARKET I COMPLETELY
SHARED CENTER NEILSON'S.
CONCERNS AND- WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN I THINK THIS
PROPOSAL. WILL ALLOW US- THE
SIMPLIFICATION OF THE SYSTEM AS
WELL AS TO THE ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS AS WELL AS ALLOWING
US TO. USE OUR SALES AND USE TAX
OUR RESOURCES AND COMBINE THEM
WITH OUR CAMPUS RESOURCES
BECAUSE NOW. IT WOULD BE AT THE-
RETAIL LEVEL SO THEY WOULD BOTH
BE SALES AND USE TAX PAYERS AS
WELL AS THE X. TAXPAYERS AS BY
THE WAY. IS I MEAN THIS IS THE
SYSTEM THAT WAS DESIGNED AND
VOTED ON IN PROP SIXTY FOUR SO I
THINK FOR ALL THOSE REASONS THIS
IS A LOT OF SENSE AND WILL. TO-
COMBAT THE ILLICIT MARKET AND
ALLOW THOSE- OPERATORS WHO ARE
TRYING TO PLAY BY THE RULES.
HAVE A MUCH BETTER CHANCE SAYS.
WHAT I LIKE THIS AND I COMMEND
YOU I COMMEND THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR CHANGING THE POINT OF
COLLECTION AND REMITTANCE- AS
YOU KNOW WE ALL WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT THE LAST TIME WE-
CONVENE THAT THE RIVER TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION- I AM I'M STILL
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THIS EXCISE
TAX. INCREASE DECREASE BUSINESS
SO. THE CULTIVATION TAX WAS 4%
THE EXCISE TAXES FIFTEEN
PERCENT. SO DO I UNDERSTAND THAT
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE IT AT 15% ZERO
OUT THE CULTIVATION TAX. AND SEE
WHETHER IT DRIVES UP CANNABIS
SALES WHICH IN TURN IS REVENUE
TO THE STATE THROUGH THE TAX.
AND IF IT DOES NOT THEN THE
NIGHT THEN THE EXCISE TAX GOES
BACK 219% YES THAT'S CORRECT AND
AGAIN IT'S LEGAL CANNABIS SALES
THAT WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO DRIVE
NO NO NO. NO NO NO I UNDERSTAND
THAT. WHAT WHAT'S THAT IS THAT
IS THE THAT IS THE MOST
COMPROMISED THAT I THINK PEOPLE
BEEN TRYING TO STRIKE IS LA-
MENTIONED. I'M GOING TO STICK
THE ENDS OF THE FUNDING. AND THE
INDUSTRY AND- WELL I'M
FASCINATED BY THE BY THIS
THOUGHT SO WE'RE DOING IT 15% TO
SEE IF IT INCREASES THE STAPLES
IF IT DOESN'T OF LAWFUL LEGAL
CANNABIS. IF IT DOESN'T INCREASE
THE SALES WERE GOING TO INCREASE
THE EXCISE TAX TO NINETEEN
PERCENT. WHICH WOULD PROBABLY IS
ASSUREDLY KEEP THE SALES LOW.
YOU MIGHT WRITE SENATE SENATOR
NIELSEN SAYS CHRISTINE WITH THE
L. AND JUST TO CLARIFY A COUPLE
THINGS THE WAY IT IS DONE AT THE
OTHER END THIS IS ROUGH I'M
SORRY SORRY SORRY. SENATOR RON
AND HE WAITED TRAILER BILL IS
CONSTRUCTED THE DEFAULT SO AS A
DIRECTOR ELLIOT NEWBY THE-
RETAIL EXCISE TAX WOULD REMAIN
AT FIFTEEN PERCENT FOR- THROUGH
THE END OF CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND THEN STARTING
ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR THE DEFAULT- EXCISE TAX
RATE IN THE STATUTE WOULD BE
NINETEEN PERCENT. THERE IS A
PROCESS ARTICULATED IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THROUGH
WHICH THE ADMINISTRATION IN
PARTICULAR CD TFA IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COULD LOWER THE RATE BELOW 19%
AS LOW AS FIFTEEN PERCENT. BUT
THE WAY THE WAY THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS PHRASED IT GIVES
THEM THE OPTION TO DO THAT UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES BUT NO NO
REQUIREMENT TO DO SO I JUST
STRICTER TO CLARIFY THE
STRUCTURE AND THAT WOULD BE.
THAT WOULD BE THE CASE FROM
JANUARY FOR.
AND THEN AT THE SAME TIME
ENHANCING OURENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS ON THOSE THAT ARE
ENGAGED IN THE ILLEGAL
OPERATION- IT. IN THE CANNABIS
SPACE SO ONE QUESTION ON THAT
SCORE THE ANALYSIS SAYS. THE
CHANGES INCLUDE ENFORCEMENT
POLICIES TO INCREASE TAX
COMPLIANCE AND COLLECTION AS
WELL AS LABOR STANDARDS. THEN
SAVE THOSE POLICIES NOT FUNDING
DO YOU RENT DO YOU ANTICIPATE.
GETTING TO THIS FUNDING ON THE
ENFORCEMENT SIDE TO ENHANCE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITY WITH
RESPECT TO THE ILLEGAL
OPERATIONS WHETHER THOSE ARE
GROWS OR SHOPS DISPENSARIES. I'D
BE HAPPY TO TAKE THAT ON THE TAX
SIDE- WE ARE CURRENTLY SPENDING
MUCH LESS THAN ARE WE ALLOWED TO
SPEND OUR TAX SIDE AND FRANKLY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE COULD USE A
LITTLE MORE RESOURCES UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW WHAT THIS DOES
INCLUDE SOME VERY IMPORTANT
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS- WHICH
ARE NOT ANYTHING EARTH
SHATTERING THEY JUST SIMPLY
ALIGN THE CANNABIS LAWS. FRANKLY
MORE WITH OUR SALES AND USE TAX
LAWS BECAUSE CURRENTLY WE HAVE
MORE TEETH IN SALES AND USE TAX
WERE ABLE TO- YOU KNOW MORE
AGGRESSIVELY GO AFTER- UNLIMITED
TAX FROM A- B. MARTIN WE ARE
FROM THE END OF THIS- BUSINESS.
WHICH YOU KNOW IT IT'S- THAT
WE'RE HAVING. I STILL HAVING IT
LOOK. PROVIDES A SOME OF THE
TOOLS WE CURRENTLY HAVEN'T- TAX
COLLECTION SO I THINK. WITH
THESE PROVISIONS WE CAN ALSO AS
I MENTIONED IN MY EARLIER
COMMENTS WE HAVE YOU KNOW
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORKING ON SALES AND USE TAX
THESE SAME TAXPAYERS WHO WILL
NOW BE. TAXPAYERS HERE ARE OUR
SALES AND USE TAX PAYERS-
CURRENTLY AND SO I THINK WE'LL
BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE THAT AND
MUCH MORE EFFECTIVELY DO THIS
WITHOUT A TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF
NEW RESOURCES IF THERE ARE-
RESOURCE CONSTRAINTS AS- AS WE
IMPLEMENT THIS WE WILL CERTAINLY
COME BACK BUT I. DON'T
ANTICIPATE. TO RESOURCE ISSUE AT
THE MOMENT ON THE TAX SIDE AS
MUCH AS IT IS A- YOU KNOW THE
POLICY- INSTRUCTIONS ATTACKS AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE LAX
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS ARE
REALLY HAMPERING OUR EFFORTS
WELL I NEED IT PERHAPS IT'S THE
LACK OF RESOURCES OR SOMETHING
ELSE ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY SIDE.
WELL AND THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SIDE IN MY QUESTION ALSO GOES TO
THAT SO I SUPPOSE THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE DRIVING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WHETHER
IT'S TO OR THROUGH OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL OR DOWN DIRECTLY TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO ADDRESS- WHAT APPARENTLY IS.
ROBUST ILLEGAL. CANNABIS
INDUSTRY OPERATING. THE. SURELY
MANY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THIS
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY DOES NOT
ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR ENFORCEMENT. AND I IF I IF I
MAY AND THIS IS NOT MY ROLE BUT
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT CENTER
OFTEN AND THIS GOES TO CENTER
NIELSEN'S- COMMENTS AS WELL WHAT
WE'RE FINDING IS THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITY. THE CHOSEN
. IN SOME OF THESE COMMUNITIES
HAVE CHOSEN NOT TO LEGALIZE
CANNABIS SALES BUT YET HAVE AN
INCREDIBLY ROBUST ILLICIT
CANNABIS. CANNABIS BUSINESSES
OPERATING VERY OPENLY- WE ARE
AWARE OF THOSE B. YOU NEED LAW
ENFORCEMENT HELP- TO ADDRESS
THOSE AND WE'RE GETTING IN SOME
CASES THE WORST OF BOTH WORLDS
FOR GETTING. COMMUNITIES THEY'VE
CHOSEN NOT TO LEGALIZE CANNABIS
AND YET THEY'VE ALSO CHOSEN NOT
TO ENFORCE THEIR- LAWS AGAINST
YOU- AGAINST CANNABIS SALES AND
YOU'RE SEEING A MUSHROOMING OF
THIS ILLICIT BUSINESS WHICH IS-
DETRIMENTAL TO THE STATE YOUR
TAX REVENUE AND- UNFAIRLY
HURTING THOSE PEOPLE WHO CHOSEN
TO PLAY BY THE RULES ARE TRYING
TO OPERATE. OKAY THIS WAS THE
SYSTEM WELL THANK YOU I
APOLOGIZE FOR ACTUALLY ASKING
THAT QUESTION- I THINK ABOUT IT
IT'S REALLY A PUBLIC SAFETY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ISSUE
SO I'LL- PICK UP THE PHONE AND
CALL OUR COLLEAGUES OVER THERE
AND HAVE THEM ASK THE SAME
QUESTION WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
IN THE- THE RESPONSE. MANAGER
THANK YOU SENATOR ROB. I DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
BECAUSE I THINK THEY'VE BEEN
ASKED- BY MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON
THE DIETS BUT I JUST DO WANT TO
SAY THAT PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA USE CANNABIS THAN
ALL OF ITS FORMS- AND REGARDLESS
OF IF IT'S- LEGALIZED IN THEIR
PARTICULAR- OR IF IT'S- A LEVEL.
THROUGH LEGALIZED WAYS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY OR NOT AND IF WE WANT
TO DRIVE FOLKS INTO THE LEGAL
MARKET. THAT IS GOING TO BE
BASED ON THE COST. OF THE
PRODUCT. AND THE COST OF
STARTING UP THE RETAIL BUSINESS
AND SO IF WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
IT. CHALLENGING OR EXPENSIVE OR
EXCLUSIVE TO ENTER INTO THE
MARKET PLACE WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE A ROBUST
ILLICIT MARKET PLACE. AND SO IT
IS A REALLY SORT OF. PRICKLY
ISSUE AND ALSO I THINK A VERY-
COMPLICATED LINE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO WALK- BUT- PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING TO SPEND EIGHTY DOLLARS
FOR THEIR WEED IN A LEGAL MARKET
PLACE IF THEY CAN GET IT FROM
SOMEONE THAT'S REPUTABLE THAT
THEY KNOW FOR A THIRD OR A
FRACTION OF THE PRICE AND SO WE
GOT TO JUST FIGURE OUT HOW TO
TACKLE THAT. SO THAT'S MY
SOAPBOX. YES SENATOR NELSON I
CAN'T RESIST MY OWN SOAP BOX
THOUGH AND THIS IS A MESSAGE TO
THE ADMINISTRATION. AND TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. THE ILLICIT
MARKET HAS NOT HAS GOT TO BE
ADDRESSED. AND MOST ARE STICKING
THEIR HEAD IN THE SAND LIKE AN
OSTRICH AND IGNORING IT. AND WE
ARE NOT COMMITTING THE RESOURCES
THAT WE NEED TO DO. REGULATE
CONTROL AND DRIVE OUT THE
ILLICIT MARKET. AND INCREASE THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR ALL THE
DESPOILING OF THE LANDS AT THE
CENTER OF THAT THEY DO. SO I
JUST SUGGEST THAT WE CONSIDER
THAT AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
THE TIME IS NIGH IT'S OVERDUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO I THINK-WE HAVE EXHAUSTED- THIS
PARTICULAR TOPIC I DON'T THINK
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SO
THANK YOU ALL I DID HAVE THAT
ONE QUESTION THAT I'M HOPING CAN
GET ANSWERED ABOUT THE TAX
PROPOSAL- FOR THE CARS FOR FOLKS
THAT DON'T HAVE ANY. HI MISTER
WHITE. I THANK YOU. FOR THE
QUESTION- REGARDING THAT PART OF
OUR- THE- DMB REBATE PROPOSAL IS
ON. IS FOCUSED ON REGISTERED CAR
OWNERS BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
COMPONENT OF THE BROAD BASED
PACKAGE THAT INCLUDES. F. FREE
TRANSIT AND ACTIVE TRANSIT SO-
SPECIFICALLY SEVEN FIFTY NINE
DOLLARS FOR THREE FREE MONTHS OF
FREETRANSIT SERVICES SO THERE
WERE WERE OUT OR GET IT TO SOME
EXTENT WERE GETTING AT THAT. NOT
NON VEHICLE OWNERS. SO I DECIDED
NOT TO HAVE A CAR I'M GOING TO
BUY AN ELECTRIC. UDAR OR BIKE.
OF BECAUSE I'M TRYING TO LIMIT
MY AMBITIONS. AND SO I'M SOMEHOW
GOING TO GET. YEAH I KNOW YOU
SAID YOU DON'T GET BUS PASSES
BUT THAT'S THE REBATE THAT I
WOULD GET. THE FREE CHAPTER.
YEAH THERE'S A COMPONENT THAT
THAT THEY HAD THAT HAS FUNDING
FOR FREE TRANSIT SERVICE AND-
THE SPECIFICS ABOUT I HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU AS FAR AS LIKE
YOUR YOUR EXAMPLE OF- YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY THAT MAYBE DOESN'T.
EVEN TAKE TRANSIT JUST RIDES A
BIKE- I. I HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOU AS FAR AS- YES WE HAVE THAT
IN THE PAST. THAT WOULD BE GREAT
BECAUSE WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET
AT IS THERE'S FOLKS THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MADE AN
INTENTIONAL DECISION. TO NOT
HAVE A DIESEL CAR. BECAUSE
THEY'RE TRYING TO HELP US
RESOLVE OUR CLIMATE CHALLENGES.
SO THIS IS DESIGNED FOR FOLKS
THAT HAVE GAS GUZZLING ALL WHO
HAVE CARS SO FOR THOSE FOLKS WHO
SAID I'M GOING TO OPT OUT OF
THIS TO TRY TO FIND ANOTHER WAY.
AND THEY MIGHT BE MIDDLE INCOME
. I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WHAT SPACE IS AVAILABLE FOR
THEM IN THIS TAX PROPOSAL SO YOU
MIGHT NOT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THE FREE TRANSIT SERVICES THE
RESPONSE. AND SO IT MIGHT BE
GOOD JUST TO GET BACK TO ME ON
THAT. YEAH DEFINITELY DO THAT
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU. SO
NOW WE HAVE REACHED OUT THE
PORTION OF THE HEARING WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA. AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MAY INSTITUTE TIME. ON
TESTIMONY. TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENT KEEP
THEIR REMARKS WITHIN ONE MINUTE.
NOW WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THE LINE. HAS.
THE OKAY OKAY. OKAY HELLO MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISTINE ABBAS HAMILTON AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY PROJECT ACTION. I THINK
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT THE GAS CAR
THE CARS TO PEOPLE WHO DON'T
DRIVE CARS IS REALLY IMPORTANT-
MADAM CHAIR BECAUSE THERE'S ALSO
THE FOLKS WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO
DRIVE A CAR AND THAT LEADS ME TO
THE PROPOSAL FROM THE KELLY I.
T. C. COALITION WHICH- WAS NOT
ADDRESSED IN THE MAY REVISION
BUT WE ARE PROPOSING. THREE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS BE
USED FOR A ONE TIME ANTI POVERTY
CHILD TAX CREDIT THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY- HELP MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN NOT FALL
BACK INTO POVERTY AS A RESULT OF
THE- TERMINATION OF THE FEDERAL
I. C. T. C. AT THE END OF LAST
YEAR. WE'RE ALSO ASKING FOR FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION FOR CAL E. I. T.
C. MINIMUM CREDIT OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
DOLLARS FOR EACH PERSON WHO'S
ELIGIBLE WE KNOW THAT TAX X.
KELLY AT SEA IN THE C. D. C. THE
Y. C. T. C. WE KNOW. ARE
EVIDENCED BASED SALUTE. THE
PEOPLE OUT OF POP. AND WE THINK
THAT IT THERE IT IS THE MOST
RIGHTEOUS USE OF. THE SURPLUS
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS FINALLY
TWENTY MILLION ABOVE WHAT'S IN
THE GENERAL FUND IN TERMS OF.
THE OUTRAGE AND FREE TAX
PREPARATION SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
GO GET FREE HEALTHY CLAIM THESE
CREDITS THAT CALIFORNIA IS
GIVING THEM AND THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO H. AND R. BLOCK IN
SPENDING. MORE MONEY TO GET
THEIR TAXES PREPARED THAN THE
CREDIT THAT THEY WENT THERE TO
GET IN THE FIRST PLACE I THINK
WE THINK THAT'S A VERY BIG DEAL
AND FINALLY ONE LAST THING.
EVENTING GOVERNMENT THAT
INTERSECTION. FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR THESE TAX
CREDITS THAT WE'RE GIVING THEM.
SO THAT THEY THEY ACTUALLY
RECEIVE THE CREDIT IS NOT CLEAN-
FOR DEBT COLLECTION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME SHARES MEMBERS- THIS IS
PUSH ON WOULD YOU ASPIRE- I
WANTED TO MAKE MY COMMENTS ABOUT
DID THE FBI PROGRAM- I WAS
FOLLOWING LAST WEEK'S HEARING
AND JUST WANTED TO. APPRECIATE
THE EXCELLENT COME AS YOU ARE
MAKING MADAM CHAIR ON THE NEED
FOR THE FBI TO PARTNER WITH
OFFICES TO DO MORE WORK AT THIS
OUTREACH AND THAT IS WHY IT YOU
KNOW TO US AND YOU ASPIRE WE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING- FORTY OF
PID TEN MILLION ACTUALLY. DID
WAS AT THE BROADER EFFORTS THAT
WE'RE DOING WE'RE ASKING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS AS WELL WE THINK. THAT
FUNDING. IS WHAT'S GOING TO
ALLOW US AS A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO HELP WHAT CAN
DO THAT PARTNERSHIP WITH OFFICES
AND CONTINUED OUTREACH WORK TO
STUDENT BORROWERS SO WE HOPE
THAT- THAT FUNDING COULD BE.
INCLUDED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND CANNOT CRAFT. MY COMMENTS TO
PERTAIN TO THE CANNABIS
PROVISIONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE INVESTMENT OF THE TWENTY
MILLION. IN INCENTIVE FUNDING TO
ENCOURAGE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
EXPAND LEGAL RETAIL WE'RE ALSO
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
PROVISIONS THAT ZERO OUT THE
CULTIVATION TAX AND STREAMLINE
AND SIMPLIFY. THE MANNER IN
WHICH CANNABIS TAXES ARE
COLLECTED. AT THE SAME TIME WE
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH
THE LANGUAGE THAT WOULD TRIGGER
AN AUTOMATIC INCREASE IN THE
EXCISE TAX FROM 15% TO NINETEEN
PERCENT. AND WE ALSO QUESTION.
WELL GEE THAT WAS USED TO GET TO
NINETEEN PERCENT. BASED ON OUR
OWN ANALYSIS WE BELIEVE 19%
REPRESENTS A TAX INCREASE ON THE
INDUSTRY. AND IS NOT SIMPLY
ACHIEVE REVENUE NEUTRALITY. I DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY WE FULLY
CONCUR THAT REDUCING TAXES WILL
INCREASE CONSUMER PARTICIPATION.
IN THE LEGAL MARKET. AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE REQUESTING
THAT THE LANGUAGE TO REMOVE THE
AUTOMATIC AND SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE. BE RECONSIDERED AND
PLACE RIPLEY. SOME SORT OF- THAT
ALLOWS THE EXCISE TAX TO
FLUCTUATE UP OR DOWN TO MEET THE
STATE'S A DUAL GOALS OF FUNDING
VITAL PROGRAMS AND MIGRATING
CONSUMER CELLULAR THE LEGAL
MARKET THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I'M
SURE MEMBERS GRAND BARGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AS HELL HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION WE URGE YOU
INTERSECTION OF THE PROPOSED
ADAPTIVE REUSE STATUTE. AND
PROJECT HUNKY THE PROJECT HOME
KEY ALLOWS FUNDS TO BE USED TO
CONVERT HOTELS AND MOTELS ON BUT
ONLY ALLOWS PUBLIC ENTITIES TO
APPLY. THE ADAPTIVE REUSE
PROPOSAL ALLOWS NONPROFITS LIKE
HF TO APPLY BUT NOT DOES NOT
ALLOW IT TO BE USED FOR HOTELS
AND MOTELS AS A RESULT IN
NONPROFIT LIKE HF IS SHUT OUT OF
THE ABILITY TO USE THOSE FUNDS.
TO CONTAIN. TO BUILD UP AND IT'S
THAT WE'VE ALREADY DEVELOPED
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS- OUT OF
HOTELS AND MOTELS FOR EXTREMELY
AND VERY LOW INCOME PEOPLE-
INCOME PEOPLE ON BEHALF OF THE
PARENT COMPANY- I WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MICHIGAN'S
RELATIVE TO THE- CANNABIS TAX
REFORM SENATOR RUSS HAD A- ON
THE MARKET. TO THE 19% IMPACT ON
THE CONSUMER CONSUMERS ARE
ALREADY GOING INTO THE ILLEGAL
MARKET BECAUSE OF THE HIGH TAXES
IF WE INCREASE THE TAXES MORE.
THEY'RE GOING TO MOVE EVEN
FURTHER INTO THE ILLEGAL MARKET
IF YOU EVER HAVE AN OPTION TO
PURCHASE- CANNABIS YOU'LL SEE ON
THE RECEIPT THAT THAT THAT THE
EXCISE TAX IS CALLED OUT
SPECIFICALLY. SO YOU'LL KNOW.
HOW MUCH YOU'RE PAYING. SUDDENLY
GOES UP FROM 15219% WHICH IS
ACTUALLY A 26% INCREASE IN THE
ACTUAL DOLLAR AMOUNT- IT'S GOING
TO DRIVE MORE PEOPLE INTO THE-
ILLEGAL MARKET. I'M SO WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO REJECT IT EVER
BECOMING A PERMANENT PART THE
MIDDLE YEARS- I THINK THERE'S
SOME FLEXIBILITY IN THERE BUT
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND MAKING 19% PERMANENT. IS
REALLY A WE THINK A VERY BAD
IDEA OF. CONTROLLING THE-
ILLEGAL MARKET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. THANKS A MADAM
CHAIR SENATOR ROTH'S CABIN
AUSTIN REPRESENTING JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU. FIRST OF I
GOT TWO ISSUES TODAY ONE IS THE
FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT- WE WANT
TO THINK- STATE CONTROLLER BETTY
YEE FOR CO SPONSORING THAT
REQUEST WITH US- AND ALSO THE
ADMINISTRATION GOVERNOR IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PUTTING IT.
IN HIS JANUARY AND MAY REVISE-
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR US
NOT ONLY TO HELP YOU. ACHIEVE
THAT PACKS. ALSO USE FILING
TAXES- WHEN THEY'RE IN THERE YOU
KNOW TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AS YOUNG
AS EIGHTEEN- SO WE WERE GRATEFUL
FOR THAT FUNDING AND FOR THAT
FOR THAT CREDIT. BUT THE OTHER
ISSUE THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ABOUT IS THE HOME OF. THE HELP
PROGRAM. AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SOME
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE THAT
PROGRAM- WE WOULD BE VERY HAPPY
ABOUT THAT- IF IT WERE NOT TO GO
FORWARD WE WOULD REQUEST. THAT
YOU SET ASIDE WHICH IS CURRENTLY
AT ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION THAT
THAT CONTINUED THERE'S A GREAT
NEED OUT THERE. FOR PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING YOUTH-
MANY OF OUR HOMELESS YOUTH ARE
FOSTER CHILDREN AS WELL AS- YOU
KNOW. L. G. B. T. Q. SO WE WOULD
FEEL VERY STRONGLY THIS PROGRAM.
FRANKLY ANY PROGRAM THAT IS PUT
TOGETHER FOR HOMELESS. WE DO SET
ASIDE AND TARGET SPECIFICALLY
USE SO THAT THEY'RE NOT HELPS
WITH. CHRONICALLY HOMELESS-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING THANK
YOU. NEXT GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
LAST REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH ADVOCATING
FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
WHAT I'M SAYING ACKERSON MY
COMMENTS AND CATHERINE AUSTIN
THING THAT WE NEED ON. TO
SUPPORT OUR HAP PROGRAM SET
ASIDE YOUNG PEOPLE WOULD
CHALLENGE YOU TO EVEN GO EVEN
HIGHER THAN THE 10% 225% BECAUSE
WE KNOW IF WE CAN GET AHEAD OF
THIS ISSUE WE CAN REALLY HELP TO
WORK TO MITIGATE AND PREVENT ANY
HOMELESSNESS FOR ALL. AND REALLY
WE HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
REPRESENTATION THAT I'M YOUNG
PEOPLE OF COLOR THAT ARE ON THE
STREETS- AND PERCENT AND I'LL
ALSO BE T. Q. THE FORTY. NINE
WHICH IS VERY. POPULATION I AM
THE INVESTMENTS I'VE BEEN TO A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THE STATE WAS
SPENDING LESS THAN TWO MILLION
DOLLARS I'M GOING FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
SO AGAIN TO ME IT'S NEVER A
SURPRISE THAT WE HAVE SUCH A
BALLOONING PROBLEM AROUND THE
HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES IN THE
STATE BECAUSE WE HAVE UNDER
INVESTED. IN OUR YOUTH
POPULATION I GROW UP AND WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM IF WE DON'T
SUPPORT THEM DURING THE DAY AGE
THAT THEY ARE TODAY BEFORE THEY
HAD TWENTY FIVE ONLY CAN SUPPORT
THEM SOME OF THEM ARE PARENTING
THEMSELVES. AND COULD REALLY BE
ADDRESSING TO GENERATIONS OF
POVERTY AND THEY'RE SO REALLY
ENCOURAGE THAT AND PLUS THE
ONGOING AND THAT INVESTMENTS
AROUND HOME HE WOULD LOVE TO SEE
WE LOVE THAT SET ASIDE. TO BE
ABLE TO. CORRECTLY ONE BRING THE
PROGRAMS. THAT I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THE PROGRAM MEANS THAT THEY
HAVE ARE AND SHOULD BE THE ONES
TO BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR THOSE
FUNDS. AND SO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE SUPPORT ACT WHICH
SENATOR WIENER'S CHAMPION HAS
ALREADY MADE IT THROUGH THIS
HOUSE AND IT'S THE SECOND HOUSE
THERE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT. MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATOR ROB- MY NAME
IS NICHOLA DELUCA I'M HERE FOR
TWO ITEMS. THE FIRST IS ON
HOMELESSNESS. I'M HERE IF YOU
HAVE THE OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY
SCHAAF WAS THE CHAIR OF THE BIG
CITY MAYORS WHICH AS YOU KNOW
THE TOP MOST POPULATED THIRTEEN
CITIES. STRONG SUPPORT OF HAPPY.
VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OVER THE YEARS THE ASSEMBLY
SUPPORT THE GOVERNORSHIP PORT-
TOP PRIORITY IS THREE YEARS OF
FUNDING FOR HALF A BILLION A
YEAR EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THE
PROPOSAL THAT YOU ALL PUT OUT.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HAPPY
TO HELP SUPPORT AND PUSH THAT-
THE SECOND ITEM- UNFORTUNATELY
IS OPPOSITION TO. THE REVISED-
DEPARTMENT FIND ITS REVISED THE
LANGUAGE ON THE RAFT. PRIMARILY
FOR THE TOWN OF CHROME- THE CITY
OF SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO. AND HALF
MOON BAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT. MADAM CHAIR
SENATOR ROTH ALEX STORES WITH
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL INDEPENDENT
VENUE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WANT TO FIRST THANK DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AS WELL AS CALLOUS BUT
DIRECTOR GRACE SPECIFICALLY- FOR
THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
AMENDING SOME OF THE ELIGIBILITY
GUIDELINES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
VENUES GRANT PROGRAM THERE ARE A
LOT OF VENUES- AND FESTIVAL
PROMOTERS. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT ARE AWAITING THIS
CRITICALLY NEEDED AID BUT
BECAUSE OF SOME INADVERTENT
MISTAKES IN THE ELIGIBILITY
GUIDELINES THEY HAVE YET TO
RECEIVE- AID FOR BEING SHATTERED
ALMOST A YEAR AND A HALF TWO
YEARS S. REALLY THANKFUL FOR
THAT HOPEFULLY GET THOSE DOLLARS
OUT SOON ALSO ON EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE HARDEST HIT-
INDUSTRY GRANT PROGRAM TO TELL
US ABOUT ARTS. RECREATION IS A-
BREEZE- JUST DOWN THE STREET ON
A GOLDEN ONE PEARL JAM KOK
CANCELED THEIR SHOW TODAY
BECAUSE THEIR BASIS CUT COVE IT.
THE REALITY IS THAT. THEY WERE
NOT OUT OF THIS- SHOWS ARE-
ESPECIALLY FOR INDEPENDENCE MALL
OPERATOR SHOWS ARE DIFFICULT TO
BOOK- THERE IS STILL SOME
CONSUMER CONCERN. AROUND
GATHERING AND SO THE HARDEST HIT
INDUSTRIES GRANT PROGRAM WERE
REALLY HELPFUL TO SEE. SOME OF
OUR MEMBER VENUES BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDS-
AS THEY A LOT OF THE ONES WHO
DID RECEIVE. A VINNIES GOT MONEY
HAVE BURNED THROUGH IT NOW
THEY'RE STILL OPERATIONAL LOSS
SO REALLY APPRECIATE FOR THAT
PROPOSAL OF PURCHASING A GO
THROUGH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS. ADAM CAREFULLY FOR MANY
DAYS IS THE LIGHT HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS. HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA.
BURNED THE BLACK LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE. FOR PRIORITIZING
HOMEOWNERSHIP AS BUDGET. HERE
AND ESPECIALLY WITH THE COMMENTS
WE HEARD EARLIER QUESTIONINGTHE
DEPARTMENT. ABOUT THAT DOCTOR
DEGREES PROGRAM AND ITS
EXCLUSIVE NATURE- FOR HOME
OWNERSHIP TO BE ELIGIBLE
RECIPIENTS. OF FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM. EVEN THOUGH IT IS IT
SAYS RESIDENTIAL- PROJECTS IN
GENERAL AT LARGE HISTORY HAS
PROVEN THAT THESE FUNDS AND
THAT'S IT'S EXPLICITLY STATED.
THAT HOMEOWNERSHIP IS TO BE
INCLUDED. THE PROGRAM'S EXCLUDED
BY DESIGN OR DISADVANTAGES BY
DESIGN. JUST LAST YEAR WE HAD TO
RUN A PIECE OF LEGISLATION TO
ENSURE THAT THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM. COULD TREAT OWNERSHIP
APPLICATIONS EQUALLY WITH
RENTAL- PROJECT APPLICATIONS WE
REALLY HOPE TO SEE A SIMILAR
PROVISIONS. TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. THAT
WOULD- GO UP WITHOUT PROGRAMS
AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT. OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE SENATE FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
JUST I CAN- LEAVE WITHOUT
REMINDING. EVERYONE THAT CAL
HOME. CONTINUED THAT WILL BE OUT
OF. ON THE PRO DOLLARS BE GONE
THIS LAST ROUND. IF I SO THIS
YEAR SO WE REALLY HOPE- SINCE
THE MAY REVISE DID NOT INCLUDE.
MORE MONEY FOR CAL HOME THAT THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL ON AT A
MINIMUM- WILL HELP REPLENISH
THAT PROGRAM. IT IS USE IS THE
ONLY PROGRAM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT SUPPORTS NEW
PRODUCTION. FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITY THAT INCLUDES SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES MULTI FAMILY HOMES
AS WELL AS EIGHTY USE ARE ALSO
NEW CONSTRUCTION FOR EIGHTY USE.
THAT HABITAT IS ACTUALLY.
SEPARATELY CONVEY THOSE TWO AND
THE FAMILY ALSO PUBLIC HEALTH
HOME PROGRAM SO AGAIN WE HOPE
THE MINISTRATION. I WILL FOLLOW
SUIT EVENTUALLY AND THE ASSEMBLY
AS WELL IN SUPPORTING THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL TO BRING FULL
FUNDING. TECHAU HOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SO SEEING NO ONE ELSE
THAT HAS- STOOD UP TO MAKE THEIR
WAY TO THE MICROPHONE HERE. WE
ARE NOW GOING TO PUSH IT TO THE
PHONE LINE SO MODERATOR. IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. YOU WILL
THEN BE. GIVEN A LINE NUMBER AND
TAKE BACK IN THE QUEUE. YOU ARE
ON A SPEAKER PHONE AS THEY GOT
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. ONCE AGAIN IT IS ONE
THEN ZERO FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY IN THE
QUEUE RIGHT NOW. OKAY WILL HURT
WITH WINE WHAT OKAY YEAH LET'S
GET IT GOING. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR. MANAGED
CARE MEMBERS OF RELIEF HAVE YOU
GOT AFTER THE LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY THANK YOU FOR THE HEARING
TODAY ON THE TOPIC OF TAX
CREDITS YOU LIKE THE RATE
WORKERS TAX CREDIT PROPOSAL
THAT'S NOT IN THE REVISED WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO ALL UNION MEMBERS
INCLUDING OUR HOPE. I'VE BEEN A
RECORD SEVENTEEN TRUMP'S ATTACKS
SECTION FOR UNION HE'S UP AT
THAT LEVEL. ON A STATE LEVEL YOU
NEED YOU CAN BE DEDUCTED I DON'T
MAKE FUN OF ISSUE WITH WITH
WORKERS NOT MAKING UP THE-
ITEMIZE ON THEIR TAX RETURNS
BACK WITH THE BENEFIT. THEIR
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN TAX
CREDIT INCENTIVES PROVIDE
BUSINESSES THEY WANT TO ENSURE
ACCURATE FOR WORKERS. IT'S ONLY
FOR A- BUT YOU USE THEM FOR. TO
CUT. FOR THE PROPOSAL TO GET UP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
CARE MEMBERS I'M FOR ALL THAT
YOU DO MY NAME IS ALEXIS BERRIES
AND I AM FROM CEMEX HELP COUNTY
OR INTO THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
I'VE ALSO EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS AS I TRANSITIONED
OUT IN BOTH EXPERIENCE HELPED TO
SHAPE ME AND THE ONLY REASON I'M
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE THINGS
THAT SHAPE BETTER OUTCOMES. I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SEVERAL
ITEMS THAT WILL SUPPORT
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST IMPORTING THE
REQUEST TO MAKE IT HAPPEN
LOOKING FOR SUPPORT FROM YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THANK
YOU I'M YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
REQUEST THANKS FOR YOUR ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN THIRTY DASH ZERO
ZERO ONE DE ZERO ZERO ZERO ONE
REGARDING YOUR TAX CREDIT YOUNG
KEPT HELP ACCREDITING CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
POSITIONS THANK YOU AGAIN FOR.
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
ONLINE AND- THIRTY NINE THE
PHONE HAD. AFTERNOON CARRYING
MEMBERS IS GAINING A NEW
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE FAMILY
FARMERS CAP. AT PRESENT OVER
EIGHT THOUSAND SMALL AND MID
SCALE CALIFORNIA FAMILY FARMERS
AND I'VE WORKED FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS AND YEAH I RECALL TRANSFER
NOT FIRING UP THE SCENE REALLY.
AND I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT AGAIN
THAT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
AROUND SUPPORTING. SMALL SCALE
FARMERS WITH ON DROUGHT RELIEF.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
EIGHTEEN POINT SEVEN FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR CAR GOT IN THE
DIRECT ECONOMIC RELIEF FOR
CALIFORNIA SMALL IN HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED FARMERS FROM THE
SMALL AGRICULTURAL BUSINESS
DROUGHT RELIEF PROGRAM AT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SO BAD
. THIS RELIEF WILL HELP MANY
SMALL SCALE FARMERS 75% OF OUR
SMALL SCALE GROWERS RELY ON LESS
THAN A THOUSAND DOLLARS GROSS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
GROSS SALES ANNUALLY. THAT'S A
THIRTY TO FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
RELIEF GRANT WOULD MAKE A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT IN THE FIRST
BUILDING TO GET THROUGH THE
SECOND YEAR OF THE ROCK RECORD
BREAKING DROUGHT. ON THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
LEADERSHIP THAT'S FINE. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. NEXT CALLER
WILL BE LINED NUMBER FORTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS DANE
HUTCHINGS TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF REDWOOD CITY
FOSTER CITY BELMONT AND
HILLSBOROUGH- TESTIFYING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT- TO THE
PARTICULAR BILL REALLY SPECIFIC
TO THE DLF AND INSUFFICIENT YOU
WRAP BACK CELLS. IN ITEM THAT
WAS PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED BY THE
COMMITTEE IN AN EFFORT TO EVADE
ITS LEGAL OBLIGATION TO BACK THE
LOCAL AGENCIES FOR OUR FAIR
SHARE OF VEHICLE LICENSING FEES
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD AMEND THE
REVENUE TAX CODE TO INSTEAD
PERMANENTLY CAP ACCESS RAP
REVENUES THEREBY SHIFTING LOCAL
DEDICATED REVENUE USED TO PAY
YOUR STATE OBLIGATION UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL LOCAL CAP EXCESS YOU
RAFFLE DECLINED IN VALUE WHILE
THE STATE ABSORBS ALL OF FUTURE
GROWTH. AS A RESULT CEMETERY
COUNTY AND ITS CITIES LOSE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR FUNDS ARE ALREADY
BUDGETED BY MANY MUNICIPALITIES
FOR PORTABLE SERVICES THE RAF
MONEY'S COMPRISE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF REDWOOD CITY'S
OVERALL GENERAL FUND REVENUES
AND FIND CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
SIR THE SET SERVICES FIRE.
HOMELESSNESS SUPPORT INFORMAL
HOUSING PROGRAMS FOR BELMONT
THIS ROLE RESULT IN 20%
REDUCTION IN ITS POLICE FORCE IN
60% OF IT ORGANIZED MAINTENANCE
WORKERS. FOR FOSTER CITY THIS
RESULT IN REDUCTIONS SEVEN
POLICE OFFICERS AND TEN
MAINTENANCE WORKERS THREE PUBLIC
WORKS- MAINTENANCE WORKERS AND
FOR HEALTH. THIS INTO A 11%
REDUCTION STAFF SERVICES. ALL
TOLD. THIS PROPOSAL IS A
FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT IN WAS
PROPOSED WITH TOTAL DISREGARD
FOR SERVICE REDUCTIONS PERFORMED
BY LOCAL BARGAINING GROUPS
ACROSS THE COUNTY WE STRONGLY
URGE THE COMMITTEE REJECT THIS
ITEM WHEN APPROPRIATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. THIS CALL
WILL BE LINED NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
BEFORE THAT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO
MAINTAIN THE PRODUCT SO THAT
SOME OF YOU HAVE BEEN GOOD FOR
BOTH THANK CALLING TO REPORT
ISSUES. FIRST TRUMP SUPPORTER OF
THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION INVENTION TO CONDUCT
A STUDENT BORROWER OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THEY ALSO
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS PURPOSE
FOR A TOTAL OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS. THE STUDENT LOAN.
COMPLEX AND ALWAYS IN FLUX THE
AVERAGE FARMER NAVIGATE WITHOUT
ASSISTANCE. EXISTING RESOURCES
ARE INSUFFICIENT TO BORROWERS
WHO NEED HELP. PLEASE RETURN TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND INVESTMENT OF THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE FBI.
SECOND I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THE ISSUES AND
THE TAX REVIEW CONTROLLED
SECTION OF TODAY'S AGENDA. HE IS
THE GOVERNOR CONTINUATION OF THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL TO REMOVE THE
ONE DOLLAR EARNINGS REQUIREMENT
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT AND
FOR INCLUDING INVESTMENT INTO
THE FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT.
HOWEVER WE STRONGLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO MORE TO
PROVIDE TARGETED INVESTMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILY EXPANDING
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT ALL
AGES AND MAKING UP HER CHILD. AT
THE UNITHOLDERS ABOUT ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA ARE FALLING BACK INTO
POVERTY OUR WATCHES HERE.
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS
LEGISLATION TO ESTABLISH A
CALIPHATE PP MINIMUM OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS.
EXPAND FREE TAX PREPARATION
FUNDING SO MORE FAMILIES CAN
RECEIVE THE TAX BENEFIT OUTLINED
IN SENATE BUDGET PLAN INSURE TAX
CREDITS FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ARE NOT INTERCEPTED
BY THE STATE. WE HOPE YOU WILL
CONTRIBUTE INVESTMENTS WITHIN
YOUR FINAL BUDGET DECISIONS
THANK. YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MINORITY. I
HAVE A NINE FORTY FOUR OKAY AND
THAT WE ARE MINOR COMMENTS WITH
THE OTHER CANDIDATES TRADED
THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED AWAITED TAX
REFORM AND ARE CONCERNED WITH
THE COMPLEX METHODOLOGY AND
AUTOMATIC INCREASE OF 19% EXCISE
TAX WE WILL CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO HELP PROVIDE RELIEF
TO THE LEGAL MARKET. SECONDLY WE
SUPPORT A CANNABIS GRANT PROGRAM
TO EXPAND LOCAL RETAIL ACCESS
THANK. YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT PLEASE ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE NUMBERS ON AUDREY RETIRED
CHECK ON BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE
OF COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
FOR CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
REVISED EXPECTED ROCKED A LITTLE
BIT WITH- CHANGE CURRENT LAW IN
A WAY THAT SIGNIFICANTLY HARMED
COUNTIES AND CITIES LIKE IN A
TAIL. LIGHT PRMANENTLY CAPPING
E. RAP AND THAT WOULD BE
RETURNED TO THEM AFTER THE FULL
AND DATE AND INSTEAD USE OUR
LOCAL TAX REVENUES TO PAY THE
STATE IN LITTLE BLF OBLIGATION
IF ENACTED THIS TRAVELING WHICH
WOULD CAUSE SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL LOSSES THE LOCAL
AGENCY REVENUES AND REQUIRED
REDUCTIONS IN CRITICAL PUBLIC
SERVICES. ULTIMATELY RESULTING
IN THE FIELD COUNTY AND ITS
pMILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
WE'VE ALREADY BUDGETED FOR
CRITICAL LOCAL SERVICES WE URGE
YOU TO REJECT THE TRADE OF THE
LANGUAGE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FORTY SIX THE PLAYERS THAT I
HAVE. GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRIN
MEMBERS DANIEL GOOD TERRY GOING
TO HELP THE CONSUMER FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA WHICH STANDS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. BUREAU
NEEDED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
CONDUCT THEIR WORK PROPERLY AND
TO AFFECT WE PRIORITIZED
CONSUMERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT PLEASE. ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ANGELA PERRY WITH THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
BECAUSE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE INVESTMENT IN
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION WHICH
SERVES AS THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE FOR STUDENTS WHO ENROLL
IN PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
PROGRAMS. IF YOU'RE A SERVICE IN
A CENTRAL FUNCTION FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THE AGENCY
HAS STRUGGLED WITH UNSTABLE
FUNDING AS A RESULT OF AN
OUTDATED FEE MODEL THE THREE
YEAR INVESTMENT OUTLINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE THAT MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL WILL ALLOW THE
BUREAU TO ADDRESS THEIR CURRENT
FISCAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND THEN
GIVE THEM TIME TO DEVELOP A NEW
FEED MODEL WHICH THEY CAN THEN
BRING BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
FOR CONSIDERATION. AND EBELING
THEM TO ACHIEVE THE LONG TERM
FISCAL STABILITY NEEDED TO
AFFECT CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS PROPOSAL I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THE INVESTMENT IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION IN ORDER TO CONDUCT
STUDENT BORROWER OUTREACH AND
EDUCATIONAL CAMPAIGNS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
PLEASE. NINE FORTY NINE SO I
HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SAMANTHA
THANK WHAT'S NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
FIRST ONE EXPRESSED THEIR STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION TO CONDUCT OUR OUR
REGION EDUCATION CAMPAIGN WE
WOULD ALSO REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY MILLION FOR THIS PURPOSE
FOR TOTAL THIRTY MILLION A KEY
PART OF THE DFK PLAN WILL BE TO
LEVERAGE TRUSTED MESSENGERS TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
GRANT FISHER ACTUALLY REACHING
THROUGH THE BARS DIRECTLY TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AN INVESTMENT OF
THIRTY MILLION TO THE FBI. ON
SECOND ALTHOUGH WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE ADMINISTRATION
TO MODERNIZE THEIR OPERATIONS
WITHOUT A RACIAL EQUITY LINES WE
ARE CONCERNED AGENCIES PROGRAMS
AND POLICIES WILL CONTINUE TO
PERPETUATE SYSTEMIC RACISM WE
HOPE THE COMMITTEE WILL ALSO
CONSIDER FUNDING SP SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR PAN TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
PATHWAYS TO MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES AND FINALLY
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
AND THE MAY REVISE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE SENATE
SUPPORT INCLUDE THIS IN THE
FINAL STATE BUDGET THANK. YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE
. MODERATOR. NINE FIFTY TWO SO I
HAVE. GOOD AFTERNOON JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION THE
STATE'S LICENSES. CONTACT US TAX
REFORM PROPOSAL THAT WE
DISCUSSED TODAY. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ADVANTAGES TO THE
PROPOSAL THAT'S CONTAINED IN THE
REVISED HOWEVER OUR MEMBERS-
HAVE MAJOR CONCERNS IN THE TAX
PLAN. BASED ON THE AUTOMATIC
TRIGGER THE 90% EFFECTIVE TAX
RATE. WHICH WOULD BE A TAX BASE
FARE TO THE CURRENT TAX
STRUCTURE IN PLACE. ADDITIONALLY
OUR MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED WITH
THE IMPLICATIONS OF THE TAX
COLLECTION SHIFT AND THE IMPACT-THAT HAS DISTRIBUTORS ABILITY TO
COLLECT PAYMENT FOR GOODS. TO
ADDRESS THIS WE ARE LOOKING AT
OFF THE SHELF SOLUTIONS LIKE
ESTABLISHMENT OF PRIVATE LAW
THIS IS ANOTHER DISCRETE ALCOHOL
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE
MINISTRATION THESE CONCEPTS
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
NINE FORTY EIGHT GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
PERSONALLY NOT TO BE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATE AND
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS HARD
HIT INDUSTRIES GRANT PROGRAM AS
ARTS ENTERTAINMENT RECREATION
HAVE SUFFERED DEVASTATING
REVENUE AND JOB LOSSES AND IT'S
- HAD NOT SEEN A REBOUND TO THE
PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS WERE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE APPROPRIATION OF
SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAMS. AND A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA IS
GRANT PROGRAM CULTURE PETITIONS
RELIEF FUNDING AND THE NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS GRANT PROGRAM WE
HAVE ALL YOUR WORK ON ALL THESE
PROGRAMS AND ENSURE THAT THE
STATUTORY CHANGES ARE CRITICAL
IN ENSURING THAT THE FUNDING YOU
APPROPRIATE LAST YEAR GET IT
INTENDED RECIPIENTS WE URGE YOU
TO INCLUDE THESE ITEMS. INTO
YOUR- BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MARK NEXT PLEASE. HE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND SET UP THIS IS
PAUL YODER ON BEHALF OF THE NAPA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS NAPA
COUNTY NEED YOUR HELP ON THE VLF
ACCESS YOUR APP ISSUE. IN THE
NEXT BUDGET YEAR THE LAST ONE OF
FIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN NAPA
COUNTY WILL BECOME BASIC AID. AT
THAT POINT THE COUNTY THE CITIES
THE TOWN AND THE DISTRICTS
SPECIAL DISTRICTS. WILL START
LOSING FORTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR WE PROACTIVELY CANDIDATE
MINISTRATION OF FINANCE. AND
SUGGESTED LANGUAGE AND INSTEAD
WHAT WE GOT BACK IN RETURN WAS
THE LANGUAGE WE NOW NEED YOU TO
REJECT. ITS CURATIVE WE NEED YOU
TO HELP US SIT BACK DOWN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION TRY TO IRON OUT
SOMETHING THAT'S FAIR AT ALL ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MODERATOR HOW MANY
MORE PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE. WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FOUR
OKAY NEXT CALLER. MODERATOR CAN
YOU QUEUE UP THE NEXT CALLER.
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LEO
GOLDBERG AND CO DIRECTOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CAN YOU ENTRUST
THAT WORKS I'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO
THE TRAILER BILL AMENDING THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION HELPING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM. THE
CUMULATIVE NETWORK CHAMPIONSHIP
A YEAR AGO AND WERE EAGERLY
AWAITING ITS ROLLOUT NEEDS FOR
THAT FUNDING REMAINS URGENT AS
EVER- HOWEVER WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROPOSED
INCREASE IN THE CAPPERS MINISTRY
FUNDS IN THE TRAILER BILL FOR
THE INCREASE. OF THE MINISTER'S
SPENDING FROM 5220% OF THE
PROGRAM THEY'LL BE CRIPPLING TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROGRAM FUNDS- AND WE'D LIKE TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT EXACTLY THE
BREAKDOWN. OF THE MINISTRY OF
SOUND. I KNOW. ARE CONCERNED
THAT WE NEED TO A LOT. FUNDING
FOR THE ACTUAL PROGRAM WITH THE
ACQUISITION OF PRESERVATION OF
AT RISK HI. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THIS TRAILER BILL
GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPLORE. INCLUDING THE COMMUNITY
ANTI DISPLACEMENT PRESERVATION
PROGRAM THAT CAP. INTO THE FIFTH
PROGRAM FRAMEWORK SO KATHY IS A
NOTHER PROGRAM- PRESERVATION
PROGRAM- POSE FOR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING THIS
YEAR. WE THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AS A COMPLIMENT- AND
WHILE WE'RE LOOKING UP THE
STREET LEVEL WE THINK THERE'S A
REAL OPPORTUNITY. TO BRING
CAPTAIN TO CREATE ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCIES AND NOT REQUIRES A
DRAFTING GUIDELINES THINGS LIKE
THAT- SO WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING
AT THAT OVER THE NEXT FEW DAYS
AS I WOULD LOOK AT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOUR NEXT CALLER. NINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MARTY REGAN WITH LARKIN STREET
YOUTH SERVICES IN SAN FRANCISCO
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC WILL
CONTINUE HAVING LASTING ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES FOR YOU FOLLOWING
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT RECESSION
EMPLOYMENT RATE OF YOUTH AGES
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR WITH MORE
THAN 18% OR TWICE THE OVERALL
EMPLOYMENT RATE FOR BLACK AND
BROWN YOUTH IT ROSE TO THIRTY
PERCENT. WE ARE SEEING THE SAME
DEDICATING IMPACTING THE
PANDEMIC AND WE ARE EXTREMELY
CONCERNED ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE
GETTING STUCK IN A CYCLE OF
POVERTY AND HOMELESSNESS FOR
EXAMPLE SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH
WHO HAD SUPPORT IN COLLEGE HAVE
LOST. INCOME SUPPORT LIKE WORK
STUDY PROGRAMS AND ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
MAKING THEM EVEN MORE. ALMOST WE
SUPPORT THE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THE HEALTH PROGRAM INCLUDING YOU
SET ASIDE AND URGE YOU TO
INCREASE THE MINIMUM TO TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. OFF THE 10% IS
KEEN IS THE MAX AMOUNT WITHOUT
CONCERN FOR WHETHER THIS REALLY
MAKES SENSE TO SUPPORT NEEDS IF
YOU WITH ME ON THE STREET.
SOLVING YOUTH HOMELESSNESS IS A
CRITICAL PART OF ENDING
CALIFORNIA'S LARGER HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. BECAUSE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIENCE YOU. STRANGE THING
HOME ARE FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY
THAN THEIR PEERS TO BECOME
HOMELESS ADULT. 50% OF THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS. POPULATION
HAD THEIR FIRST EXPERIENCE OF
HOMELESSNESS WHEN THEY WERE
UNDER TWENTY FIVE. SECONDLY IT'S
TAKE HOME TO FINDING. HAS BEEN
PHENOMENAL FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IF NONPROFITS COULD ACCESS AND
THE FIVE THIS FUNDING WE WILL
ENSURE THAT MORE YOUTH SPECIFIC
HOUSING IS CREATED. WE ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT THE SUPPORT ACT
CHAMPIONED BY SENATOR WIENER
THAT IS CURRENTLY. IN THE SYSTEM
WE HAVE IN COMMITTEE AND WOULD
MAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY AVAILABLE
TO NONPROFIT YOUTH SERVICE
PROVIDERS WE KNOW THAT YOU
SPECIFIC SERVICE HERE. I WANT
YOU RAFAEL IS BECAUSE YOU'RE
OVER YOUR MANY HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
INTERVENTION FOR YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
. MODERATORS. NINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ROADKILL AND TODAY
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF UNITED
WAY CALIFORNIA AND ALSO AS A
PERSON WHO HAS EXPERIENCED FIRST
HAND THE ADVERSE EFFECTS OF
POVERTY HAVE FROM CHILDREN
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH POVERTY IS
LINKED WITH MANY NEGATIVE
CONDITION INCLUDING HOMELESSNESS
INADEQUATE NUTRITION AND- HEALTH
. IN MY PERSONAL LIVES THE
VARIANCE POVERTY BECAME THE ROOT
CAUSE. OF ISOLATION ADDICTION
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WITHIN MY
FAMILY WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN. TODAY
THE FIFTY FIFTY THE ISSUES IN
THE TAX REBATE PROPOSAL SECTION
OF THE AGENDA AND STRONGLY URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
TARGETED INVESTMENTS FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. THAT ARE
LIVING IN POVERTY IN OUR STATE.
THAT WE SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF
THE WIFEY KEITH B. OF ALL AGES
ALL AGES. AND MAKE IT A PER
CREDIT PER CHILD CREDIT AS DAVID
HELD THAT THAT THAT ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA ARE AT RISK OF
FALLING BACK INTO POVERTY. WE
ALSO URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ESTABLISH A KALYAN PC MINIMUM OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS-
EXPAND FREE TAX PREPARATION
FUNDING SO MORE FAMILIES CAN.
DETECT BENEFITS AND TO ENSURE
TAX CREDITS FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ARE NOT INTERCEPTED
BY THE STATE. WE HOPE YOU WILL
PUSH THE CONTESTANTS WITHIN YOUR
FINAL BUDGET DECISION TO SUPPORT
THE WEALTHIER WELLBEING.
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. NINE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS GO AHEAD. CALIFORNIA
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORTED THE
PROPOSAL RELATED TO THE
EXPANSION THAT THE YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT FOR FAMILIES WITH
ZERO HEALTH INCOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. FIVE FIFTY SEVEN SO I HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANNA JOHNSON
CALLING FROM RICHMOND CALIFORNIA
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE COFFEE IS TAX CREDIT AND THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT
DEPLOYMENT ECHO WHAT OTHERS HAVE
ALREADY SAID IN PUBLIC COMMENTS
ABOUT AN EXPANDING THE TAX
CREDIT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NINE FIFTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
ANDY ABOUT MILLION I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF JOHN BURTON%
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM WHICH INCLUDES A YOUTH
CERTIFIED TO ADDRESS SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE OF YOUR ALMOST NOTHING
CALIFORNIA. J. MAY HAVE ISSUED
FOR PUBLICATIONS ON HALF AND ITS
PREDECESSOR IN FRONT OF THE
PROGRAM IS AN EFFECTIVE STRATEGY
TO ADDRESS YOUTH HOMELESSNESS.
IT EXPANDED THE CONTINUUM OF
HOUSING OPTIONS FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH AN INTEGRATED UNIT INTO
THE LOCAL HOMELESS RESPONSE
NETWORK. CITIES AND COUNTIES
REPORT THE CAP YOU SET ASIDE AS
A SINGULAR STRATEGY. PREVENT
ADULT HOMELESSNESS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY AFTER THIS IS OVER
ELEVEN THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE
TAKING THEM OFF OF THE STREETS
OUT OF HARM'S WAY AND ON THE
PATH TO ECONOMIC SECURITY. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN HALF. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
MODERATOR. NINE TWELVE YOU MIGHT
NOT HAVE BEEN. MADAM CHAIR LUCY
SALCEDO CARTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT WE THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE OFFICE OF
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAD. TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS CODE NINETEEN RELIEF
GRANT PROGRAM AND THE CALVIN YOU
GRANT PROGRAM TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO THESE PROGRAMS FOR
NONPROFITS. BUT PLEASED TO SEE
THAT THE PROPOSED STATUTORY
CHANGES FOR THESE GRANT PROGRAMS
REFLECT THE CONVERSATION AND
NONPROFIT APPLICANTS NEEDS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THOSE CHANGES. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR TEN MILLION FOR
OUTREACH TO STUDENT BORROWERS IN
FACT WE BELIEVE THE AMOUNT
NEEDED FOR THESE EFFORTS AS
THIRTY MILLION- THERE ARE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SUPPORT STUDENT
BORROWERS NOW WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL AT THIRTY
MILLION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS MY
NAME IS IN A FEW MINUTES AND I
AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF GRIEF
AND TOP RB CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTOR
FOR THE PUBLIC OUT ARMED WHILE
THE MAJOR VISION HOPING CREDIT
REPORT THE FHA INSURED THAT THEY
HAVE AVAILABLE EMERGENCY FUND
FOR UNANTICIPATED. COVERED BY
STEPHEN MERCHANT BARCLAYS- PHONE
NUMBER FIVE. FOR QUITE. FOR A
MINUTE. THIRTY TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED CHILDREN ORPHANED BY
CRICKET NINETEEN. I'M TALKING
ACROSS THE STATE. REQUEST TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR FUNDS TO BE ALLOCATED TO
PUBLISH SUCH AN ACCOUNT FOR THE
FOLDABLE YOU. END UP WITH A COPY
FOR THE ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY.
EIGHT WE WANT. THAT IT
PRIORITIZING THAT IN EUROPE A
BUDGET PRIORITIES I AM JUST
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU FOR
INVESTING. IN YOUR FINAL BUDGET
DECISIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
PROBABLY. THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NINE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN BUT IF I HAD.
NINE FIFTY EIGHT OR NINE AND. I
THANK THE AIRLINES HAVE BEEN.
MMHM. ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
AND- GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS LINDA
FRANK- CALLING ON BEHALF OF
GRACE AND CHILD POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN. SPEAKING TO
THE THREE GRACES THE TAX REBATE
PROPOSAL INCLUDED ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WELL WE APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
CONTINUATION OF HIS JANUARY
PROPOSAL ALONGSIDE OTHER APPS IF
YOU'VE HEARD FROM WE ALSO
STRONGLY URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO MORE TO EXPAND THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT ALL AGES AND
BAKE IT FOR TRIAL. TO ESTABLISH
THE COUNTY IDC MINIMUM OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS
EXPAND FREE TAX PREPARATION
FUNDING AND ENSURE TAX CREDIT
FOR LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE
NOT ACCEPTED BY THE STATE WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK. THAT YOU
INCLUDE THESE INVESTMENTS IN
YOUR FINAL BUDGET DECISIONS
THANK YOU THANK. YOU MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. R. NINE NINE ZERO
NINE SEPTEMBER. EACH OF THE
PROGRAM. MIND YOUR MIND AND I
THINK THE- WHY DO YOU FIND THAT
. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS COURTNEY BALL
TO SEE WHAT THE YMCA BENDIGO
COUNTY CALLING WITH PARTNERS AND
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOUTH WE HAVE OVER FIFTY YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE IN WORKING WITH
YOUTH AND FAMILIES WHO ARE IN
SHELTERS AND ARE CALLING TO
SUPPORT ONGOING FUNDING TO HELP
PROGRAM. WHICH INCLUDES A SET
ASIDE FOR YOU. FOR ME IT'S AND
YOU GO AND WHAT IS THIS GOING.
WE URGE YOU TO INCREASE THE
MINIMUM THRESHOLD IS TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. OFF THE MUNICIPALITIES.
THE 10% THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
FUN WITHOUT CONCERN FOR WHETHER
THAT MAKES SENSE TO SUPPORT
NEEDS LIVING ON THE STREET.
APRIL TWENTY NINETEEN ANNUAL
HOMELESS ASSESSMENT REPORT TO
CONGRESS CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IN THE COUNTRY. ELEVEN THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED AND NINETY THREE
YOU BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWELVE
AND TWENTY FOUR. IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY OUR COUNTY INCREASED
FUNDING TO USED TO HAVE TO AND
WE HAVE EXPERIENCED REMARKABLE
OPPORTUNITY TRANSFORMER SYSTEM.
IN AN EVIDENCE INFORMED HUMAN
CENTERED COLLABORATION ACROSS
YOUR PROVIDERS WITH THE HELPING
OUR YOUTH PROGRAM IT IS WORKING
WITH OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
DOCUMENTED IMPRESSIONS WITH
YOUNG BOTH AND OVER A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY YOUNG PEOPLE
PERMANENTLY HOUSED IN UNDER TWO
YEARS. IT IS SCALABLE WITH
INCREASED FUNDING. FOR THE WALL
HOME GIVE AN EXCELLENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OTHER NONPROFIT A PROGRAM THAT
WE CANNOT I FEEL LIKE WE WOULD
ENSURE MORE- YOU SPECIFIC
HOUSING IS CREATED. IN SAN
DIEGO- HOME KEY PROPOSAL DOES
NOT INCLUDE A COMPONENT. WE FIND
THE SUPPORT ACT CHAMPIONED BY
SENATOR WIENER THAT WOULD DO
JUSTICE AND IS CURRENTLY IN
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
MODERATE NEXT CALL. FOR THREE
NINE SEVEN NINE SIXTY THREE. HI
TRUCK BELL WAS CONSUMER REPORTS
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
TEN MILLION- APPROPRIATION
RECOMMEND BACKUP IN THE NEWSROOM
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION TO
CONDUCT THE STUDENT BORROWER
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION CAMPAIGN
. WE ALSO REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY MILLION FOR A TOTAL OF
THIRTY MILLION. CALIFORNIA HAS%
OVER FOUR MILLION STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS EXISTING RESOURCES ARE
INSUFFICIENT TO ASSIST THE MANY
BORROWERS WHO NEED HELP. TENS OF
THOUSANDS ARE FACING DELINQUENCY
AND DEFAULT MANY OTHERS NEED
HELP APPLYING FOR LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS AND
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS AUTHORIZED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. BY
RESISTANCE WILL HELP- RECEIVE
MONEY AND CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION AND EVEN GET MARRIE
BUY CARS PURCHASE HOMES AND SAVE
FOR RETIREMENT- FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A PROACTIVE
INVESTMENT OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE FBI. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING A MAP OF DEFINITELY
THE HOME CARE MEMBERS BY NAME
BUT ALI KING WOULD BE ABOUT THE
PROJECT CALIFORNIA- PROBABLY
REVISED MAKE BOND INVESTORS ON
CONCRETE AND PROGRAMS THAT HELP
OUR MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
OUR STATE WILL NOT MEANINGFULLY
EXPAND. EQUITY ISSUES- POLICIES
ARE OT FULLY RESTORED AND
IMPLEMENTED IN A CONSISTENT AND
COORDINATED WAY WE URGE THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATIVE THAT'S
AWFULLY FUN TO BE COMPLETED BY
SENATOR CAMP WHICH IS DOUBLED
HIS OFFICE IN RACIAL EQUITY AND
PROVIDE PEOPLE BUT VISION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. WITH STATE
GOVERNMENT THE WHOLE POLITICALLY
ADDRESS RACIAL INEQUITIES THE
WHOLE THING ALL THE DEPARTMENTS
ARE WORKING AND HAVE SUPPORT
NEEDED TO ACHIEVE THEIR EQUITY
GOLD ACTIVE SILOS. AND
RECREATING THE WESLEY ALL WEEK-
AGAIN WE URGE THE GOVERNMENT
MUST SUCCESSFULLY WITHOUT FULLY
FUND THE SQ SEVEN PM FOR THE
BENEFIT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
NOT JUST THE PRIVILEGED FEW.
THANK. YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NINE YOU FOR
REMINDING OPEN SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
DON'T. YEAH COMMUTE CHAIR MY IS
CHRISTINA FOR I AM NOT BOSS USED
FROM BAKERSFIELD HEALTH WHICH IS
PROFOUND I'M CALLING THE BOARD
FOR THE REQUEST. THREE OF THE I.
SEVEN SEVEN ZERO DASH ZERO ONE
DASH ZERO ZERO ONE REGARDING THE
PARTIALLY AFFECT CREDIT YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
POSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ASKING HER CALLING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA SEVERAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ECHOING THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S AMENDED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REGARDING
THE TREATMENT OF ACCESS HE RAPS.
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
REJECTION OF THAT EITHER THE
LANGUAGE AND ENCOURAGE- ALL THAT
AFFECTED AND CITIES AND COUNTIES
AS WELL AS THE ASSOCIATION. DOWN. AND COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS
THAT- DON'T I HAVE A DRAMATIC
IMPACT ON AND HE'S AFFECTED.
OPERATOR I ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL FOR IT
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN HOME
KEY AS WELL AS THE FUNDING. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO COLLABORATING
WITH- THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION ON FUTURE ROUNDS
OF HALF A GRAM AS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR HOW
MANY FOLKS ARE IN THE QUEUE.
YEAH WE HAVE NINE OKAY GREAT
NEXT UP YEAH NINE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
QUINCY ON BEHALF OF THE HUMBLE
KIND OF OR SUPERVISORS WE WANT
TO THANK ADMINISTRATION- NICOLE
ELLIOTT IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE CAMPUS TAX
REFORM PROPOSAL IN THE MAY
REVISE AND WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL. THE CURRENT
CULTIVATION TAXES ON IS
INHERENTLY UNFAIR AND IT'S A
THREAT TO THE VIABILITY OF THE
ENTIRE ENTIRE LEGAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ANTI HUMBOLDT ECONOMY.
AS YOU MAY KNOW HUMBLE HAS MORE
STATE LICENSED CULTIVATORS THAN
ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA AND SO
MANY OF THEM HAVE LOST
EVERYTHING HERE IT'S ALSO A
THREAT IN HUMBOLDT TWO IMPORTANT
SERVICES WE PROVIDE TO CHILDREN.
CURRENTLY WE PROVIDE- FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
OF OUR LOCAL CULTIVATION EXCISE
TAX TO FIRST FIVE HUMBOLDT THE
COMBAT ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES OR ACES IN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY HAVE THE HIGHEST RATE OF
A HOUSE IN THE STATE BUT THIS
YEAR WE WERE FORCED TO
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE OUR LOCAL
CULTIVATION TAX TO HELP THE
INDUSTRY. MAKING IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
FIGHT ACES IF CULTIVATORS
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO THE
CULTIVATION BACK AT THE STATE
LEVEL WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD THESE CONTRIBUTIONS SMALL
CULTIVATORS ARE BEING PUT OUT OF
BUSINESS LEFT AND RIGHT. AND
THIS PROPOSAL GIVES THEM A
FGHTING CHANCE ANIMAL COUNTY IN
THE SOLUTION WE APPRECIATE
FINANCES OFFERED TO USE GENERAL
FUND TO BACK FILL IF NEEDED AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE LARGER
CARBURETORS CONTINUE TO PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT LOWERING THE TAX RATE AT
THE POINT OF SALE SHOULD
INCREASE SALES AND PROVIDE THE
REVENUE NEEDED FOR PUBLIC
SERVICES. AND WE'RE ALSO DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT INCREASING THE
EXCISE TAX AND. 90% IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT.
MODERATOR MIND. TWENTY NINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THANK YOU PRESSING THEM FOR A
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SEVERAL
ITEMS IN WITHIN THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY WAS FOR
THE **** IT'S TAX CREDIT
EXTENSION HELP RESOLVE BUSINESS
HARD HIT INDUSTRIES GRANT
PROGRAM CALIFORNIA SMALL
AGRICULTURAL BUSINESS PROPERLY
GRANT PROGRAM THE FEDERAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ADMINISTRATION GRANT AWARDS. WE
APPROPRIATION OF SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAMS IN THE
FUTURE PROTECTION PROGRAM
CONFORMITY IS ADAMS I HOPE
YOU'LL CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND
ALLOW FOR LAWYERS THE LEADING IN
MANY WAYS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. LINE
FIFTY FIVE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MONICA LAST
FALL I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
GOLDEN STATE OPPORTUNITY AND I'M
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO THE
ISSUES IN THE TAX REBATE
PROPOSAL SECTION OF TODAY'S
AGENDA WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR CONTINUATION OF A
GENEROUS PROPOSAL TO REMOVE THE
DOLLAR EARNING REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE WHITE B. T. C. AND FRANKLY
NOT INVESTMENT INTO THE PROPERTY
TAX CREDIT HOWEVER WE MUST
STRONGLY URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO MORE TO PROVIDE TARGET
INVESTMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES BY EXPANDING THE Y. C.
D. G. WALK AGES AND MAKING IT
FOR CHILD. ADDITIONALLY WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ESTABLISH A
CALLIE IDC MINIMUM OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS
EXPANDS FREE TAX PREPARATION
FUNDING SO MORE FAMILIES CAN
RECEIVE THESE TAX BENEFITS AS
OUTLINED IN THE SENATE BUDGET
PLAN AND ENSURE TAX CREDITS FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE NOT
INTERCEPTED BY THE STATE WE HOPE
YOU WILL CONTRIBUTE INVESTMENTS
WITHIN YOUR FINAL BUDGET
DECISIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER. OUR NEXT
CALLER LINE TWENTY FOUR LINE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LIFE. THANK
YOU- MY NAME IS AVID GRIFFIN
I'M HERE BEFORE YOU IS THE
CURRENT CHAIR OF THE ALBANY
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS-
SPEAKING HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE- HE RAPS TRAILER BUILT-
FIRSTLY- HELPING COUNTY
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREES WITH A
COMMENT LETTER YOU RECEIVED FROM
SAN MATEO COUNTY- LESLIE-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WRONGLY
DENIED HER APPLICATION FOR
ACCESS THE RAFT. FOR THE FISCAL
YEARS 201-617-2017 EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. IT IS
A REQUIREMENT TO SUBMIT TWO
LETTERS REQUESTING THE FUNDS
RATHER THAN THE ONE LETTER
REQUIRED PREVIOUSLY AND
PERSONNEL TURNOVER IN OUR
FINANCE DEPARTMENT WE MISS THE
NEED FOR A SECOND LETTER. IMAM
QUESTION IS ONLY THREE HUNDRED
AND NINETEEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN DOLLARS BUT
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY FOR A
SMALL COUNTY SUCH AS OUTGOING
OUR CHILD POVERTY RATE IS TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. OUR MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS 78% OF THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE. ALPINE COUNTY
IS REQUESTING THAT ANY CHANGE
THE LEGISLATION SPECIFICALLY
REFUND IS THE. THREE HUNDRED
NINETEEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE TIME FOR YOUR TIME
AND THE WORK THAT YOU DO. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER MODERATOR. MY
NUMBER THIRTY SIX ALAINA HUFFMAN
NUMBER THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU THIS IS CODY
CANADIAN I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR HERE AT THE STUDENT
DEBT CRISIS CENTER BARBECUE
GETTING ABOUT TWO MILLION
SUPPORTERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND I'M CALLING IT A STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PROTECTION INNOVATION TO
CONDUCT. A STUDENT BORROWER
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION PROGRAM-
I WOULD ALSO REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS PURPOSE TOTAL
OF THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT'S BECAUSE I TALKED TO
STUDENT BORROWERS EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND IT'S A PLACE FAR TOO
COMPLEX TOO CONVOLUTED AND
CHANGING EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR
THE AVERAGE FARMER CAN NAVIGATE.
WITHOUT ASSISTANCE AND TO PUT IT
SIMPLY FOR EVERY DOLLAR THAT'S
INVESTED IN OUTREACH EDUCATION
IT'S BEEN NOT ONLY A DOLLAR
RETURN THE STUDENT LOAN BORROWER
BUT IT'S TRANSFORMATIVE IT HAS
THE ABILITY TO. EXCHANGE THE
FINANCE WITH INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILIES BY FINANCIAL
RESULTS. ALL THESE REASONS WE
RESPECT THE OPT FOR THE SPORT AN
INVESTMENT OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TOTAL. YEAH YEAH BUT I
THINK IT'S ABOUT OPPORTUNISTIC.
THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
MY FIFTY NINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DANIEL BRADLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THE FUNCTION ISSUES AT
FIRST WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF OUR MEMBER COUNTY IS AN
APP THAT YOU REJECT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
PROPOSED TRAILER TRAILER FOR
LANGUAGE RELATED TO EXPENSE IN.
SECOND WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED
ADDITIONAL HOME WITH NOTHING.
OKAY THAT'S IS THAT HOW BUT THE
ABILITY TO FINANCE THOUSANDS OF
INTERIM AND PERMANENT HOUSING
UNITS. WE ARE PUSHING THE
PROPOSED ADDITIONAL HOME THE
FINDINGS ARE CURRENTLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAM. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE ADDITIONAL
DETAILS FOR THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS INVESTMENT.
WOULD BE THE PREPARING SITES FOR
INTERIM HOUSING ON. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. MY NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER SPECTRUM HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WOULD BE A DOCTOR USE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- YOU KNOW
THE FACE PERSISTENT- PREFERENCE
FOR DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
DEVELOPMENT HOLDING. OUT HOPE WE
ARE SPECIFICALLY WERE UPFRONT
PAYMENT THAT DOCTOR REVIEWED
PROGRAMS INCLUDE HOMEOWNERSHIP
HOUSING PROGRAM WELL IT IS
VITALLY IMPORTANT THEY CREATE AN
EQUAL PLAYING GROUND FOR ALL
TYPES PROBABLY. THE DOCTOR READS
PROGRAM FUNDED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY FOCUS ON
THOSE OR RENTAL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AMENDMENTS OFF ONE
YOU'RE NOT CONCERNED THANK. YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. NINE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR MINUS
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS OAKLAND I'M CALLING FROM
MARKET STREET YOUTH SERVICES AND
I'M JOINING MY COLLEAGUES FROM
ACROSS THE STATE THE SUPPORT THE
ONGOING FUNDING OF THE HALF A
GRAM WHICH INCLUDES IF I DECIDE
TO USE- AND I URGE YOU CAN
INCREASE THAT MINIMUM THRESHOLD
IS TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. ARE TOO
OFTEN THAT 10% SATISFIED IF YOU
KNOW THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF FUN
WITHOUT ANY CONCERN FOR WHETHER
THAT MAKES SENSE WHAT YOU NEED
IF YOU WERE GOING ON THE STREET.
HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO WE KNOW IT
NEARLY HALF OF. THE HOMELESSNESS
IN OUR CITY EXPERIENCE THAT
ALMOST THE FIRST. WHEN THEY'RE
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE.
FURTHER HUNKY HUSBAND. OUR
LOCAL. AS A MEMBER. PROGRAM THAT
WE CAN APPLY DIRECTLY TO WIN
SURE THAT MORE YOU SPECIFIC
HOUSING STATED. WE ASK YOU TO
FUND THAT- DOESSUPPORT. ACT
CHAMPIONED BY SENATOR WIENER
THAT WOULD DO JUST THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THE LINE IS OPEN FOR MY
NUMBER SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND BODY THIS IS YVONNE
WORKS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH. URGING AND
CALLING TO SUPPORT ONGOING
FOREIGN FUNDS FOR HALF PROGRAM-
WE NEED 25% TO SUPPORT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. THE GREATEST SOLUTION TO
IN AN ENVELOPE CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS IN THE GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS BY ENDING YOU
HOMELESSNESS AND FURTHERMORE
WHEN IT COMES TO HOME KEY WE
NEED OUR NONPROFITS THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT FUNDING AND
THEREFORE WITH THE CHESS GAME-
OF SUPPORT ACT BY SCOTT- FIGURE
SCOTT WIENER. I WOULD LOVE FOR
YOU OKAY GO AHEAD AND SUPPORT
THAT AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
TIME THAT THEY ARE GIVEN US TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THANK.
YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THAT WOULD PROVIDE
QUESTION YOU. ALL RIGHTY WELL
I'LL WITH THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THAT HAS ARRIVED- IN THIS
HEARING ROOM AND WE'VE EXHAUSTED
ALL OF THE FOLKS THAT ARE ON THE
LINE- AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
ANY OTHER MEMBERS- DIETS HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO SAY
SENATOR ROB THE SHAKING HIS HEAD
NO. SO I WANT TO THANK YOU TO
ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENT OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION I ALSO WANT TO
THANK STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK
DURING THIS BUDGET SEASON AS
WELL AS THOSE WHO JOINED US TO
PRESENT AND DEFEND THEIR
PROPOSALS. WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING THE
SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR IS ADJOURNED.
YOU.